Today I'm teaching my brother how to
start day trading with just $4. But
instead of a normal tutorial, I'm
literally walking him through everything
live, [music] setting up his account,
showing him how to actually read the
market, how to grow a small trading
account, just starting with $4, and then
answering every beginner question he has
along the way. That was one of my
questions going back that can resistance
levels become supports like floors.
>> But more importantly, I'm focusing on
what actually matters step by step so he
doesn't get overloaded trying to learn
everything at once. He learns things in
the proper order. I've never made a
video like this before, but if you
follow along, it's going to give you a
much better foundation than most
beginners have, and most beginner
trading videos give you, even my own.
So, let's get my brother and you set up
the right way to become a consistently
profitable and confident trader. So,
like, yeah, this is the trade I took
what, two days ago now, at this point.
And it's like this is basically what I'm
just trying to do every morning is
looking for the market. You know, this
is Eastern time. My charts are always in
Eastern time now. So, it just opens here
at 9:30.
>> Yeah. And then ideally like looking for
I'll just get out of this so it doesn't
you know like this big move down into a
spot where it looks like it's going to
reverse and then looking for you know
cuz that just gives you much more like
room for a trade to play out in your
favor you know and and you can have
small riskreward. I always find trying
to stay with the trend like if you think
it's going to continue down here it's
really hard to understand where like the
riskreward will go. there's not like an
easy target versus here and we'll talk
about later. It's very often you can say
where this move started is where if it
reverses it'll end like so that's super
easy target and easy to figure out your
riskreward and
>> how much room you have in it.
>> Yeah. and and so you can do the math and
everything. And so, you know, it's just
spotting that unhealthy move and then
like kind of looking for a bottoming
pattern that we'll get into a little bit
later. And then just kind of trying to
like ride it out and manage it. And you
know, I I don't want to get too into
like entry and managing, but just kind
of like this is trying to repeat this
consistently every day and and looking
for just this one thing has made it like
super simple for me and a ton of other
people in just being able to master one
thing versus trying to
>> Yeah. do it consistently.
>> Yeah. Get bogged down in so many
different styles and everything.
>> Yeah.
>> And and so this is pretty much where it
got knocked out. And this was way longer
than normal. Usually on my trades are
like 20 minutes, but I think this yellow
line, I think I drew that later. But
just to look at the target, I guess like
6,965
is
>> that number on the side, that's ticks.
>> The points, I guess. Yeah. Mainly
points. Ticks would be the the main
>> the little sub ones. Okay.
>> Yeah. Between like this 0.25, that's a
tick.
>> Got it. And those are always in 0.25s.
>> Yeah. For for the ES. Uh but so you know
I want to try and like figure out and
teach you like the best way to approach
this in a methodical way that you can
slowly build up. [laughter]
>> Huh.
>> That I can reproduce.
>> Yeah. and that you can like slowly cuz I
think there's so many ways to get
distracted and and trying to focus on
the key pillars of what makes a
profitable trader and it's easy to get
bogged down in the like the candlesticks
and stuff and and try and enter and and
manage a trade perfectly when there's
really like the first most important
thing is just looking like for this
first week I think the best thing for
you to do is we can just start to teach
you and you can practice literally just
looking at like major trad trends in the
market because the like final entry of
where you jump in doesn't really matter
if you can't pick the general thesis
that it's going to reverse here. You
know, if you're wrong about that, you
could enter in here and it could be
great, but it could just reverse at some
point and continue lower going lower.
And that's like understanding the big
picture.
>> Yeah. One of the one of the notes I took
from going through your course earlier
this week was like you're talking about
one minute versus five minute charts and
how the five-minute chart really just
like reduces a lot of the noise. It's
like if you're looking at it too
closely, you're going to get too much
noise.
>> Yeah.
>> I thought that was helpful for trying to
like identify the larger patterns or
moves.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, definitely use that
and look at that in a second. I mean, I
think even like here like this kind of
noise here could get you in trouble. And
there's definitely other times like in
choppier markets where you can start
looking at it too much and and get
sucked in and think it's something could
happen and really it's just you should
stay out which is why like yeah going to
the bigger trends can be helpful.
>> Yeah. I have a question on the first 30
minutes I guess. So one of the things
you were talking about earlier was an
unhealthy move and I'm wondering how
much in the first 30 minutes is that an
unhealthy move or just the market
figuring out what it's doing? because I
know you talk a lot about 30 minutes
after opening, so at 10:00 a.m. roughly,
it makes a change in momentum or trend.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I'm wondering how much of it is
like that first 30 minutes here. Is that
unhealthy or just the market figuring
out what it's doing and then it
reverses?
>> I mean, I think what we're going to go
over later is like will help with that
is okay.
>> Is how to like identify okay, what is
how do you tell the difference between
this being a healthy trend or a strong
trend? Yeah,
>> that it's, you know, it's going to fail
in reverse here versus continue to go
down. And obviously, like you can't
predict that every time, but there's
definitely like good signals and reasons
to be able to try and predict that. Like
the other important thing of this first
week is like just getting used to the
schedule.
>> Yeah.
>> Just getting used to the schedule of I
kind of wrote it down here a little bit
of like opening your charts like 15
minutes before the market, which would
be, you know, 9:15 Eastern Standard
Time. So then in those first 15 minutes,
it gives you time to kind of just look
at, you know, the major swings of the
market, like what's going on kind of
thing of seeing like, okay, what
overnight or in the past like day has
the market, you know, if it's Monday,
like in the past weekend, like what has
the market done? And so like where do I
see kind of the main levels and moves
that have happened? So I can look at
kind of the big big picture going into
the day. So you can kind of figure out
that bias. And then as well, I like to
where's this chart at? This will work.
Drawing those major swings. And then
going into I'll just because it's the
weekend right now, but go into when the
market's going to open. I like to draw
vertical lines at just the 15 minutes
after the open and like the the 30
minutes after the open. So 9:45 and 10
a.m. because those are key news times
where the market will do something a lot
of the time. And just like so it it
allows you to again like put like a v
easy visual thing on the chart that'll
as you watch like you know the
candlesticks come up into that area you
can say okay it's hitting this I can
kind of like I know that's a spot where
something could potentially happen
>> more likely to do something there.
>> Yeah. I I find that it really helps me
like stay more focused on, you know, the
strategy you're trying to execute versus
just reacting to the market because
that's such an easy thing to get into of
just like reacting to the market versus
waiting for it to come to you.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah.
>> Yeah. And then and then the idea is
you're probably going to be at the
charts for like an hour at least, like
until, you know, 10:15 Eastern, just
because that gets it to that 10:00 a.m.
time, you know, where that it's likely
to do something. And then a lot of times
either the move will happen or you just
won't have a good read on the market or
it just won't be a good market. Yeah.
>> And I like to then just kind of be done
with trading for the day cuz you've come
in, you've looked for, you know, your
specific strategy and that time window
of opportunity and then if it doesn't
show up, the idea is just moving on for
the day versus trying to stick around
and like force something to happen. Do
you ever look at it like two hours later
just to see if it's like similar to
looking at it at like I guess what it be
6:15 my time. So 9:15 like 15 minutes
before the open. Just look at it like a
couple hours later just to see if it's
changing or resetting up or like market
behaviors.
>> The other like last main reversal time I
would say is 11 a.m. Eastern. So, you
could, you know, some if something
doesn't happen at 10:00 a.m., you could,
you know, be done at 10:15, go like for
a walk with your dog for like 45
minutes. Yeah.
>> Come back, you know, get some food or
whatever. Take a break basically with
the idea that I'm going to take a break.
>> Reset my brain.
>> Yeah. Reset your brain so you're not
just staring at the charts and getting
impatient and more likely to just do
something stupid. But, you know, then
you come back and you, you know, you're
following your plan of like, okay, I'm
gonna, I'm just going to see has the
market, yeah, like you're saying, has
it, you know, come up to somewhere at,
you know, 11, which would be all the way
here. And it's like, okay, has it done
something? Because that's, you know, an
hour of time a lot can happen.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's just the other time where
I've noticed that it can kind of top out
and reverse or or change. And then after
that, like I mean, you know, there's
people that trade all day, but I always
find that it's easier to trade for
shorter amount of times because you can
kind of be laser focused and you're not
going to overdo it. And you know, like
you say,
>> burn out.
>> Yeah. Cuz it's it seems a lot really
easy to think about it, but then when
you're actually doing it, there's just
so many micro decisions you're
constantly making that it's just super
draining. And even just the micro
decisions to stay out and do nothing is
still very draining. Yeah.
>> And I think another thing about that
first week is I guess this is like
working on not actually
>> doing anything while you're trading.
Yeah. Like
>> not like going and doing, you know, I
don't know, looking at something else on
our screen like either like I like I
used to, you know, play video games,
watch YouTube, or even like do some work
related thing. And there were so many
times where I'd look back at the chart
and I would have missed something or I
would yeah
>> think I was about to miss something and
do an impulsive trade because it's so
much easier to FOMO and think you're oh
I just this massive candle just popped
up and I'm going to miss something
because you're not really thinking out
the market and thinking oh that if I see
a big candlestick here I think it's a
bait or something.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And you know there's I still like
what I do is like I well I think trading
like a short amount of time makes that
easier but then also like listening to
music or like trying to find that fine
line between something that kind of
keeps you occupied but your brain can
still be thinking about the charts in a
way.
>> Yeah. like either music or like
stretching or doing push-ups or
something versus like, you know, and I
stand at my desk, you know, I think
sitting is way easier to kind of just
get kind of just like sluggish and not
engaged.
>> That makes sense.
>> Yeah. Any like questions on like
schedule or any of that kind of stuff?
>> I don't think so. It definitely will be
the like hardest initial hurdle for me.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah,
>> cuz being on the West Coast and not
being a fully committed morning morning
person. Uh, [laughter]
>> but no, I mean it's something I've
known. It's something I like I would
like to wake up earlier anyways. So,
this just gives me a better reason to
wake up rather than just waking up for
the sake of waking up.
>> Yeah. Oh, go ahead.
>> Yeah. No, no initial questions on like
scheduling or schedule. I don't know
like a rough time but like I think you
know I think this depends for every
person but like waking up with enough
time to wake up before trading so it's
like I had to struggle on the West Coast
too with like okay if you wake up an
hour before market that's 5:30 that
blows.
>> Yeah.
>> Like in an ideal world going and doing
like a workout before trading just to
get your blood really flowing would be
sick. But
>> 10 minutes kind of thrusters.
>> I mean honestly like I definitely think
it's ideal like I've even done here of
like going for a run for like just a
mile.
>> Yeah.
>> Just something to get your blood going
and get you kind of awake. And you know
sometimes I don't do that either. Like I
just kind of get up but like giving
yourself at least like I think 30 to 45
minutes before the market opens is
ideal.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just to fully wake up.
>> Yeah. And of course that's kind of like
person dependent. Yeah. I think we can
do next is try and just get charts set
up and like talk about charts and talk
about trends and like what what you
should try and be focusing on and
reading in the first week or two.
>> Getting it set up would be super good
cuz I followed along a little bit with
one of your tutorials, but then I was
like, this seems far ahead from what I
should be doing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, we can totally go
through just like a a simple one. Do you
have the link for or do you have like an
account already set up? I have an
account already set up
>> and we're just going to use Ninja Trader
for anyone else that wants to use what
we're using too. I'll just leave a link
for in this description below and we're
technically going to be trading futures,
but honestly like we're not even going
to talk about that in the first week or
two cuz I think you don't even, you
know, it's like charts are charts. Like
you can use this kind of stuff on
anything. You don't need to, you know,
really get into the nitty-gritty. Again,
it's it's trying to focus on the big
picture first. I'll try. Do you want me
to share my screen or
>> I'm assuming you just have a blank
slate, right? Like you just have this
window cuz I can just you can just
follow along and I can just do it which
will probably work too.
>> Okay, I see which window that is. I have
that window pops up and then like four
[snorts] other little charts pop up
every time.
>> Okay, I think you can try and close
those out.
>> Okay,
>> let's see. try and I think do close
those out and go to workspaces here and
click new
>> workspaces
>> because I think this will help like set
up
>> okay yeah what should I call it
>> I don't know whatever you want cuz
that'll I think that just that might
actually reset everything and make it
like a new workspace and all you need to
do is just go to new up here and then
chart
>> and that kind of like pulls up this
window and then there should be a
drop-own menu here I don't think you'll
have these so you want to go to futures
And then you can just go to ES and it
should have a number next to it. That's
just like the expiration month.
>> Okay. Yeah, I have ES December 25.
>> Okay. You can you can just click that
and then you can always just like write
in you can just delete this and write in
03. Maybe not here. Oh yeah, it does
work. Yeah, you can just literally just
type it in. Usually normally like Ninja
Trader will give you a prompt to
automatically roll over so you don't
really have to think about it cuz you
know it'll it'll expire and go on to
next a different contract number.
>> Okay. I have ES December 25. Which did
you rename?
>> I literally just clicked on this box
right here and just deleted it and typed
in ES03-26
and press enter.
>> When I do that, I get a little weird
data is delayed box next to it. Oh, it's
cuz you your free trial ran out. I think
this ran out.
>> Probably if you made your account like,
you know, weeks or months ago.
>> I opened this under sim.
>> I don't I don't Well, with your delayed
data, I don't know why it would
>> I think some of it said it was
>> I don't know how that works.
>> There's like a 15minute data delay.
>> Like that should be fine. You should
still be able to select this correct
instrument though. Do all these say 12
instead of three?
>> If I go to futures. Are they all 1220 or
1225?
>> Uh ZW,
ZN, ZB, those are all 26. GC is 26. CL
20 Jan 26. My ES is December 25, though.
>> What about your NQ?
>> NQ December 20. Same thing.
>> I mean, maybe you just have to go get
data. I mean, you're going to have to do
it at some point anyway.
>> Yeah.
>> So, just go to ninjatrader.com and log
in.
>> What if I told you I don't see that?
Okay. Go up here. Go to settings. I was
just in the Yeah, it had the old file
and then it said open [laughter] legacy.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. It looked a
little funny actually. Yeah. So, go to
settings first and then you'll see up
here and Okay. And then you probably
won't see all this cuz this is mine set
up.
>> Oh, I have market data. It says CNB
bundle level one status inactive.
>> Well, how much does it say it is?
>> That one's $12 per month. I also just
have account plan. You should be able to
Yeah. If you find like the subscription,
you should be able to um do Can you get
to this page when you click like manage
subscription?
>> That's for market data subscription.
Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I have an update
subscription, but it should be some kind
of like market data subscription.
>> Yeah. It looks like I just subscribe to
it.
>> Yeah. But then it gives these. Go click
here. Go to just the customize drop down
here and it puts all this cuz then you
can you should be able to Yeah. You
should be able to just do this one. CME
for $4 per month. Let me just double
check. I always get these mixed up.
Yeah. So, this has the ES and the NASDAQ
and I don't think it has if other people
are like wanting to trade gold and oil
and stuff, you're going to have to do I
think Comix. I think this has Yeah, this
has gold, silver, all your like
minerals. And then oil actually might be
in a different one. So, if you just
Yeah, like it's it's if you need to do
all these, like I'm subscribed to just
this one for 12 a month that just all of
them, but if you're just like like for
you now, like it's better to just start
on
>> Yeah, that sounds like a problem for
later.
>> Yeah. Like it's better to just focus on
just like the ES and the NASDAQ. And I
think I've slowly over time just doing
like I'm just doing that because it's
just again simpler is always better. So
like you can easily just $4 a month is
super cheap for data. A lot of places
charge you more.
>> Oh, I just want ES, right? ES March 26.
>> Yeah. So, you got this finally. It says
now that you updated it, you can just
see this is all like 03.
>> You charge us 26. Okay.
>> Cuz if not, another thing to do if it
you can go to tools here and go to
database management under tools. Just
database management. It's like the third
one. And you can click this rollover
button. If there's some that are like
not updated, generally like it'll
automatically do it. And so you won't
really have to do this, but if you ever
like need to, it's an easy way to do it.
>> Okay. I have opened a chart. Um
>> Oh, you weren't supposed to open a chart
yet.
>> I've closed a chart. [laughter]
>> There's still some stuff over here. We
have
>> Wait, I don't see Where do I see that
now?
>> What?
>> That screen. So, if I hit If I Okay, if
I go to my workspace and hit my I named
it Trading with Riley. by How do I get
to that screen that you're on?
>> This one. It should just You're going to
have to go down to like on your tabs cuz
it's a different window.
>> Okay. It's different.
>> Oh, you're under you're under accounts.
Okay, gotcha. Okay, I'm there.
>> Oh, I mean like Yeah, this doesn't
really matter. Like you can just It's
just the the top things are the same.
That's all you really need. Okay. Yeah.
So, we're here. We have this selected.
And this is like how you open a chart
generally. Generally, it's like this is
just like it's a minute chart. And then
>> I'm sorry. I'm gonna be
>> what?
>> Oh, you're just under data series.
>> Do you What are you looking?
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah, I know. I see what
you're talking about. Okay, I'm there.
>> I guess first it's like you can we can
do like a 15. Change the value to 15.
So, it's a 15minute chart.
>> Yeah.
>> And then days to load. I like to just do
50.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I think just this should
automatically say does this
automatically say use instrument
settings?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I like to click break at end of
day. That little toggle button below it.
If that's not
>> Yeah.
>> You have to kind of tell me if these are
different. I don't know. bar width. I
think that's probably normal. And then
the colors I changed to basically have
up bars be white and down bars be blue
versus and then the outline of the
bodies. I think you might have to change
that too. Just a simple like white or
something. And the idea with having
them, you know, a different colors,
those are a lot more calming. Like
having red and and green candlesticks is
very emotionally triggering. It just
yeah helps keep it to where it's like
it's you know just red and green are
just very emotional colors and so
reducing as much triggering input as
possible really helps and I think that
should be it other stuff like it's just
yeah we can so you can just press okay
and that should open up a chart like
this.
>> Yeah, mine looks the same.
>> Okay, you need to rightclick just
anywhere on the chart and pull up
properties.
>> Yep. And then so just like there's not
too much on here, but like right side
margin is how much space there is right
here between the Yeah. the chart. So
like if you want more space there, it's
kind of just personal preference like
visually you can change this. So it's
like it automatically forces a lot of
space to to be on the right side. I
usually have it at like I don't know 300
400. Again, that's some like preference
you can kind of change over time, but
300 is like a good just visually having
a little space there is kind of nice.
And I think the other main things is
just these grid lines. You can open
these up and just make them visible.
Just kind of helps when you're looking
at the chart. And we'll have one more
setting that will that'll help add to
this. Then we know when you got that
done. And you might have to I I don't
know if your colors are the same, but
I've always kind of made them, you know,
it's again preference of like not having
them stand out too much. Yeah, mine are
slightly different color, but that's
fine for now.
>> Okay, I think that's everything there.
Last thing for grid lines is see this
button up here. It's called chart
trader.
>> Yep.
>> Toggle that on. Do the middle option.
>> Is that like center it? No,
>> it'll it'll pull up the side panel.
>> I look like I have more Let's see.
Vertical lines. I look like I have two
to one.
>> Well,
>> or you just weren't zoomed in very much.
>> They just adjust. Yeah, they're like on
scaling.
>> Okay.
>> Once you have this up, you want to right
click on it.
>> Yeah. and then properties. Yeah. And
then go to I guess we'll do this now.
Some of this will be pertinent to later.
Oh, I actually don't know. Yeah, I think
you want this one set to here. We'll
double check that probably when we get
more closer to trading, but then I think
this should just be I think just this
makes sense as default settings for
this. Just having this on on points
versus like money or anything makes it
so you're kind of just focusing.
>> Yeah. You're not paying attention to the
dollar amount.
>> Yeah. And then like having this off too.
This will show how much you're up and
down. Like it it changes this to be, you
know, zero or or up or down money. You
also don't need that. And then here's
like later you can change a bunch of
this stuff, but it's mainly personal
preference. Right click the axis and
properties. Oh, I see. We didn't even
need to go to this. I'm just going to
turn that off. Yeah, you can turn this
off. I might just cut that whole section
out. We don't need that right now.
>> Especially because we left everything as
default.
>> I know. I was like, "Wait, [laughter]
what?"
>> So, all right. Next up, we go to this
part and we leave everything default.
[laughter]
>> We also won't need it until you start
trading.
>> I thought this setting was in there that
we're looking for. [laughter]
>> Okay, last thing for the grid lines. Go
right click on your axis, Yaxis, and
then go to properties and then change
this the horizontal grid lines here. So
change it to fixed and then just leave
it at points and one point. And so what
that does is it puts a horizontal line
every point. And so it allows you to
really visually easily see the velocity
of the market. Like if you if I just
like scroll to the side right here and
zoom in.
>> Yeah. It gives you a fixed point of
reference rather than
>> as we were talking about earlier where
it was scaling all the time.
>> Yeah. Like here it's like you can see
the lines are a lot closer. So you can
tell that the market's moving a lot
faster versus I mean like here it's
moving it's there's been a ton of
volatility recently but like if I zoomed
in here you can tell okay it's not
moving that fast.
>> Yeah.
>> And then that should be so this will be
the idea is this is your 15minute chart
that you open up. This is kind of the
first thing you're looking at every
morning and you're coming in here and
saying, "Okay, I am going to, you know,
look for my my major support and
resistance zones that we'll talk about
in a second, too." And like any like
trend lines that I see going on, stuff
like that. So, this is like your
15-minute chart. And so, what you can
do, what I like to do is down here in
the like super bottom left, the little
tab right here.
>> Yeah.
>> You can rightclick it and just rename
it. When you right click, you And then
where is the name? Oh, tab name. And
then I I just like to say 15 minute
chart. Actually, I usually do ES because
it's the E. We're looking at ES right
now. And then just 15 minute chart
because then that'll then once you have
all these charts up, you can easily find
them when you're trying to go through
your windows and tabbing through them.
>> Yeah.
>> And then once you got that, right click
on it again and do duplicate a new tab.
And then that'll completely keep all
your settings. And then you can just go
up to the top left and change it to or
you can just honestly just type in here,
type in NQ and it'll do it and it'll
pull up the NASDAQ.
>> Should I be looking at the NASDAQ at all
to start? I know you're talking about
how one of them slightly follows the
other, but I think it was the NASDAQ is
more volatile. I think it was NASDAQ
follows ES to some extent, but is more
volatile or changes in some way. Yeah.
No, I think it's okay to I think it's
good to look at both. I think the idea
is you could focus on just only when we
get down to it only trading the ES, but
I think a good confirmation that I use a
lot of the time is are the NASDAQ and
the ES aligned? Because if they're kind
of moving similarly, they're more likely
to be easy to read, easy to predict, and
easy to kind of like actually do a
successful trade versus sometimes you'll
have the NASDAQ kind of doing some crazy
move up and the ES will be just kind of
chopping. And I've realized over time
like you don't want to be trading when
they're kind of each other. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, just kind of like another
indicator to be like, all right,
everything is moving in the same
direction.
>> Yeah, it's it's Yeah, it's a really good
indicator for that. Um, last thing is
just right clicking on this and renaming
it.
>> Yeah, I did.
>> Okay. Yeah, just to NASDAQ. You could
just do NQ or you could say NASDAQ.
Whatever your preference is. And then
and then we just need to Yeah, go ahead.
>> Really? This is a dumb question. How do
I get the background lines to be more
opaque?
>> You should be able to just go to
rightclick and properties and then the
grid line. Mine are just a dark color.
That's why it's like, you know, versus
if you have like a full white
>> maybe. Yeah, mine's a silver.
>> That's horrible.
>> Yeah, like usually their like default
background like back I think mine has
background medium or something. It's
pretty good. And you could also make
your chart background like darker. I
think a big thing is some of those
colors get changed in
>> Oh, I don't have all the dim gray.
>> Yeah, if you go let me see. I think if
you go to go to your Can you come to
here again? Go to tools. Just the normal
>> can do that. Yeah, just pull up the
normal Ninja Trader window. And if you
go to settings,
>> tool settings. Yep.
>> And then on general, just right here at
the bottom of this page, you don't have
to scroll down. Mine's on Ninja Trader.
>> Okay. Ninja Trader Dark. Okay.
>> Is yours What's yours not?
>> It was just on regular Ninja Trader.
>> Okay. So, that's how you Yeah, you get
darker colors. You will have to restart
to make that change,
>> but that'll probably just make your
charts like much darker.
>> Yeah. If you don't do that, dim gray
also works really well.
>> Okay. Okay. So, these are like big
picture charts that we're like I I
really just look at these like initially
and then as I'm trading I'm really just
looking at like a five minute and a one
minute which we'll we can make in a
next. So, I I just go right click again
at these tabs down here and go duplicate
a new window, not new tab.
>> Oh, okay. Fancy.
>> And then all we do is just change this
the 15 minute up here. this dropdown.
Just change it to a one minute. And then
change the name. Just take out the five.
Change it to a one minute. And then we
also want to turn on the chart trader up
here.
>> One second. I was busy jumping ahead and
making one for ES.
>> Oh, I mean I can do that too.
>> Okay. What do I What do we need to do?
>> Say change it to 1 minute.
>> Yeah, I did that.
>> And then just open the chart trader.
>> Chart trader. Okay.
>> And then you could you can make it full
screen, whatever works. I'm just going
to keep it a little smaller because it's
easier for me right now. Yeah. And then
just duplicate in new tab. And we'll
actually change this to a five minute.
>> Okay.
>> Change it to a five minute. And then
rename just put the five in there. I
like to do it this way to where it
depends totally on how many monitors you
have and what like your setup is. But
often I'll have and then well just
before I get to that, I'll duplicate
this again and duplicate like duplicate
the one minute and the five minute again
and then change these to NASDAQ. So then
basically you have a one minute of the
NASDAQ, a one minute of the ES, and then
a five minute of them as well. And so
it's all on one window. Oh, I've messed
that up. So you can easily just look
through them on one kind of tab on one
screen. So really, it's like, okay, I'm
going to be trading this one window on
the this is like where I enter. The one
minute is where I enter. And then I can
confirm on the five minute of kind of
like what's the the more medium picture
looking like. It kind of helped drown
out the noise. And then you can also do
the same thing with the NASDAQ one
minute and the five minute to help
control kind of what you're seeing.
>> Okay.
>> All set.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I have my six different
tabs.
>> Yeah. And like your two windows and then
it's really easy to like on Windows at
least is like to mouse over and be like,
"Okay, I want to pull up my one minute
or 15 minute." Like if you're on a one
single monitor or if like you get lost,
like usually I have a couple other ones
open. Like the other one I'll have
sometimes open when I'm trading is, you
know, I'll have main ES one minute chart
on my main screen and then I'll have if
I just duplicate a NASDAQ one minute,
I'll have this also kind of smaller on
another monitor just to like when you're
really trading and like entering in, I
can be like watching each little
candlestick develop and see like, okay,
is that aligning up with what I'm seeing
for like, you know, confirmation on
They're both moving in the same
direction.
>> Yeah. When you really get down to the
nitty-gritty, but again, like, you know,
we can talk we'll talk more about that
later.
>> That sounds like next week's problem.
>> Yeah. Or a couple weeks problem.
>> Or a couple weeks problem. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Cuz that's definitely like a
little more advanced. So, and I mean
like you don't technically you don't
need if you don't want you can turn off
the chart traders for any of these
windows.
>> Okay. What is the chart trader? It's
like when you're actually trading and
we'll get down to that. When you're
trading, it's like it's how you
>> enter. Okay. Yeah, I see quantity
>> and it also brings up like these lines
on the chart. Like it brings these up
and so it allows you to like actively
manage on the chart.
>> Aren't those specifically are Oh, are
those your plugin or your indicator or
are those the base ones and then your
riskreward is the
>> No, these are the base ones.
>> Okay. you know. Yeah. Like my my add-ons
I have that like the two main ones that
I use are like this click trader that
pulls up to here and then it allows me
to just like I can't really do it right
now and we'll get to it later but allows
like to like with with literally a click
of a mouse like enter in an order.
>> Yeah,
>> it's kind of spazzing out because the
market is right [laughter] now
>> and it's broken.
>> And it's broken.
>> Yeah, that sounds like it'll be good to
go through later on.
>> I might have to start restart my
platform. Oh, there we go. It kind of
the market's closed right now so it kind
of spazzes it out. Yeah. And then then
this risk reward tool. Yeah. We'll
definitely go into that when we like
talk more about entry.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Those are super important.
>> Yeah. Because they look very helpful and
I would like to use them.
>> Yeah. So with I guess Yeah. Like so
>> can you hear Tucker?
>> Not really.
>> Okay.
>> I heard it's going off.
>> So now we're all like set up. I This is
kind of personal preference too actually
is you can right click on the chart for
properties and just change the font
size. Like I would say this is kind of
small, but again it's personal
preference of like how big your screen
is and like what your I also kind of
have it big just for like recording
purposes.
>> Where did you click?
>> Just right click anywhere on the chart
and go to properties.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. Oh, I don't I don't see
that as something I can change.
>> It's like this little
>> Oh, I see. I see. I see.
>> It's a little confusing. It doesn't look
like something's there. Yeah.
>> What does that change the numbers on the
side?
>> Yeah. And then when you're like in a
trade, it's those profit numbers. No, I
just lost my train thought.
>> How to draw trends.
>> Yeah, I guess so.
>> Or is there any more setup we need to
initially do?
>> No, I think we can get into like Yeah.
your your your basics. Let's pull up the
15-minute chart and just try and go like
kind of more methodically of like, you
know, the first thing you're going to do
is like be looking at the big picture,
right? And so I guess another setup
thing for that is you can pull this up
by just right clicking on the chart and
seeing drawing tools right here. Yeah,
>> it'll pull up all your drawing tools.
There's also a button up here, this
little pencil at the top left. And I
like to just use hotkeys because it's
super easy. And so if you go pull up the
main control window again, you can go to
tools and go to hotkeys.
>> Okay. Main control window. Tools.
Hotkeys. Yep.
>> And then yeah, you just the first one
will be chart and then scroll all the
way down really cuz that's where at
least down to where you see drawings
halfway down.
>> Yep.
>> Let's see. We want to go to It's kind of
hard to There's only a couple I use. I
think line right here. I have You just
click on it and then it and then click
the button you want. I like F2. You
can't do F1 because that's like the
Ninja Trader hotkey button. If you press
F1 on any window, any like thing you
have selected, it'll literally
automatically bring up like a Ninja
Trader like help window of like that
section. So like that's kind of helpful
for certain things. But so yeah, F2 for
that and then rectangle I have this F3.
That's how I draw my like support and
resistance zones.
>> So it's already in use by chart line. Do
I care about chart line?
>> No, just override what if it says like
it's in use by something else.
>> Oh yeah, that was dumb. It was also ray.
Okay. And then so and then vertical line
all the way at the bottom. I do F6.
Again, like you can change these to what
makes more sense later. And then you
probably won't have this, but maybe you
have it as just the normal riskreward,
but when we get you set up with that,
you'll want to come in and change that
as F4. So maybe I don't know if I don't
know what you have right there right
now, but when you get the risk
indicator,
>> how far down was that?
>> All the way at the bottom.
>> Yeah, I don't have that. Mine adds find
text.
>> Okay. Yeah. I mean other stuff you come
in later or whatever drawing tools you
think you want, but like those are like
really the main ones are like yeah like
the vertical line is how is how like you
know that F6 is how I just come in in
the morning and say okay I want a line
you know to mark those key times in the
market.
>> Okay. And then I imagine I can change
colors in something somewhere.
>> Yeah, we'll go we'll go through that
stuff in a second. So do your like pull
up a rectangle.
>> Yeah, that is F. Wait, wait. Uh before
we do that
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
>> How do I properly move this chart
around?
>> Oh, good thing you're here. Otherwise, I
don't know to tell that. Um,
okay. So, basically, you just click and
move.
>> Yeah. Which also seems like it's middle
scroll wheel.
>> It's Yeah, that seems really inefficient
for me.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> obviously,
>> but it is like locked. And so, if you
always if you scroll too far to the
side, this arrow at the top right will
pop up. You can click that and it will
always like reenter your part to that
side. Um, and if you hold control um,
and click anywhere, you can just it it
unlocks it. And then so if you go way
off the chart, this little F pops up at
the top right and then you click that
and then click the arrow and it will
totally like reset it. And then the same
thing with these, you can click and drag
the axis and you can click control and
drag just to like move it without like
scaling it. And again like you can reset
it by clicking the F button.
>> Okay. So, is there is there any way do I
have to go over the Oh gosh,
>> you can
>> do I have to go over the right hand side
to
>> to vertically move it
>> to like zoom in and out. I guess
>> um
there might be like No, that's Yeah,
that's pretty much to zoom in and out. I
mean, I or just drag on the chart, but
like generally I would say once you like
have it set up the the way I zoom in and
out is literally just drag the bottom
because it's like that zooms out to give
you more data data. And so just dragging
the bottom will do that because it'll
then fit to the chart, you know, as it
expands to the left.
>> Yeah. Okay. Mine looks ugly. But
>> why does it look ugly? What? What's
wrong?
>> Not being able to zoom is annoying.
>> What do you need to zoom on? Like you
can zoom in by just dragging to the
right will zoom in or drag, you know,
drag to like pull the chart.
>> Yeah, I think it's really just
>> getting used to it or
>> getting used to it.
>> Okay. Yeah, because pretty much I think
all I do to zoom is just drag the bottom
axis.
>> Drag the bottom and top.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't think I even touch
the right side really. Yeah, it it it
auto adjusts to that.
>> Wait, mine's not auto adjusting.
>> Oh, that's awkward. Did you And you The
F is clicked.
>> The F is
No, the F was not clicked. I was looking
at the little arrow thing and thought
that's what you were talking about.
Okay. Okay, we're good. That seems so
much more natural. [laughter]
>> Okay. Yeah, it's not like my chart
doesn't work. I
>> What are you talking about, Riley?
>> This looks [laughter] so ugly. That
makes way more sense.
>> Okay. F is your like F is essentially
recenter.
>> Yeah. F is recenter and the arrow is re
like get back.
>> Okay.
>> And it does the same if you drag to the
left. Like you go, you know, reset to
the right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Ready for drawings?
>> Yeah. Ready for drawings.
>> Okay. So, F3 to, you know, you F3 and
then you click and then you don't need
to hold. It's just it's just a toggle.
So you click, drag, and then click again
to like finish it.
>> Yeah.
>> And then double click on it to pull up
properties. You can also right click,
but I find double clicking easier. Um,
and then this is where you can change
the settings. I just, you know, whatever
color you want. I like cyan for some
reason. And then to make it feel like a
box with strong edges is you just make
the opacity 10%. And then you just have
to make sure you click this outline
button to match the color if you want
the color to be the same. Um, and I just
keep it the same color for a support or
resistance zone because really I'm just,
you know, the idea is like this is an
area where I see it reversing and it's
easy enough to be like, oh, I see it
reversing, you know, what direction. And
then you might, you can increase this
width number to increase the like line
around the box, a solid line, but like I
find two is fine. One, you can even go
one if you want like a little more.
>> Yeah, I just left mine on two.
>> And then click this template button at
the bottom and then click save and click
save as default. So, every time you
click that hotkey and pull it up, it'll
just be those settings.
>> Oh, okay.
>> I kind of like the I'm gonna go with the
the one width for for a while. See what
that feels like. Um, and then same thing
with your line tool. F2. Same thing.
Just double click on it. Um, I just have
the the line width of two pixels. I have
it yellow. Same thing. Go to template
and then just do save. Save as default.
>> Oh, save as default. Okay. Uh, let me
>> Are you saving it as my template?
>> The first one I definitely just hit save
and then um save as default. Save as
default. Okay, I named it default.
>> There's a button.
>> Yeah, I did read. [laughter]
>> And then I think honestly that's kind of
like I guess you could do F6 and just
click for your vertical line.
>> Yeah. And just do that while we're doing
it.
>> And just I mean my I don't know what the
default is, but I just do red
>> vertical line. I'm going to swap mine to
width at one and then just save as
default. And then to just get rid of any
of them, you just click on it. Click
delete button.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Um
Oh, right click on the chart and then go
to crosshair and then do local.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I this it's way easier to see where your
mouse is and also just like see I don't
know match it with what the x-axis
>> Yeah. It let you kind
>> you could do a kind of a quick
resistance level or something.
>> Yeah. Um Okay. Oh, last thing is go to
your control window and then just go to
workspace and highlight over whatever
you named it. Like mine is new setup and
just do save. I think that'll that'll
make sure you saved everything we just
set up. So then it should theoretically
always and then when you exit this, I
think when you exit every time it'll say
save workspace and I always say yes
because then it will save like all your
drawings and stuff.
>> You've done any changes or anything? Oh,
okay. Okay. Any changes or any drawings,
it'll just keep those.
>> So you don't have to like restart every
day. Yeah. Kind of like keep some of the
stuff in. Okay.
>> Yeah. Or just have whatever your Yeah.
And then you can always right click and
go to drawings and literally just remove
all drawing objects if you just want to
like get everything out, which is
sometimes works too cuz sometimes I'll
um have too much stuff on the screen.
Oh, I guess the last thing I actually
forgot about pull up your rectangles and
then this attach to I don't know if you
noticed that this was different. This
allows you to do it. So it if you click
on all charts, it'll automatically so
it's up on this chart and now if you
pull up your one minute chart of the ES
>> Oh, it'll also be there. Okay.
>> Or here is a five minute. It'll find it
easier. It's automatically on that
chart. So that's how like you can easily
do that. So, I I have that for my my big
rectangles, but I don't have it for like
my trend lines all the time. I think I
actually do by default. Yeah. But
sometimes like if maybe you have a big
trend line on your, you know, 15-inute
chart, but then you go on a one minute
chart and, you know, you draw like a a
really small trend line. Well, it's kind
of annoying if that shows up on your,
you know,
>> it looks like just a random little tiny
line. Yeah. So, you can go in and say,
"Okay, well, I want this personally one
to just be like on a one minute and then
it doesn't show."
>> Okay. And then I imagine for when you
make those changes every time, you just
need to go template save as default or
just save.
>> Um, if you want it to always be Yeah. If
you want something to always be there,
you always have to resave it as default.
>> Okay.
>> Um, I guess also because we we goofed up
and I didn't do this in the beginning,
you're going to have to go in and change
all your crosshairs on these ones to
local. you'll eventually like it it'll
be easy to do either like right now or
just
>> do I have to save in some fashion for
that or is it just good to go?
>> You can go to workspace again and just
click save.
>> Okay.
>> And make sure but again like when you
exit out of the platform
>> it'll prompt me to save.
>> It'll prompt you to save but you know
just to be safe like in case like your
thing crashes or something. Okay. Okay.
So, I guess let's start with like big
picture like support and resistance
first because those are like the most
important things is just like you know
you can see that the market just zooming
out it it's very like back and forth you
know.
>> Yeah.
>> Um especially right now like it's a very
volatile time sometimes. I don't know if
I can scroll far enough back because
we've been in pretty volatile time
recently. it's very volatile and like
because of that for for me in the
mornings I find the best thing is to um
be looking at like the extremes right
like be this is the most recent like
extreme high like if you scroll back
like the market you know topped out here
before it sold off kind of thing like in
the last I don't know what how many days
this is like a month basically um and so
it's like that's something I want to be
aware of and so I'll generally just draw
like a box from the like I'll try and be
very specific specific at the top of the
box at the high and then the bottom is
kind of subjective. Like the idea is I'm
trying to just keep track of okay these
areas like it it bounced here. You could
make a justification for pulling it all
the way down to this one but at some
point like the you know the box gets
pretty big and you you want to try and
like be sticking to the more extremes
because those are where the market's
more likely to reverse because it's kind
of overextended and in that unhealthy
situation.
>> Yeah. And for so for drawing these
you're always kind of starting at the
absolute top that the market reached.
>> Yes. Yeah. Like for your biggest big
picture like okay what is the like even
down here like I would this is where
like having those crosshairs really
comes into play. I would match this
bottom and then pull this up here.
>> Yeah. And it's never it's never like
where it closed in those candlesticks.
It's the farthest point it moved to.
>> Yeah. Because you know in a in a in a
15minute candle it's like that's a lot
of time or even if you picture you just
want to because that's like that's where
price went. That's the extreme price
went. Ideally with extremes like I'm
okay like sometimes taking in one
extreme for a zone but ideally you have
multiple touches. Like my basic rule of
thumb is like you it's nice to have two
you know like if the market was like
trading here having these two I mean
like I would draw the level kind of like
this of like okay well it's hit here
before here and here and so the next
time it comes up here I'm going to
that's that's like where I want to kind
of hone in and be aware of that okay
well it's likely to reverse in this
area. You don't have to think of like,
oh, it's hit the zone perfectly like the
bottom. I bet that it's going to like
reverse right now or I think that it's
going to reverse right now. Or if it's
broken it, that means like it's going to
now, you know, make a big move up. Like
that's it. It can like break out like
this and then fail back in. You know,
it's idea is it's very subjective and
it's very it's a very like loose idea of
like okay in this area and the area
could still even be larger, you know, it
could be up here.
>> Yeah. It's not it's not hard and fast.
It's like a it is more likely and
there's a higher chance that it's going
to do something in this zone.
>> Yeah. The whole idea is just to help
yourself like mark okay where are the
important areas that you need to pay
attention to. And so like even here like
this is the last like couple days. I
like to think about like the the super
extremes and then when I'm zooming in
because usually, you know, like here
it's like, well, I can't wait like it
could take days for the market to get,
you know, to hear um the this super big
high or down here, right? And it's like
there are areas in the middle, but
generally I like to be, you know,
patient with those and think of like,
okay, well, I need again like multiple
touches um for me to think about an
area. So like here it's like okay well
there's clearly like a spot here where
it's like the market keeps failing off
of
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then same down here it's like
okay well we came off this level and
it's like it can find support in the
middle where it's like okay well there
was clearly kind of a spot here where it
broke this high and then in a way like
this is like when you have trends like
it'll hit a spot like this is clearly a
resistance for some reason. sold off,
broke through it, and then it came and
like retested this area basically. And
it's almost like saying like, okay,
well, this area where it was resistance
now essentially like turns into support,
and then it comes and like it tests it
again before it, you know, you moves up.
And you can even say, so this this like
turns into almost like a stairst step
pattern where it can like, you know,
come up, come down, test, and then like
move up again and then, you know, like
it it it won't always follow it, right?
But like it changes how it like you it
moves through stuff. Um
>> yeah, that was one of my questions going
back that can resistance levels become
supports like floors.
>> Yeah. And so I I
>> do you count that as a touch or is it
kind of just a additional thing you like
to see
>> as like this as a touch or this as a
touch?
>> Like um the left two. So where it tested
it, that one and that one. Like if you
didn't see the third one, would you
count those two? Um, I would say no in
the sense of like if you're if you're
like right here because you haven't seen
this yet. This to me feels like again
the bigger thesis is sticking to the
extremes of
>> what the current market conditions are
and obviously like those are always
changing um of where the extremes are as
you know the market moves up and down
you know like and so as the market moves
up here like this was an extreme but as
it breaks up here and then bounces here
now it's here like if you kind of look
at this of like okay this is kind of
like the range it's
This kind of feels more towards the
center. Like I would start to think that
this is more the extreme and down here
is the extreme. And this is kind of
you're getting into the center where
it's a lot harder to be correct about
>> what's going to happen. It's so easy to
get in, you know, where it just starts
chopping or or going back and forth. Um
and so that's why I try and stick away
from that. So, I wouldn't use this as a
level I think until when I was looking
at this like it's this is kind of the
overnight like let's see right like
here's this is the overnight session of
that day and so
>> but like without thinking about that
like yeah I I don't think I'd use this
because at this point I'm starting to
think of this as an extreme and then as
it plays out you know then you you get
to a point where it's like okay now I I
can I have enough information to start
to realize okay what is the new extremes
like that's the hard part about trading
sometimes is you'll be bouncing between
like this was clearly in a range from
like here to here for a couple days and
then it bounces up here and kind of goes
in this range for a couple days. And so
it's about like adjusting identifying,
okay, we're breaking out of this. I
can't bet lower anymore, but now I have
to like almost wait for more data to be
able to find, okay, this is maybe the
new range that we're trading in. Yeah,
that was one of I mean I saw a Discord
comment from the other day that was like
I'm seeing support levels everywhere.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And part of what I was thinking of when
going through one of your lectures was
the like where where are you determining
or like what time frame are you
determining the major support zones on?
Cuz yeah, like as you were talking
about, we had that first one that kind
of hits those three points, but then it
looks like it forms one above it, but is
that still all in the middle of the two
larger ones?
>> Are you talking about this one?
>> Yeah. So, there's like that one and then
there's the second from the top support
level that you drew that one.
>> The resistance level.
>> So, um the one down.
>> Oh, this one.
>> So, there's that one. But is that then
like is that in the middle of the one
below it and the one all the way down?
>> Right. Yeah. So it's it is kind of like
you're looking at the extremes extremes
and then you're kind of because that
that that's kind of like really big
picture.
>> Yeah.
>> And because you know trading on a one
minute chart like that trade we started
with um was literally I bought here and
sold here.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's and you know that was a
plenty of move for a trade, right? And
so it's like you're because you're in
such like a focus and smaller time
frame, you can trade these smaller
extremes and smaller brackets.
>> Yeah. And those larger ones would be
like, "Okay, we're trading overnight."
Like that's a fiveday trade or
something.
>> Yeah. And and I mean like I still would
use these levels to take a trade off of
like getting in here and like you know
catching this up. That would be huge.
Um,
>> but you're not waiting you're not
waiting for your one minute chart to go
all the way back down there.
>> No, I'm definitely like every Yeah,
every day is like once it, you know, I'm
not taking a trade here and like
catching a move because it's, you know,
I needed more time to figure out, okay,
this is actually a level I like.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, because it's there's, you
know, this this level, this bounce, this
bounce, and then this bounce. Yeah.
>> That gave me enough reason to be like,
okay, there's kind of a support level
here.
>> There's something there. Okay. and you
know like a trend line came into play as
well like off of these these two right
here really um and then also like the
the ES chart kind of looked the same and
so um there's you know other things that
we'll talk about that went into that it
takes some time to learn to do that cuz
also then you can go into you know your
five minute chart and sometimes I'll do
the five-minute chart to be looking at
those levels because you can see them um
you know zooming that back out for those
multiple days is kind of hard but like
if the market was opening here. You
know, it's pretty easy to say, okay,
well, there's a nice clean double bottom
here that I could say there's a
potential support here.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> tested it twice.
>> Yeah. And there's kind of a high right
here, you know, and especially Okay.
Well, there's another swing here, so I
can definitely draw kind of a box based
on those. But also, you know, like
you're saying, like you don't want to
over complicate things. Sometimes it's
like without trying to just say like,
oh, this like this kind of comes with
experience of like trying to figure out
um and and reading the levels of like,
okay, now it's like this level maybe
isn't as good anymore or like, you know,
based on what's like you can start to
understand when a level is like a really
solid level and when it's starting to
like it's not very strong or something.
And I think just going through examples
and stuff, we'll we'll pull out why
that's the case.
>> For this one here, that second two
points where it's touching,
>> which zone, one, two, or three?
>> Um, where it's touching two, the two
recent ones
>> here.
>> Would that be a good spot? Cuz it looks
like it's doing its whole double bottom
thing. But are you looking for
>> more of a touch or
>> I think you could enter in here. No,
this I think this is totally fine of a
touch if you're saying like, oh, it
barely touched the zone or or kind of
didn't.
>> Yeah. No, I think it's totally fine.
Like again, it's like it's super
subjective. Like you could have drawn
the level like right up here.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, sometimes I'll think, oh, like
sometimes I'll take in like, oh, this is
like a little chop range that it had.
Yeah.
>> So almost like think of this as like a
little box where the market came down
and bottomed
>> kind of consolidated.
>> Yeah. And so take that into account and
draw my box including that.
>> Okay.
>> Um but again, you don't want to get too
crazy like this one up here. I don't
want to take in this whole box because
then you pull the box like
>> all the way down at
>> Yeah. It's almost in the middle of the
flipping range here. If you stick to the
extremes, like your box is all the way
down here, you know. Um, so you want to
be aware of that when you're drawing
that kind of stuff, too.
>> Okay.
>> Um, and then trend lines, I would say,
are pretty similar. You know, you can
have, you know, like I I think they're
pretty subjective as well, and I try and
do them pretty loosely of like, hey, you
have a swing here and a touch here. And
so, you know, I'm going to draw a line
off of that and just pull it out. And,
you know, I like to do try and do the
extreme of the initial one, like the
extreme price, and then just touch
somewhere on here. Usually try and stick
to the extreme if that makes sense. And
then, you know, this it's like, hey,
it's close to the trend line. you know,
there's not an easy way to like make a a
a rectangle like we have for the
>> yeah zones that trends like that. Um, so
I just try and use it like, hey, it's
close. That's another indicator that I
can say, you know, especially with
confirming that with like, oh, I kind of
have like a low here and a a support
zone that I think might bounce to, you
know, after this bounce is made, you can
then say, okay, well, it bounced here.
I'm going to adjust this to take that
into account. And it's like it's fine if
it cuts through like this candlestick.
>> You're you're a little bit kind of using
like the mean.
>> Yeah.
>> Or like the average.
>> Yeah. Because the you know the market
doesn't that's why it's like I draw the
zones. You don't want to draw like a
specific price and be like okay well the
market has to come up and touch this
exactly to reverse for me to that's not
really how it works.
>> Yeah.
>> I think something that has kind of been
helpful for me when thinking about this
is just being like this is all
behavior-based. like this is people
reacting and doing things.
>> Yeah. I mean that's a huge thing why
like um like I don't know for an example
here like the market bounces here at
this specific price and then it goes
comes up again and people are like oh I
I really like this spot to bet that it's
going to go lower but I'm going to get
in early because I think it'll reverse
before that or or I want to get in
before it starts reversing. Yeah.
>> And so it pushes it lower earlier.
>> Yeah. And so that's why it's like stuff
can, you know, reverse in the same area
but not the exact price.
>> It's not exact same point for price.
>> Yeah. Um, and so yeah, trend lines I use
like kind of the same thing of like you
have your like there was kind of a big
picture trend line here of like taking
this extreme high and then touching
these two and then you know this was
kind of like with a little bit you could
see it like right here like oh we did a
big punch up like this is pretty like
kind of through those areas and it's
like okay might sell off here. Um
>> and then you know it it broke it a
little bit but it still kind of sold
off.
>> Yeah. and then eventually, you know, it
kind of went sideways and eventually
broke it. Like that's a lot of times how
things happen is they'll start to go
sideways and then break or something. It
won't always if it breaks, it doesn't
necessarily mean it's just going to like
start skyrocketing.
>> Yeah. It seems like the market likes to
try and think about it for a second.
>> Yeah. Sometimes
>> unless it has a shitload of momentum.
>> Yeah. And then same thing on just like
you know using that on like a smaller
time frame chart using it as a guide to
say like okay there's this like really
tight downtrend and now it's broken. And
so because of that it's like the trend
is probably going to change but it
doesn't mean that it's not going to
continue lower. It could just continue
lower and like like sometimes you'll
have like a super tight trend like this.
you'll have like a trend line and then
it will break, but then it will just be
like, oh, it's actually starting like
this bigger downtrend, this more
healthier downtrend that has like this
kind of trend line that matches what
it's doing
>> or essentially it's kind of like
consolidating and thinking about it and
then going lower again and then thinking
about it again.
>> Yeah. Like it's just it's having a
pullback is a healthy part of the
market. Yeah. Um and that's like what
what um kind of I think the next thing
is so like you know in your first week
is like looking at those big picture
levels but then between them you know
like what'll really help is like oh if
the market's going to like break a level
or not um is having stuff like you know
you have I think I'll try and go down a
list of like I think you have something
like you have a healthy trend you can
have and a healthy trend I would say is
like something like this that's just
like methodical and almost like having
that um like that stairst step pattern
essentially. Now it doesn't necessarily
[clears throat] mean like
>> or the like flag shape.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean a a pullback can be
like this one like it's it's kind of
just like consolidating and pulling back
a little bit before it continues. Yeah.
Like here it's like great example like
move up consolidation and the strength
in that is like it slows down but it
doesn't go down.
>> Yeah. And so that shows you a lot of
strength of like, oh, it's it's likely
if it's not going to like fail and give
this move back up, it's likely to keep
going because that means there's a lot
of momentum and the buyers aren't drying
up. They're actually continuing. Um, and
so that's like a really strong trend I
would say. And how like an easy way to
see when it's going to end is when you
start to see like a change of like,
okay, there's
>> a big big kind of candle.
>> This is Yeah. Like this is a big change.
Like there was any time in this trend
there was no like pullback that was like
huge like that. Like this was the
biggest pullback and it was a lot more
stable and and then eventually like it
rocketed up and here it's like okay it
pulls back and just cuz you see that
it's like you don't you're not going to
short but like it's an indication that
it's something's changing.
>> Yeah. Like it spent because what each
one of those blocks is five minutes so
it spent
>> 15 minutes slowly ticking up and then
>> Yeah. I mean like it
>> drop in five minutes. Yeah, I mean this
is a one minute chart, but like yeah, it
doesn't matter. Like it could be
>> Oh, yeah. No, sorry. Sorry. I was
talking about the larger grid squares.
>> Um, and so that's like the biggest thing
I think is like just when you're
watching the charts in the morning is
like looking at like, okay, what is what
type of move is happening? Like this is
this was Friday and so it's like market
opens up here at 9:30 and then like this
is another thing you're going to have to
easily identify is like okay, it's just
going into chop. Like it's getting used
to like seeing that print and you know
after the fact it's easy to tell okay it
was choppy here but like when the market
opens it's like starting to recognize
that of like okay we're like just having
these swings back and forth and a lot of
time it's like the candlesticks are kind
of really close to each other and like
not really moving and like the wicks are
very large. I mean the general like you
know it doesn't have to be like super
technical. It's just like realize that,
hey, the in reality like the market's
really not going anywhere, you know?
It's not really trending. It's it's just
a lot of all over the place, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then it like clearly starts to move
and and this could be this I would
almost say is more likely a strong trend
because even though you don't have any
pullbacks in it,
>> they're big wicks. the Yeah, you can say
like here it's like in these two
candlesticks the market did move up and
and make actually a massive pullback.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, like here that was a big
pullback and um I would say a lot of the
time when the market opens and chops for
like 30 minutes, you know, you could
even say like okay, it was chopping like
for 20 minutes, 25 minutes, like it's
it's gaining its momentum, you know,
it's kind of like sitting there getting
ready. Yeah. And so it does make the
potential for a move like this to be
stronger. And so then, you know, it like
when it comes up to I think I got to
redraw this. I think it was this. You
know, essentially like, you know, here's
our resistance zone, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And so when it comes up here of being
like, okay, we're close to it. This is
where you might think of it. It could
reverse because it's at these highs
where it's reversed multiple times
before. You know, you think, well, it's
consolidated here. It's moved up. in
reality like big picture like you'll get
used more used to this. This isn't that
that large of a move.
>> It's not.
>> No, it's not that big of a
>> Yeah, cuz that was that was going to be
my question of like it almost looks like
it's done a little double bottomish
almost in that like first 30 minutes.
Yeah.
>> And like then is that 9
>> 50 or 95 when you start seeing it
ticking up? Is that ever a spot where
you're like, "Okay, I'm going to hop
in." Or is it just it's not at the
bottom? I wouldn't I that's not how I
trade. Like I want to see a move like
this that I think is unhealthy that I
think is gonna fail.
>> Okay.
>> To me, this is just like I'm staying
out.
>> That's the That's just the starting what
it's doing.
>> And it's like the the market there will
be plenty days where the market opens up
choppy and it just doesn't do anything
and I just get off for the day, you
know? Yeah.
>> And here you can also see it's it's
making this like consolidating wedge.
>> Yeah. Um, yeah. And so that's just kind
of like at that point it's like, oh,
okay, if you were like taking a big
picture bias of like, well, it's at the
support zone, so I think it's more
likely to go up. You you totally there
are definitely people that would take
that. That's just not something I like
to do.
>> You're looking for higher level
probability.
>> Yeah. And I just think that um I like to
see the move happen in the day versus it
because you don't know. It could just
kind of continue to chop.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> Yeah. And so yeah, I mean I think like
but you know there can be trades like
this trends where it's like okay if we
go to the I think the day before here
this is actually the trade that I took
is like where the market let's see
opened up right here at 9:30 and it just
kind of sold off and I you know part of
it's like okay this isn't like a super
unhealthy trend like it does have
pullbacks in it. Um, but then it just
starts to go super choppy here. Yeah.
>> And then eventually like, you know, I
guess there was indicators of I thought
like, okay, well, I think it's slowing
down and it's going to like reverse
higher. Um,
>> but you know, every time with these is
like you want to you don't want to be
thinking that it's going to reverse
until like this trend is broken.
>> Yeah. Until you see something actually
happen. Um because just because it's
like at a level doesn't mean it could it
could just keep kind of trending down
like bouncing off of this trend line.
And so that's kind of like a a big
indication of like you're using these
bigger picture levels that you draw
earlier to then go into a one minute
chart and watch like okay how is the
market moving today and how is it
reacting when it hits this level and
like what does the trend look like? Um,
and you don't have to always know, you
know, like there's plenty of times where
I'm like, I don't have a good read on
what's going on. Um, I can't tell if the
trend is healthy or it's not or just for
some reason it's just being really
jittery and I I, you know, don't feel
like I have a good read. And that's
okay. Like there's the idea is to be
only trading or making trades when
you're like, "Okay, I have a really
clear understanding of what's going on.
I'm super confident in this like zone
being a good zone and then also my read
of the market. What's it doing today?
>> Yeah,
>> that's why I like to wait for like I
don't take a trade at the market open.
Like the first time I'll take a trade is
like that 9:45 that 15 minutes after the
market open time because it gives you
time to see, you know, okay, what is the
market doing this morning? What's it
done so far? You know, it opened at this
high. I don't think this was a zone yet.
Yeah, it was like the market moved up
here, kind of chopped, attempted to go
higher, and then it essentially just
opened up and started selling off. But
like this isn't like a super unhealthy.
It's like kind of down a little bit and
it's chopping a little bit. And so it's
like, okay, I don't have a good read.
Like I don't have a good read. I'm just
going to let it keep printing until
either I do have a good read and there
it's fitting in an area that I want to
trade. Like right here, it's like, okay,
I have this zone down here. I would if
it sells off in a good way and sets up,
you know, a head and shoulders pattern
or a pattern
>> for that zone. Is that a future zone
though?
>> Yeah. I mean, like it's we don't have to
get into like, you know,
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like I think this is just more of like
theoretical.
>> Yeah.
>> Um of like it coming down to this zone
and you know, you essentially trying to
have a plan of what I want to see to
take a trade when it gets there versus
just kind of waiting for it to happen.
Um, and you'll get better at that as you
get better at like seeing what these
trends look like. But, you know, here
being like, okay, there's not it's not a
I don't have enough information or I
don't have enough good enough read and
it's not acting how I want. Like,
there's not enough move here to make a
reversal. And obviously, it's not at a
zone that I like.
>> Yeah.
>> And then when it gets down to there,
then you can start to say, okay, now I
do, and you know, here's like more that
10:00 timing of, okay, now I do have
more information. But then also you're
like, "Okay, well now there's this
>> now there's a trend
>> make this trend line and I need to see
that broken."
>> Yeah.
>> Um and so here, you know, it just starts
to go into a chopfest of just candle
after candle just not doing anything. Um
and you're like, "Okay, well, it's going
to break this trend, but I got to be
aware of that. I I need a little bit
more movement to happen kind of thing."
Um
and so like I don't like to enter in on
stuff like this. I need to see it start
to break. You can start to like with
these little chop zones, you can almost
make sometimes like sometimes I'll just
make like a I'll just do this in my head
a lot of time, but you can make like a
little box.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, of like something that just
like makes it so it's like okay, there's
just like this little box here and I
need to wait for it to break out of this
because then it's broken out of this
like area that it's clearly not doing
anything cuz otherwise you'll in these
chop ranges you'll get these like big
candlesticks that'll
>> it looks like something's happening but
>> Yeah. And in reality, it's like it's
still staying in this range.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then it kind of breaks out and
does like a you know, I don't want to
get into this too much, but like a fake
lower and then that that fake lower gets
reversed and then that was like kind of
the signal that I was like, okay, now I
think it has a potential to reverse.
>> It's tested again.
>> Yeah. Again, that's more like entry
stuff. The idea is like, okay, the big
picture. And that's like the idea is
like you're slowly going more narrower
and narrower focused as you kind of get
into these areas of like okay what is
you know the big picture like zone that
I'm getting from a 15-minute chart or a
five minute and then either on a on a
you know you could also go to a five
minute and look at this of like okay
what is like what what have we done
we've done a big move this morning into
basically like you know here is like
kind of more of that zone I was looking
at that day okay it's kind bottom tier
and there was also this this upward
trend line farther back. Yeah.
>> And so it's like okay those are like two
kind of it's kind of theoretically
bouncing off this little swing here and
then it's also like hitting this trend
line. Um and then you know going into
kind of the one minute chart and seeing
like okay what's the trend and seeing
that it's kind of bottoming at that
10:00 time which is that timing that I
really like of when stuff reverses and
then seeing like even just the big
picture of like okay there was a
downtrend. It's clearly lost its steam.
What's likely to happen at this area?
You don't have to be thinking about this
like what the candlesticks are doing
specifically. Just like you could almost
even like blur your eyes of like, okay,
we're down. We're kind of sideways and
we're at an area where I think there's
going to be upwards pressure. Well, then
it's likely that we go up, whatever that
looks like.
>> And then what am I looking for?
>> Yeah. And then when we get into like the
entry, it's like, okay, what am I
looking for to actually enter in a trade
of like where I enter and like where I
put my stop loss kind of thing and it
up.
>> Okay. Well, I know you don't have a lot
more time, right?
>> Yeah. Um,
>> so for this week,
>> well, I guess Yeah, it's like um cuz I
was trying to I guess does that make
sense with like trends? Um, I mean it's
like I think just this week there's, you
know, there's going to be like like this
is like this is like a super strong
trend, you know, like like we kind of
had originally of like it's not really
having pullbacks and then you can have
trends where it's like, you know, like
this one, it's like it's super strong,
but it's kind of unhealthy of like it's
a huge move. And so it's like it it has
a more likelihood to fail, but you just
have to you don't know sometimes where
that is. And so I think in the morning
trying to just get good at identifying
what kind of
>> healthy unhealthy. Is there a way to put
in text boxes onto this and just like
right click text box?
>> Right click drawing tools text.
>> Okay. Um,
>> so maybe I'll try and go through and
just like put in resistance zones or put
in floors and ceilings or resistance and
whatever the other word that I can't
think of right now and then trend lines
and then put some trend lines in and
then try and label them healthy,
unhealthy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you could like try and
take pictures um and put them in like a
folder or something. Uh, another thing I
like to do like a super easy way of
doing this is just with like an
indicator. If you go I don't put this on
my my one minute charts. I like to do it
on a five minute is if you just go to
your five minute chart and go up here to
indicators. I don't know why this little
square circle keeps turning off. And
then in the box just type in don't know
how to spell like fair to bring up fair
value gap or you can just type in gap or
something.
>> Oh yeah.
>> And that'll bring up this indicator
called the fair value gap indicator and
you just click apply without changing
any settings and it will help
essentially identify like unhealthy
moves in the market. Yeah. Should I
start with that on or leave it off so
that I'm not relying on it as much?
>> That's a good question.
>> I think I'm going to start with it off
so that I can try and do my best and
gain some intuition and then
>> it's not going to be right every time.
Like this was, you know, this it's
saying there's an unhealthy move here.
And this was that that move here we were
looking at earlier where it's like, you
know, there was there was definitely
reasons to say it could have been an
unhealthy move, but I think there was,
you know, other reasons to think it
wasn't. And so
>> and then it kind of did that little
consolidation thing there. Yeah, it did
this little pullback and then kept going
higher and um yeah. So yeah, I think
that's totally a reasonable thing to do
is like leave it off because I mean at
the end of the day like yeah, you can
see it's pretty easy to see like okay
this is a big move down. We need to give
that back up or like this is a big move
down. It's like the basics is like,
okay, are there a bunch of candlesticks
in one direction without like much
pullbacks essentially like, you know,
like the bodies are just all stacked up
on each other just moving up.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's just all it's just one
directional, you know, like that's like
the easy way to say and like the whole
idea behind these unhealthy moves is
like, okay, it moves up crazy. Well, it
has to kind of pull back.
up crazy and it kind of has to pull back
or or the flip side of it like a crazy
sell off it has to kind of give that
back up to some extent. Yeah. This week
is like just trying to get in that
routine of like pulling up your like
15inute chart, looking at, you know,
kind of what's going on, trying to think
about the trends and stuff of like what
what you're seeing and then just seeing
what that's like. And then also, you
know, doing that on a five minute,
trying to think of your support and
resistance levels and looking
>> for for drawing support and resistance
and trends, you're generally doing
support levels on a 15-minute chart,
right?
>> Yeah. Like sometimes I'll look at a
five, but like quite often even the five
minute ones, you know, like even these
swings, like you can tell it's on a on a
15-inute chart that there's, you know,
like this support level,
>> something there. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Like you can still
>> Yeah. And then I imagine you're never
really drawing them on a one minute cuz
it's just
>> No, I think Yeah.
>> Too too far in.
>> Yeah. You're too zoomed in and that at
that point you're not looking, you know,
it's not you're not using the like big
thesis of like, oh, I'm sticking to the
extremes.
>> Yeah. Are you drawing what levels are
you drawing trends at? All levels.
>> Trend lines.
>> Trend lines. Yeah.
>> Um, yeah, I would say so. Because I I
like to think though like trend lines
are a lot of like helping you identify
like the big picture that's going on.
>> Yeah. You know, of like, okay, here
there was this like trend line up that
was going on.
>> Yeah.
>> But also like try to not just say, okay,
we're in an uptrend. Think about it like
here it's like okay it's trending up but
it's starting to make
>> yeah tops
>> tops and like it's starting to reverse
in the same area and so when that
happens well it's probably going to
break this at some point and so trying
to think about stuff like that too of
like you know don't get married to a
drawing tool it's all subjective at the
end of the day and you know stuff like
that you know next week we'll we can get
into I think more of the nitty-gritty of
like trying to enter in and stuff like
that because I think you know it's it's
I don't think you need to start doing it
this week, but at that point, you know,
it's it's helpful to just even start
learning like what it feels like to just
even just the controls of all that
stuff.
>> Um, so I've watched the I don't know
what is it the course overview, I guess
the the section one and two in your
course. Should I watch section three
this week in preparation for the
following week or just hold off? Most of
that that's like um how to enter into
trades properly, my phase three
management blah blah blah and then a
bunch of like trade walkthroughs.
>> Um I don't know. I think we can just
hold off on that. Yeah.
>> Okay. Stick to the basics.
>> Yeah.
>> Don't over like you're just you're
getting ahead of the game of like Yeah.
You're not even thinking you're not even
starting to enter in yet. Like I think
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because it's like the the big picture
and just learning to read the big
picture is literally going to be like
90% of your success.
>> Yeah. just being able to pick the right
zones to reverse at and be able to pick
and understand like okay what is the
trend like why you know why that you
know it's reversed here multiple times
why this time is it going to push higher
you know
>> yeah managing trades doesn't really
matter if you're not trading in the
right spot
>> yeah like and 90% of your trading is
your entries and so you and and your
entries are based on your thesis of what
the market's going to do from that area
and So getting that down is like the
most important thing about trading. Like
it's so many people get distracted by
all the other stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> That's why I think so many people
overload and then they realize, oh, I
need to go the simple route and just go
back to the basics almost.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Keep it simple, stupid. But
should I be trying to do or maybe I just
try um like little market thesises of
like I think it's going to do this here
at all of like oh it's approaching a
resistance level. I think it might do
this or I think it might do that. like
kind of almost like you're not entering
in a trade, but you're saying, "Oh, I
think it's gonna bounce here."
>> Yeah. Or I think it's gonna do this. And
maybe it's something I try and think
about, but like
>> Yeah. Like you could even like something
like this. You could type like, "Okay, I
think we're at here. You know, I think
we're because of these reasons, I think
we're going to go up."
>> Yeah. or like like you know this trade
like you came down here and you had that
like support zone and that resistance
zone and you could say like type in like
reverse up you know something like that
>> put in put in some thoughts
>> yeah like reverse up you know because of
I think probably saying like because of
blank will help you get in the mode of
like why do you think that you know
versus like just because you don't want
to just start randomly thinking that and
then because even if you're not in a
trade you're still going to get like
kind of some confirmation bias if you're
right or wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. I was right. Yeah.
>> It'll just be random thoughts that pop
in your head, you know, and so trying to
just think of like, okay, well, I think
it's going to even if it's like, oh, I
think the trend's going to just start
chopping here. And you could always
change it as like more candlesticks come
out. Yeah.
>> Like, oh, it's like moving. I think it's
going to reverse up now or or I think
it's going to like fake higher and then
go lower. Stuff like that. Okay. So week
two, we are trying to start focusing on
trade entries. So I'm just going to
quickly show you a trade I took a while
ago where, you know, it's basically the
same just to kind of give a quick
overview of what we're trying to
accomplish. Again, we the first week we
were really starting on identifying just
these trends. And then I think this week
we can start to really focus on how do
we tell like when something is going to
actually bottom and that we can look for
an actual trade and reverse to the
upside. Especially this last week and
we'll get to it. There was a lot of
times where we got to let's say like a
support level here or resistance level
up here and the market just broke those
levels. And so how do you tell the
difference between that and the market?
So showing signals where it's going to
start to reverse and we can enter a
trade and you know take advantage of
that and and bet on the reversal. And so
the big the big part about the strategy
is finding those reversal spots here
using you know the idea of identifying
the major trend of the unhealthy trend
into this support zone and then like in
this trade identifying there's a head
and shoulders pattern and then a
potential for the market to give back
this kind of unhealthy move. This is a
very common like target to go back to
this high right here. And so this week,
I think it makes sense to try and get
you ready to trade and not necessarily
be entering in, but focusing on starting
to identify them and have the tools in
place to figure out, okay, how you can
pull the trigger on these trades and
starting to paint the full picture of,
okay, the five-step process to, you
know, enter in on this trade and then,
you know, what it looks like so we can
start to kind of visualize that more.
>> Perfect.
>> What else? Yeah. And I think last week
we did a good big picture of talking
about identifying trends and the big
picture. I think it makes more sense to
well now we can start to look at I mean
head shoulders patterns and other
patterns that are used to enter in on.
>> Yeah. I had a couple spots where I was
like seems like there could be something
here but I don't really know what I'm
actually looking for in terms of an
entry.
>> Yeah. And like when it
>> pattern or signal. How do you know when
it's going to continue going in one
direction versus
>> um
>> actually setting up a trade to reverse?
>> Yeah, one of the questions I had
somewhere was like how how much like how
credible are those zones from way back.
>> Maybe it makes sense to like just go
through a bunch of those questions.
>> Okay. And because that might maybe we
start with that and then that'll
[clears throat] jump starts or ideas.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we can go from there. Yeah. I
think I think maybe we start with market
and structure. So like section one was
at Q4 the like how normal was last week
mainly thinking about the like having
the major draw down on
>> was that Tuesday or I'm sorry the major
draw down on Thursday and then also
having the spot where like the NQ and ES
were not lining up in like the moves
they were making or at least I thinking
I think ENQ was leading ES in the trend
for a while.
>> Okay. Okay, I don't remember which day
that was, but yeah, like so how normal
of a week was last week? It definitely
was not super normal. Like if I mean
even if you just look at like a daily
chart, we zoom all the way in. Let's
see. We're technically on Monday. So if
we discount this candlestick, I mean
like the the wicks were pretty big. I
guess these are the five candles the
last week and it was definitely like
pretty all over the place. But you can
also say like right now that is kind of
almost the norm. Like in the last few
months, there definitely have been
there's been times where it's like,
okay, a week you barely move anything.
>> Yeah.
>> If these are, you know, each of these
are daily chart and then like you have
like here's a week where it's like,
okay, the market kind of went crazy. So
it's definitely been like very volatile
and that's where like I don't know
market type comes into or like just what
the mode the market is because if you
you know look at these last four months
but then you go and look at you know the
the four months before them like the
amount of movement that was happening
was very small
>> just much smaller candle
>> and then there's some moves and then
some down. So like we're definitely in a
like much more volatile time.
>> Okay. Yeah. One of I mean one of my
questions farther down was like how do
you determine if a candlestick is like
big or significant in terms of sizing
and like is there like a number of
little what are they called on the side?
Points
>> ticks or points.
>> Ticks. Yeah, ticks or points that like
it needs to hit for it to be like oh
that's a significant move like that's I
don't know indicating that the market's
moving heavily in one direction I should
enter on a trade or is that kind of all
just relative to what the market's been
doing. And so for instance, like just
like you were saying here, everything's
been going up and down like crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's kind of just normal day or
normal week.
>> I mean, I think it's like even dayto day
it can change, you know, you judge of
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like
>> this is all kind of relative.
>> Yeah. I mean, like, you know, you have
candles like this where it's like
they're kind of this size and then all
of a sudden like they're this size and
then all of a sudden, you know, they're
this size. And so I think it's like just
kind of using okay what has the market
done in the past recently and where you
like what are the current candles being
printed in relation to that. So like
this candlestick is huge.
>> Yeah.
>> Compared to these ones. So that you know
just knowing that okay something
something has changed and this is like
something you should pay attention to
but know that like a lot of time that
can change what's going on in the
market. And then also even like a big
candlestick like this in a choppy
situation like this, it's it can be a
lot more likely that it just reverses
like it did right here.
>> I think we briefly touched about it, but
like even something like that, even
though it seems like, oh, it's so
unhealthy, it has to snap back. Like if
there's not really an entry spot or
something obvious, it's just not worth
trying to take it because you're just
essentially FOMOing in.
>> Yeah. I mean, those like V bottoms like
that are just really hard to They're
just not tradable.
>> Yeah. It's more like gambling than
>> Yeah. I mean, sometimes like when the I
mean, even like on this day last week, I
think this was Wednesday or something,
but you know, where the market just like
opened up here and just sold off for
hours.
>> Yeah.
>> Trying to like catch a bottom when the
market's so strong in one direction just
doesn't really work cuz it's just so
unlikely to reverse after it it starts
to really move in one direction with
that like momentum.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There's just so much
pressure. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I guess I
think I think it was on the day before
this on the 27th there was a lot of
upward pressure and one of the things
like you traded for a bit and then in
Discord were just like going to be
really hard to take a trade today. It's
just yeah just really going to be really
hard to take a trade today and it seemed
like it was hitting some I guess
resistance levels throughout the day but
maybe it's just like there's just was
there just kind of like too much upward
pressure that even if it hits resistance
levels it's just so likely to continue
going up. Was this this is the 27th?
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Yes. Yeah. 127.
>> I was just trying to situate myself on
the chart. Yeah. I think looking at it
trying to just find the price of what it
looked like before the market opened. I
think the idea was that with this was
that we just taking into account like
the super big picture of having this big
selloff and bottom the week before and
then it kind of did this consolidation
pattern like bull flag or you know
pullback where the market just kind of
chopped for a few days and then it
breaking out of that.
>> Yeah.
>> And then pulling back and continuing
higher. It just seemed like there was a
really strong trend in place. So it was
more likely to just continue higher.
>> Okay. And even though like there's these
highs back here, you know, you can
definitely make a good resistance zone
off of this.
>> Yeah, that's one of the ones I drew.
>> Even if you pull it down to like where
these two highs touch too, like it's
very far away from the open price. And
so it just seemed like it would be more
likely that the market would just, you
know, trend higher over the day. And so
like going on to a one minute chart, I
think this is that level like when it
broke that.
>> Yeah. And that's kind of where I was
looking. I was like, "Oh, is this a spot
where it could reverse now?" Cuz you've
you've hit your resistance level and it
looks like it's doing almost like a
little double bounce or testing if it's
wants to fail. But also, it has maybe
it's just a question of like it has so
much momentum behind it heading upwards
that it's probably just going to
continue upwards through an old
resistance level.
>> I mean, same thing though, like both of
them on this day, the NASDAQ pretty much
opened at the resistance level and then
sold off and came up. And so I mean both
of them kind of hitting that move up in
the morning like this was a a nice move
into that level like to where it could
reverse.
>> Yeah.
>> But one thing was when the market it
opened here and when it kind of does
that spike lower first and then it's
almost like think about it like the
market's already faked in one direction
this morning and so a lot
>> probably not going to do it again.
>> Yeah. I mean a lot of like you have
multiple ways the market can play out in
the day and I feel like a lot of times
it'll one option is it fakes in one
direction and then trends in the
opposite way it faked or it could just
start faking in every direction and you
have more of a rangebound day and choppy
day. But a lot of the times especially
if you know you take into account the
big picture of thinking that overall
there's going to be upwards pressure
it's more likely that this fake lower is
going to turn into just trading higher.
So, even though it comes up to here and
had this like big bearish bar, you know,
you can start to think, okay, well, that
could turn into a spot where I could
look for a reversal because this could
be considered a pretty rapid unhealthy
trend move, you know, cuz all the
there's just bullish candlesticks here.
>> Yeah. But I think the big thing is okay
well if trying to think of like where
the market's going to move is where like
the gaps between like support and
resistance and and and so like where is
this going to pull back to and you can't
just think about the low here. You have
to think about okay well there's kind of
this here too.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's it could come back to here.
It could be breaking out and pulling
back to this these previous highs from
like
>> the overnight high. So there's all this
price movement in here which makes it so
there's not as much of you know when you
think about like the fair value gap idea
of like if there's just nothing to hold
the market it'll just fill that quickly.
Like I'm trying to find a good example
here. Even like this is a good example
of like okay the market shoots up here
and there's so much room between here
and you know this previous swing here
for it to like move down and so the
potential for a swing to go a long ways
is higher because there's not as much
support or in the way and like you can
you could draw this here but really it's
like so close that it's hard to fail
break out of that.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, it's like the next level down.
Um, that's why like I won't take, you
know, even though this looks good,
sometimes I'll think, okay, well, if I
enter in here, how much space do I have
before it runs into some resistance? And
in the sense of like, you know, if
you're getting in a trade and you're,
you know, your risk award is like this,
it's like, okay, well, it's it doesn't
go very far in my favor before it, you
know, has a chance to reverse. And so
that's a big thing to think about I
think when understanding like like a
almost like a little bit advanced of
like understanding when it's worth
risking taking a trade is is those gaps.
But I also think that just comes with
reading the trends as well of like and
in a way like the a healthy or unhealthy
move potential.
>> Yeah. And I think like here like the
patterns I would be looking too short
here cuz just because this is here
doesn't mean it's like not a good spot
to bet a trade. I think here like this
can actually be a good signal too of
like oh you know this thing moved up
clearly it was losing steam right here
cuz it got super choppy and then all of
a sudden it just you know broke lower in
a big way. And so because but so with
that, you know, my first thought is
like, okay, well, is this just a
pullback to continue higher, you know,
cuz it's the pullback like that is
healthy in the sense of further uptrend.
And so I would want to see, okay, what
is this what is what is like these next
three candlesticks look like? Does it,
you know, start to come up and like
retest this area where it failed and
then start to turn down? That's where
you would start to want to think about,
okay, well then maybe I'll get in short
once it like breaks this low again,
>> goes through that. Yeah.
>> Cuz the way I see that is like it's it's
really tell it's showing you that this
is like a you know I don't like to read
into every individual candlestick, but I
think in these key areas it really helps
to.
>> Yeah. And so that's where like I would
be reading in the candlesticks and
looking at like, okay, how is the price
reacting to and is it going to make a
new high? And if it breaks and makes new
high, I think it's probably just going
to keep continuing higher because that's
a really strong signal.
>> Yeah. Strong rejection of that.
>> Yeah. of this like failure to or trap to
go lower or you know attempt to go lower
and then this becomes an attempt to go
higher and it succeeds by making a new
high versus attempting to go higher and
then failing. And so you know even for
like almost like for this big
candlestick it's almost like any
whichever way it breaks out is a big
signal um if it broke that that way or
broke out this way. But like this isn't
I I don't consider this candlestick, you
know, breaking out of this. Like I think
that's that's almost just like okay,
it's moving down really fast. The
candlestick closes and a couple seconds
continue and then it reverses. You know,
you just see it as one move.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That was something I was
thinking about for either like five or
15 minute candlesticks is that some
extent how they're drawn very much
depends on which minutes of market
activity they encompass. And if you move
them 30 seconds or 1 minute the other
like either direction, it can change the
shape dramatically.
>> Yeah, that's why I think yes, I mean
that's a really good observation is yeah
like the candlestick forms very
differently if you just change the time
by a couple seconds. And so I some
people would do this and I don't think
this is good. Some people just go to
like, oh, if they don't like how the one
minute chart looks or it confirms,
they'll go to, you know, a two-minute
chart or like, you know, they'll go to
like a 30-se secondond chart. And it's
like it changes how the candlesticks
look. But again, like in a lot of ways,
you're just almost like trying to find
something that looks good to you.
>> You're trying to find something that
says yes.
>> Yeah. You're you're like basically
looking for a confirmation. And you know
with how the market is, it's you can
always find that if you set the right
indicator or thing on your screen. You
know, you could you could just draw
something that tells you, you know, to
go short. You could just make some
random pattern up.
>> Riley, I've got a new indicator for you.
Whenever there's a white candlestick,
you enter. [laughter]
>> How do you how do you look at it when it
you scroll a little bit to the right
when it's comes back and retouches? So
at the I don't know what is it 10:30ish
time frame right in there like yeah when
it retouches that are you thinking about
like oh is this a
>> I don't know that's not really head and
shoulders forming but like is that
another spot where it's testing downward
pressure to see if this whole thing is a
failed breakout or like I I guess a
question is like what constitutes a
failed breakout and what does its like
time frame look like of like
>> yeah I generally think the have to
happen pretty quickly.
>> Okay.
>> Just because I think the idea with them
is, you know, the movements's happening
quickly and then, you know, it some like
double top like this happens and then it
fails like that. What because the idea
is it's a lot of people getting in
rapidly getting super excited and then
there's no actual strength behind the
market to hold this price up. And so the
longer the market sits up here, the more
strength there is in confirmation that
there's people that are willing to yeah,
they're accepting the price. Either
they're holding in, you know, they
bought down here and they think it's
going to continue higher, so they're
holding, or there's people jumping in
here or thinking it's still good. Either
way, like it's not it it should happen
pretty quickly. And again, that's not
super, you know, super clear on like,
oh, wait this many candlesticks or wait
this many candlesticks after this many
candlesticks cuz like here it's like
this is still like I don't know what 5
10 candlesticks and I would still say
yeah this could totally happen of come
up here and fail but I think it should
be okay if you know this was a strong
for this you know particular spot like
this is a big candlestick and in my eyes
if this candlestick if it doesn't come
up here and fail and and that's what
happens. That's where it should have in
my eyes that's where it should have
happened. And so if it makes a new high
and then starts to chop and even starts
to pull back, I think at that point
>> okay
>> the failure
potential has gone and instead it's it's
transforming into a it would be a
different kind of trade. Like even if it
came up here and and eventually slowly
reverse and trend down, it would be more
likely that it's a slow selloff. And
those aren't really like something I
want to play with. They're a lot harder
to actually trade and manage. And in
that sense of like you could also paint
the picture of well this is just like a
bullish consolidation after that move.
So it's harder to predict that you know
>> if you look at that on a five minute it
probably just looks exactly like that.
>> Yeah. And I think that you're at this
point you're, you know, usually these
play out with the major trend. And I
would say the major trend is the upside.
And so you're betting on I think at that
point you're betting against the major
trend. Um, which isn't a good idea.
>> Yeah. I think a major a major thing for
me to try and focus on next week is
thinking about time frame of everything
and like making sure I'm zooming out or
using a good frame of reference. Because
like as you say here like if you paint
the giant flag there. Yeah. Yeah. It's
just like oh this is just a
consolidation but remembering to do that
rather than getting focused on oh in
this tiny window of time in this what
hour and a half that we have here on
screen.
>> Yeah.
>> Things can look one way but as soon as
you zoom out a little bit you're like oh
actually
>> yeah it's more like
>> that's just a consolidation. Yeah.
>> In Yeah. In a huge uptrend.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Keeping the bigger picture
in mind is something for me to work on
or focus on.
>> Yeah. And you know, like we talked about
this last week of I think that's the
biggest thing that'll be the key to your
success because, you know, you can have
all these little like a great move up,
you know, these little micro patterns
that look good, but the micro patterns I
think are so inaccurate by themselves
that they're never, you know, they have
to be like the last thing that you think
that you're using.
>> Yeah. They have to be taken in context
of
>> the larger market and larger trends.
>> Yeah. You can't just go to a random spot
on the chart and you know enter in based
on that pattern and then win money you
know.
>> Yeah. How does like weekend trading or
after hours trading work and then like
how much of a reset is the weekend in
terms of like market behavior or is it
kind of just not really much of a reset
cuz things kind of are just always
trading? I would say sometimes it's a
reset but not every time for sure
because like if you look at uh if I pull
up more of a 15inute chart if we look at
you know like trying to let's see Sunday
last couple weekends are 31 and 24 so
like this was a weekend this was a
weekend you know I mean I think it's
generally it it doesn't necessarily
reset it but I do like to come into
Monday and see how things are going and
seeing a potential for movement
difference. But also, I think a lot of
times, like you're saying, because
trading happens not 24/7, but pretty
dang close. And even when the market
closes for the weekend, it does close
from, you know, Friday at 4 Eastern time
or 5 Eastern time and then opens up at
6:00 p.m. Sunday. And so it is closed
for like 2 days. But, you know, here,
unless something huge happens over the
weekend, like this just looks like
normal. like that's
>> it didn't look like anything happened
here and then before the market even
opens. I mean the market then opens up
here on Monday. It there was a lot that
happened between now and then and I
think it allows you to just look at that
data and kind of see what's going on.
But of course like that doesn't mean
Monday could open up and a lot of things
could change. So I think Monday is
definitely more of a day than the others
to be aware of potential
>> potential for trend changes or swing
changes.
>> Yeah. But even like today it was, you
know, I it seemed pretty obvious that
once the market kind of opened up and
started ripping higher that we were just
going to continue higher for a while.
>> Yeah.
>> Just because, you know, taking in
account that big picture of well, we had
this huge Vbottom from Friday and then,
you know, Sunday night until Monday
morning and then opening up and and
having that rip higher,
>> heading higher and then
>> just cuz, you know, Yeah. It was pretty
overextended. Yeah, because what?
Professional traders aren't trading on
the weekend. They're only trading during
>> Yeah. I mean, like big banks and stuff.
Yeah. They're pretty much only trading
during main market hours.
>> Okay. Okay. So, I reading into it or
coming up with an explanation that works
or for myself would be like, okay, yeah,
non-professional traders or casual
traders traded over the weekend, had a
Vbottom, and then Monday came in and
professional traders are like, yep,
we're ready to continue higher. and then
just ripped it higher.
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> could just be a story that fits the
trend in an absolute but
>> Yeah. And it's also like just cuz well
the US markets are closed but like the
other
>> like I definitely wouldn't discount this
data of like being like oh just because
like main US banks are trading US shares
and stocks doesn't mean like that this
isn't a reasonable move that like has
meaning behind it. because quite often
it's like it it's it's matching major
moves happening in other markets that
are open like Asia or Australia or
Europe. So I I just I just view it as
continuous data. Like I you know when
I'm drawing my levels I look at okay
here's the most recent swing low and
here is a you know a swing high that it
had before it had this selloff. So like
if we're coming up here like that was my
initial target of like okay well this is
going to be an interesting spot to look
for if it reverses. Um, and also, you
know, that's where the market closed on
Friday and we had this kind of gap down.
Um, and then after that, you know, it's
there's not really a good these little
swings like as the market's making these
little swings down. I don't really like
to just be like, okay, well, I'm going
to, you know, make a level here, make a
level here. You know, you can't keep
track of all these. Again, like the
whole idea with looking at levels and
zones is trying to identify the more
significant ones. And
>> yeah,
>> the reason why this one is significant
over these other four is because this is
where this selloff basically started.
Um, and so that's where I would assume
that, you know, the whole idea of, okay,
when a market has a big sell-off, it's
going to fill that and give that back up
and it could then sell off again
equilibrium.
>> Yeah. And then this is also where the
market closed on Friday. Um, and then
gapped down. And so that's kind of like
just another significant area to look
at.
>> Okay. Yeah. I had I had a question on
how you drew that level as well as the
one at the bottom. Is the one at the
bottom just because that's your most
recent significant low?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean it's, you know, it's
like we bottomed here and then bottomed
here and then but yeah, the main thing
is like, okay, well, if we get down
there, I want to see how the marketer
reacts to the most significant recent
low. You know, like I guess you could
zoom out and and you know, you have to
go pretty far back to find a new one.
And there is ones further down, but the
most recent ones are more likely to have
reactions than, you know, ones where you
have to zoom like, you know, weeks out
to find them, you know, where it's like,
okay, this one's 10 days old.
>> Yeah. I had I was trying to figure out
or I guess had a question as well is
like how do you view the strength of
like LS or resistance zones that are I
don't know um 2 days old, a week old, a
month old and my guess is it's just gets
weaker the farther back they go but like
do they just become irrelevant or
something is still kind of there is I
guess I guess maybe also question is
kind of like what's a speed bump versus
a a zone? I would say yeah it's like
like you initially said as they are
farther and farther away the levels in
terms of like okay 10 days old you know
30 days old 2 months old you know if you
kept zooming back
>> um I don't consider those to be levels
after a while
>> yeah like that top one you have there I
think the one I was uh one of the ones I
was kind of primarily thinking about
>> yeah know so one first idea is I want to
see how it's going to hit that level
because it's so it's been so long that
it's you know for a far back level that
you drove it's drawn it's been so long
since the market's even been at that
price a lot could have changed and so I
want to I'm not going to initially think
that it's going to respect it because I
don't [clears throat] know any recent
market action around that level
>> yeah it's like the underlying variables
are constantly changing and so what
happened what is that 2 weeks ago or a
month ago
>> 15 days from here to here. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean well well and also the other um
argument is well okay we came up and
tested this level sold off and then the
markets you know regained strength and
now it's you know coming to test it
again with probably more strength and so
it makes it more likely to break through
it.
>> Essentially a giant V.
>> Yeah. Like this is just a big you know
if we you know zoom out even more to
even just a daily. like this level, you
know, it's just a swing, a swing in the
market of like it just come here and
pulled back and now it's pushing
through.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's like I
>> Do you do you view that as like okay,
maybe something happens here or like it
is a it is a point to pay attention to
but unlikely to influence the market.
>> Yeah. I mean I would say yeah like with
a big far level like that you know it's
like you have your levels like that are
really really solid where it's like you
know like this when this level was
originally made and you know you had it
like this and the market was more
looking like this. It's like these were
times where it was really the level was
really strong and you're more likely to
>> think that the markets are going to
respect it and more aggressively trade
at it versus um when it's coming here
you know you think okay the level's
probably weaker but it's definitely a
point of interest and so how I would
approach that is okay well if you know
let's say if you know you go down to a
one minute chart and the you know the
levels all the way like up here or
something and the market makes some
crazy move and you say, "Well, okay,
that today the market trend into this
level is really overextended and there's
a ton of signals showing me that I think
that we're going to double top and we're
going to sell off and give this
shortterm move back up that we've done."
>> Yeah. then it's it's worth you know I
would still take the trade because
there's still that area where it has the
potential and then all these other you
know smaller trend signals are giving
you a big picture reason to bet that the
market's going to go down there.
>> Okay, talking about resistance zones,
can you zoom back to that screen you
just had up or time frame? So looking at
the like I don't know 22nd to 25th how
there's Yeah, there's kind of an
resistance zone through those top little
ones. Yeah, like here.
>> Yeah, right through there. How do you
Because I think that's one I drew at
some point. How do you or off the bottom
of that maybe? But how do you think of a
zone when it's like It kind of seems
like there's something there, but you
also have candlesticks or little
sections that go through it.
>> I hear
>> Does that kind of Yeah. Like does that
discount that kind of resistance zone or
cuz there's something still a little bit
there and it's small indicator to pay
attention to but not a strong. It's like
a there is a little bit of a zone, but
it's not a strong zone.
>> Yeah. I mean, like I would say this is
like it did basically did a failed
breakout, you know, whatever this like
this is, you know, I'm looking at the
time at the bottom like you know, it's
the market's open right here and so it
did some kind of punch higher and then
failed back in. Um, but it definitely
like I think makes it so this resistance
level is a little more tricky. Like more
than likely I wouldn't be looking for
like it to come up here again. And I
would think, okay, well, maybe I start
tracking this high now. Cuz a lot of
times when levels start to get broken
like this, it's like, okay, something's
going to start changing and it's either
going to sometimes it'll break out this
way and then fail and then push out the
other end. Uh, or it could be like it's
breaking and then comes back and then
breaks it again and actually like that's
where it finds the actual strength to
continue higher without failing back in.
>> Yeah. Um, looking at the bottom one for
those. U Yeah, that one there. Yeah, I
did something where I kind of pulled
that pretty far across um for looking
for when this whole thing kind of comes
back down. Yeah. Through there.
>> Yeah.
>> And it seemed like it kind of worked,
but it was also felt like something
where I was just Yeah, it kind of It
seemed like it kind of worked, but also
something where I was kind of just like
hunting for something. Is that like
>> um no I mean I think that
>> strong enough or
>> I no I think it's a good like my
assumption with this move up and then if
it when it started to really like rip
like this
>> yeah lose its 2%
>> this move like if the idea of it's it's
going to give this whole move back up I
would think that it would somehow come
to this zone and find support. It
doesn't have to necessarily be this
support level but I would think
>> view it as a bigger zone.
>> Yeah. like this is where the market was
chopping and gaining strength and then
it just took off and then it you know it
failed and so like that's you know where
I kind of just you know with the idea of
okay it's going to give the whole swing
back up if it fails that's how I would
read that so that did kind of
essentially align up with that
perfectly. Um so I yeah I mean I think
that that's a good level and target to
be looking for that. I mean like during
it I'd be
>> Yeah I mean like I'd probably just be
thinking like okay it's going to come
down here somewhere.
>> Yeah. And then you know you go into a
smaller time frame and look at when it
actually bottoms.
>> Yeah. But yeah, I guess and then leads
into the next question of like when it
rips down like that, how do you how do
you even I mean it maybe it's something
where it's like Yeah. No, you just don't
really think about taking a trade in
there because it's moving has so much
momentum and is moving so much in one
direction. Like okay, it's in a little
bit of a zone. It's making a little bit
of a I don't know tiny bounce or mini
pullback or whatever. Like are you are
you looking like oh hey maybe there's
something here or is it just there's so
much momentum and so much downward
pressure. Yeah. I guess I guess it's
somewhat of like the how do you
determine the balance between what is
unhealthy overextension and what is just
a lot of downward pressure cuz it like
in the 15-minute chart it's just like
two or three candlesticks that rip down
through this. But like
>> on the one minute chart, you see a lot
of those like little tiny pullbacks or
like mini consolidations. Yeah. Yeah. So
there like Yeah. Like that.
>> Yeah. Like this is a five minute and
then Yeah. Here's the one minute.
>> Yeah.
>> Um Yeah. With cuz this kind of move is
like this is something that doesn't
happen very often.
>> Yeah. Maybe it's irrelevant to talk
about, but
>> Well, it's just like it's Yeah. It's
like, you know, sometimes you're like,
"Oh, well." And this is a great example
of the the dream of what you could do of
like if you did somehow, you know, like
you're saying here was the it bought in
like almost exactly at that area and oh
if you went long it's like you would
have caught like somehow, you know, you
would have caught like a huge move back
up and I find it really hard to actually
do that. Um cuz like trying to determine
okay yeah like this is what's healthy
versus unhealthy. And even in this trend
there are pullbacks and like all these
trends are you know it's every trend is
going to eventually reverse in some way
>> that can't continue forever.
>> Um but
>> but in terms of like trying to figure
out like okay if we have a huge move
like this you know that means well
eventually it's going to have a huge
reversal. you know, like even looking at
a 15-inute chart here, it's like it did
pretty much give back, you know, until
like the market closed, like it gave
back like 80% of the move before it
eventually continued to sell off
further. Hindsight, this is definitely
was an unhealthy move. Um, and it did
reverse like middle of the actual
trading day, but I guess in terms of
trading it like well, first off, like
looking at, you know, like more my
timings of like thinking about
reversing.
>> Yeah. like the the early moves like when
it moves so much in the first 30 minutes
like this cuz here's like the first 30
minutes first 45 where it's like okay
this is how much it's moved in the first
10 minutes which is a huge amount it's
kind of hard to look you know I guess
that helps comparatively to normal
market movement um
>> but [clears throat] zoomed in is kind of
hard to tell because there's no nothing
to tell against um but I always find
like it's the momentum is just way more
likely to continue lower. Um, and like
you know, something like this where you
think, okay, well, here's the final
attempt to go lower and then we got some
bullish candlesticks here where it's
like could continue higher and then, you
know, you think, okay, well, what if it
gives back this whole move?
>> Is it setting up some sort of head and
shoulders?
>> Yeah. Like it's, you know, it's easy to
start to look at those micro patterns
again and get too laser focused on them
when again like, okay, well, the big
downtrend is telling you that there's a
ton of momentum lower and a ton of
momentum like can just kind of defy like
the norms. 99% of your trading time is
like spent in more normal market
conditions. Like yes, they go back and
forth from like, you know, having like
decent moves in a day and like
choppiness and then like a spike and
lower and trending days, but like very
infrequently do you have times where the
market just all of a sudden just some
news is behind it and there's just some
craziness. And so it's I I almost try
and stay away from those days because
>> it's not behaving in a normal pattern.
>> Yeah. And like what you're trying to do
over time is have your strategy that you
do every day and if the market doesn't
fit that um you move on. And a lot of
times like the market doesn't this isn't
the market fitting that you know cuz
it's not making a like an unhealthy move
down that you think is going to reverse.
It's making a an extreme momentum move
down that could be an unhealthy move.
But in my experience, most of them will
move down and then they'll have they can
still have some big moves up, but a lot
of time they'll just go into like a
sideways chop or like a slow bleed lower
or maybe even like a slow grind higher
with some pullbacks that are just like
really hard to trade in. And so I think
trying to determine like what's an
unhealthy versus like a really big
momentum move just comes with kind of
experience of seeing the market like
this morning even you know like this
seemed like it could be an unhealthy
move.
>> Yeah. because the market just opened up
here, ripped up in the first 30 minutes
and then, you know, the had had some
chop here, had one more push higher, and
then, you know, started to kind of sell
off here. And then it had actually had
this candlestick where the market, you
know, went up and sold off in this one
candlestick here. And so my thought was
like, oh, well, that looks like it could
be basically at the top.
>> Yeah. and it could start to sell off and
give this move back up because that
really aligns with, you know, my
strategy of seeing a move, hit a zone,
happens in the first 30 minutes. Um, but
if it just, you know, ripped up an even
bigger amount or just, you know, here
it's that signal didn't fully develop.
It just start continued higher. It's
like, okay, well then it's there's just
more momentum behind it and I'm just
going to move on with my day.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think I watched it to
about what would it be 11 or so?
>> Yeah. Because then I mean like even here
it's like big move up and then it just
and this is why a lot of time I don't
I've stayed away from being like okay
well and I've tried it in the past like
okay well if it's not if I don't think
it's going to reverse well why don't I
bet it's going to go higher and it's
like that the hard part is a lot of
times it's like well a lot of the big
move has already happened and so you're
betting on a continuation of the this
trend becoming an even bigger trend.
Yeah.
>> And like today perfect example where it
just went up and just kind of sat there.
>> Yeah. Or it seems like it's just going
to [clears throat] make a little flag.
Like we shot up and now it's consolidate
over a small period of space.
>> Yeah. So I mean that's just like such a
hard part about trading is seeing all
these different things in the market and
seeing thinking, okay, how can I profit
from this and how can I profit from
that? And in reality, you know, that's
trying to fit what the market's doing
versus waiting for the market to fit
what you want and just taking advantage
of that. even if it doesn't happen very
often.
>> One of the questions I had from this
morning um was around how the ES and NQ
interact with each other. Um, and so I
think the way it worked this morning is
so that resistance level or zone that
you had drawn there, um, the ES hit it
first. And so it was like, okay, if the,
um, essentially like, okay, the ES hit
this first, the ES might reverse here,
would you expect to take a trade on NQ
if NQ was following ES? And then
similarly when NQ hit that zone, would
you expect if ES has just continued
shooting upwards, would you expect NQ to
reverse or just kind of keep following
ES up through the zone? Does that make
sense?
>> I think I need you to say that again.
[laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Uh, essentially it's just like
understanding more about how ES and NQ
interact and follow each other. And so
if one hits a support zone or a
resistance zone and the other is not at
that zone yet, do you expect the other
to potentially reverse if the first one
reverses? So for instance, if ES hits
the zone and reverses, do you expect ENQ
to reverse wherever is even if it's not
at a resistance zone?
>> Okay. So yeah, I think I understand your
question like how did things how do ES
and NASDAQ correlate? And when one's
hitting a zone and one's not, will the
other one like catch up first or will it
just kind of reverse where it is?
>> Yeah. Or or or in some ways it's like if
if one reverses, do you expect a
reversal in the other?
>> Okay. Yeah. So, I mean I I think a lot
of it's how this kind of goes back to I
think my rule of like I need them to
both be trending the same way and acting
the same way very similarly at least.
like you know this morning it's like um
let me try and just get these charts to
like almost match perfectly is okay so
this is pretty much the same point in
time even though the chart there's more
space here um you know the NASDAQ had
these big spikes and flags this morning
where the ES was almost more just kind
of like continuous chug higher you know
maybe you can say there's a low flag
here little flag here and then it had
that spike
>> um but you know that's without reading
too much into the candlesticks, like
just at a glance, okay, the trends are
basically the same. Like we're just
yeah,
>> opening and moving up. Um, and so I view
those as, okay, they're both correlated.
They're both going to be pretty much
doing the same thing. You know, one
might make like like a little bit of a
divergence here was okay, the ES made a
high here and it sailed off like this
far, where the NASDAQ made a high here
and sold off like just not as far. Um,
>> yeah.
>> And so, you know, it's like there was a
little bit of divergence there. And the
thought was like, okay, well, if I take
a short, will the ES sell off faster and
harder than the NASDAQ? Um, but both of
them I think would sell off even if like
you're saying the NASDAQ is at like a
resistance zone and there's this
downtrend that I had drawn this morning
from like kind of the big picture of
these like swings. Okay, we're coming up
to this area. you know, if we hit this,
how does it kind of like sell off when
it if it is going to even if the ES
wasn't [clears throat] at that level?
Like I would still think that okay
though the ES it would sell off too. I
would say that it makes it kind of less
likely for it to happen though. I would
say that better setups and trades happen
when both of them are at a clear
reversal zone.
>> Okay. At the same time essentially.
>> Yeah. because it's
>> Yeah, because that was part of my that
was part of my question this morning is
that it seemed like the ES hit the
resistance zone while NQ was still like
in between resistance zones or hadn't
got to that same point in time and then
it did later on and I think at that
point ES had continued through it.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Yeah, I mean I think it's
just another one of those things of like
trying to have things line up really
well, you know, and that's when you, you
know, you bet on the outcome just cuz
it's just another variable where, you
know, the the quite opposite thing that
I see often is like, okay, the ES just
opens and sits there while the NASDAQ
opens and spikes in a direction. And so,
you know, I used to think, oh, well, if
the ES isn't moving, maybe it'll that
shows weakness in the market and the
NASDAQ will just give this move back up.
Yeah.
>> And that doesn't h like it just it's a
lot harder predict to predict what's
going to happen when they're not moving
together. thinking about timings in the
market and you focused me around the
most of the time specifically around the
10 a.m. one. How like if it doesn't
reverse at 10:00 a.m. and kind of just
continues through that or doesn't have a
major change like around that, do you
expect that when it comes to the 11:00
a.m. point that it's also going to kind
of just continue through and follow what
it's been doing or is that another spot
where it will
>> No, I think
>> there's potential for reversal. I think
the 11 a.m. is the other spot where you
would say, okay, even if it's been
trending up since the whole market open.
If it, you know, comes up to a
resistance level and the, you know,
uptrend gets broken and you see
something like a double top or something
and you think that the trend is has the
potential to reverse, I think 11:00 is
another window where you can look for
reversals. I don't think a lot of time
at that point it's not as much of an
unhealthy move that gets reversed and
it's not necessarily going to move like
very quickly versus like in the morning
the spikes up can be a lot reversed a
lot quicker if it's like at you know the
9:45 time or the 10:00 time. So like
these moves can will be a lot more like
slow grind lower but you can still
>> get them
>> catch a big move. It's like the 7 a.m.
was often going to be more focused
around an unhealthy move while or 7 a.m.
10 a.m. is going to be focused around
being an unhealthy move while the 11
a.m. is going to be more focused around
not structural but just like a more of a
shift in the market than something being
specifically unhealthy.
>> This move right here, I think you
mentioned this earlier, like pretty much
bottomed at 11.
>> Yeah.
>> That day. And so it's like pretty much
everything lined up there for it was at
that resist reversal zone and then this
big move, you know, bottomed around that
time.
>> Yeah. So, how do you think about it when
it gets into like cuz I saw this I was
like, okay, it's done it it's done its
two little bottoms. It's then shot up
for a little bit,
>> but then it kind of just Yeah. Well,
then um even before that, like that
initial part and then it gets into that
chop and that was when I was like, okay,
it I could like it's just gone into chop
and consolidation and so now it seems
like it could just continue down or
continue up and then it obviously
continued up.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think this is it's
basically like you're saying like an
inflection point. Like there's it's I
think it's a big decision spot of like,
okay, is it going to continue lower and
just be like a downtrend the whole day?
Because if you're looking at like, you
know, just this trend, it's like it's
basically coming up and testing this
previous swing low.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um and so it's like, okay, in terms of a
stairst step pattern, it could just it
could, you know, it had this big
aggressive trend and that clearly is
changing after this move up, but that
doesn't mean like it's, you know, it
couldn't continue lower, right? Yeah.
>> It could just be shifting from, okay, a
huge spike of a trend to like more of a
channel style trend.
>> Yeah. Um that's more of a broad trend.
>> Yeah.
>> And so like but you know that's where
like having that big resistance or
support zone comes into play of okay
well that maybe makes the odds of it
breaking through this a little bit
better because you think okay well the
the overall trend could shift because of
that major support zone. And then you
know you could see this is a short-term
like bull flag as well.
>> Yeah. So, it's, you know, it's one of
those spots where it's tricky to to know
exactly because it could go, a lot of
this could go either direction. You
know, there's reasons to support either,
especially because this, you know, trend
was so aggressive and had such momentum.
>> Do you ever trade off of those bull
flags as a like indicator to get in once
you see that it starts continuing higher
or at that point? Is it just like a
okay, it's continuing higher? I can tell
that, but it's just lost or it's like
potentially moved significantly through
whatever amount of move it's going to
make and then there's just not
necessarily enough room for the trade.
>> Yeah. I mean, for my trades, I like to
be trying to target getting in down
here.
>> Yeah.
>> And once it Yeah. Once it comes up here,
the thought is like, okay, well, a lot
of the move has already happened, like
the easy money has happened.
>> Yeah. And so it can get to a spot where
it's like, okay, well, why is it doing
this? That, you know, reduces kind of
the confidence in the potential of the
trade.
>> Got it. Yeah. You're limiting your
upside. Okay. Have we talked about
setting levels at all when things get
super high? I guess maybe we talked
about like really briefly on the phone
of how do you trade when market seems to
be hitting all-time highs.
>> Yeah. Like even let me bring up 15
>> or monthly highs.
>> Yeah. Or it's just like I mean even
sometime like a lot of times it's like
oh it's just making new all-time highs
like this where the trend is just kind
of like up and there's no like every day
it's just kind of doing like this is
continuing higher and higher and there's
nothing to look back to the left side.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, pretty much you're
just sometimes I'll come in and I'll
look at, okay, well, if the market, you
know, opens up here, I'll think about
like, okay, well, there's this little
mini zone from overnight and I'll see,
okay, well, what if the market comes up
here and and, you know, I look for a
bounce off of this zone or it can open
up like this where it's kind of like in
this chop range. This isn't a great
example, but it could be like doing like
this. And then if the range here is big
enough, I'll almost look to like trade
between this.
>> Trade in between it. Okay.
>> Um otherwise just
>> just kind of enjoy the show.
>> Yeah. I mean otherwise like it's just
like you just got to wait it out. You
know, it doesn't happen forever.
Eventually, you know, it's going to
start doing this and you can say, "Okay,
now here's a a zone and like here's a
zone and then trade in that and then you
know it shifts to this and then you know
it's just a part of always adjusting to
what's the market doing."
>> Yeah. And being patient. That seems like
a key.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's like not every market
condition is going to work, you know. No
strategy can fit every market condition.
>> Yeah. And so don't force it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You just want to all, you
know, biggest thing is you want to just
try and be waiting for the market to
come to you, not going to the market.
>> Yeah. Shifting to talking about trend
lines a little bit more. How often are
you like redrawing them or adjusting
them? seems like it'd be super easy to
do kind of fairly consistently. So, for
instance, like I know in that in that
large downwards trend there
>> like it'd be easy to draw Yeah. Like
it'd be easy to draw one from Oh, I
can't see the bottom. What is that 10
right there to one of those highs a
little bit lower and then or draw it
like before you know the whole thing
putting it at the top of that like it
seems like it'd be really easy to
constantly kind of draw them different
ones.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so kind of like what's
like the difference between like
adjusting versus a breakthrough versus
just kind of a really poorly drawn trend
line like cuz you could have that one
there. I think I did this like I drew
one there and did that one to then to
that and then Yeah. Like and you just
kind of end up with them.
>> Yeah. You could have them just all over
the chart everywhere.
>> You know, it's it of course it always
just ends up being kind of subjective
cuz it's a subjective thing at the end
of the day. Um, I try and do it only
like have them only if it's like it's
super clear that that is a trend line.
Like I think this one is pretty dang
clear because you have, you know, here,
here, here, and then it breaks. But that
doesn't mean like there'll be times
where, you know, the market there is
this trend line and then it starts to go
into something like this and you don't,
you know, adjust and it still this still
fits or something.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it could just be
>> reasonably well. Yeah. Yeah. And then,
you know, okay, you see this and it's
like, okay, well, I can now adjust to
like something like this, taking into
account these three, but then, you know,
it breaks here. So, I'm like, okay,
well, I'm I'm not going to I'm just
going to discount this cuz by the time
the market comes all the way back to
this, it's most likely, you know, it's
just like a support zone. It hasn't
touched it in forever and the trend is
clearly like changed and started to do
something different. I'm not going to
expect it to come up here and like start
continue to respecting this downtrend.
Like, that's just not how it works.
>> Yeah. like they usually stay in even
even though it's like you're doing a
trend line quite often the same thing
you can still basically do like a
channel you know and it's like okay it's
respecting like a channel and like you
can match it on like the other side or
or somewhere you know
>> um and once it kind of breaks that it's
like okay well it's probably just going
to not
>> it's not going to conform to that again
anymore yeah
>> um
>> okay
>> yeah I mean same thing with like this
right here was like this morning we kind
of had like a channel and then it broke
that and so I'm like okay well I'm just
going to delete these now because
clearly this doesn't matter anymore you
know like the markets just skyrocketed
from there. Same thing with like just on
a one minute of like trying to you know
adjust to like okay well there's some
kind of trend here or like did we change
and adjust to like something like this.
I think a big thing that threw throws
people off and threw me off in the
beginning is it doesn't have to be like
at a major swing or like the bottom of a
swing. A lot of the times, a lot of the
trends will do what I call like a spike
and then trend. And so like it'll have
like a big move up and even it could be
all the way up here. It doesn't matter.
Like it just makes a huge move and then
starts to go into something that's more
constructive.
>> Yeah, that was I ran into this literally
this morning of like, okay, do I draw it
there or do I draw it off that bottom
point where it's makes the high spike
and then actually seems like it goes
into
>> Yeah. Yeah, the mini channel
>> goes like in Yeah, I mean like on these
two charts like this morning was I mean
there's not a good trend line that fits
this to be honest. Like it's this is
just like a funky weird like spike
trend. And so it's like you don't have
to fit something. And just cuz there
isn't a trend line, you can also just be
like, okay, well, even though a trend
line doesn't fit this, I can tell that,
you know, here it's like the trend is
still in place cuz the trend right now
is spike goes sideways, spike goes
sideways, spike goes sideways, a little
bit of a pullback, but spike goes
sideways. And and so it's like you can
still tell like the market is still
doing the same thing. And that's all
trends and trend lines are really
telling you is is the market
continuously doing what it's been doing
and which makes it more likely to
continue doing that, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> And then once that breaks, then you're
like, "Okay, well, now it's over and I
can I'll expect something to change."
>> Yeah. Is there a time frame that's good
to draw trends over? I guess I found
myself um [snorts] in a couple places
drawing a a bunch of like really small
trend lines that's like oh there's a
mini trend there or there's a mini trend
there
>> like this.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like someone something
almost like that. It's like okay yeah
you can draw something there but is that
is that even relevant at all to what
we're trying to do?
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. I mean like you can
just mark the [__] out of your chart if
you really want to. Um
>> I yeah I don't think you want to do
that. I mean, I even though it's like
you're looking at, you know, you can
look at a five-minute chart and a
15-inute chart and you can look at a one
minute chart and those are like zooms in
zoom in or zoom outs like that. I'll
look at for cuz you can definitely see
bigger picture trends and stuff on those
different charts, you know, like with
this stuff, but I same kind of thing
with support and resistance levels. Like
I want to I only want to focus on the
main ones that are like really clear.
>> Yeah. the the ones that actually have
strength behind them.
>> Yeah. And well, and even like like here
it's like okay well you can do you know
like you were saying you can draw one
like here and you know here and here.
It's like instead of doing that like
think about okay what is the the more
bigger picture and that's you know that
the like trying to find some I mean you
know this isn't a good example but like
looking at the main swings and seeing
okay this is clearly like the trend that
it's in and I don't need to draw little
trend lines for each of these spikes of
the trend and then you know trend lines
for the pullbacks of these trends like
you're just trying to you know at the
end of the day all you're trying to do
with all this stuff is just help you
figure out like what the main idea and
main picture of what's going on is. Um,
and you know, again, like with the
philosophy of the big picture is
important and all these little micro
moves are really just a lastm minute
thing to confirm where you're going to
specifically enter in your your order.
>> Yeah. But really, it's what is the big
picture.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. That's a good thing for me
to work on for next week. Oh, I guess
for assessing health in the market, like
what chart are you trying to do that on
to some extent? Cuz a lot of the time it
like if you look at the 15-minute chart,
it'll just be steady blue upwards or
steady blue downwards or not blue,
whatever your colors are.
>> But yeah, like steady up or down.
>> Yeah, steady up or steady down. Um, but
if you look at the one minute, it's got
little consolidations all over the
place. And like similar with five
minutes like yeah I guess it seems like
it can look unhealthy on one chart but
be a little bit more healthy on a
smaller time frame. And so are you is
that like are you assessing the health
on a more a larger time scale or a more
narrow time scale? Yeah, I mean I look
on a one minute, but like generally you
can it's easier to identify it on a five
minute like especially if you use like a
fair value gap indicator that just gives
you you know like the boxes.
>> Yeah.
>> Just to like really like tell you okay
here's where like the overextended moves
are. Um but like on a one minute
>> you know like you're saying like there
is the like
>> Yeah. There's all of that.
>> Yeah. And so
>> I guess part of my question is like does
that then not invalidate what's
happening on the five or 10 minute or
five or
>> the little consolidations?
>> Yeah.
>> Or are they just they're just small
enough that they like don't really
matter.
>> Yeah. I think it can be small enough to
where it doesn't matter. Especially if
you're looking for more of like a
10-minute reversal or like an 11:00
11:00 reversal like on a big you know
the five minute like you can still tell
that it's overextended like even like
this like looking at you know the move
we had today like I would say looking at
this on a big picture five minute like
this is a pretty big move that if it if
it fails like it'll definitely come back
down to here. Um, yeah.
>> You know, and even like on a 15-minute
like like that's a big spike up that
totally could reverse like you know, of
course like the it could just be a bull
flag and and continue higher, but like
the idea that it's there is
>> opportunity.
>> Yeah. like going back to what we talked
about like there's not really that much
between the you know the only previous
swing is this and so from you know if it
it would at least come back down to here
I would think if it's going to give this
back up and so like there's a lot of
opportunity here of potential like I
guess void in the market for like it to
find support easily.
>> Yeah. Um, and so yeah, like you know,
even though there's this consolidation
now, like it it still can like, you
know, even though it's like, oh, I was I
like to see it fail right away, it can
and will most likely still have times
where it does, you know, maybe it just
needs overnight to happen and then
tomorrow it will reverse, you know,
stuff like that. Like you can always
just zoom out to a 15-minute chart and
it's like it's like this move too. like
this move moved up and and went sideways
for a while and then was given all the
way back up.
>> Okay. I think that's at least all the
main questions I have or at least has
given me plenty to think about. So
>> yeah, I mean do you think it makes sense
to like like get you set up for trading
stuff or just still focus on that? Maybe
like put you could put the fair value
gap indicator on your chart and you know
you can just be thinking about that
stuff more and like thinking about the
five steps
>> I think
>> cuz that was a lot and there's still
like you know just another week of
>> looking I just need like yeah just
looking and not pushing it too much. Um,
I think putting the fair value gap would
be super useful cuz that just gives me a
better idea of like I got a little bit
of idea of when unhealthy is and stuff
like that, but having something to just
help confirm it cuz a lot of my notes on
my chart are like was this unhealthy? Is
that unhealthy? This seems like it is.
Um,
>> yeah. And so I think for that like you
can put it on put it like on the five
minute but then also you can also put it
on like the 15inut.
>> Yeah. because the 15-minute is I think
the 15-inut more clear of where the
unhealthy moves are. Now, sometimes the
15 minute isn't enough for if you're
catching like a 15 or 30 minute reversal
in the morning, but big picture you'll
be able to see like yeah, like this is,
you know, this is a great indicator that
this is an unhealthy move that we did
this morning, you know, and maybe we
just come up to this area and and sell
off tomorrow and and, you know, retest
this low or something even.
>> Yeah. How does that work for for
instance if it if the market opens
tomorrow morning I guess obviously we
have all the overnight trading or after
hours trading but if it just starts
going down immediately are you looking
at stuff that's happened before market
open for it's like oh yeah there's a
head and shoulder or it's already tested
this um before market open and then
starts going down. Are you jumping in on
it or are you like didn't hit my
reversal or didn't hit my pattern and
entry during market open hours?
>> I would say I try and stick to waiting
the first 15 minutes um to see that cuz
a lot of times like I have done times
where I'll just Yeah. For some like I
think oh this is doing a double top and
you know I all the signals are there and
it looks like really good to sell off.
>> Yeah. Um, and
>> but most of the time you're trying to
give it a little bit to figure out.
>> Yeah. And I I would rather see like it,
you know, spike up and attempt a new
high and maybe fail in the first 15, 10,
30 minutes and then enter in on that cuz
that's like a great signal to go short.
And personally, like I just it feels a
lot more methodical and repeatable to do
it that way versus like there have been
times where I've caught like a a crazy
sell off like the market opens, you
know, and it just like sells off right
away. Um, but those those always kind of
felt a lot more of like trying to
predict a little bit more aggressively
than lower
>> sticking to Yeah. my like my strategy
and like what I I feel very confident
in.
>> Got it. Okay. Well, do you want to show
me how to install the fair market value?
>> Yeah. I mean, all you do is it's in the
Ninja Trader platform. So, you just
click this little I don't know. It says
indicators, but it looks like a little
chart almost and then just search for
it.
>> Yeah. You just type fair in here and
then you just double click it to add it
to the chart.
>> What's max FVG?
>> Just how many that it will show. Like
each one of these is a fair value gap.
And so, you know, like if you scroll
back, it only it's only showing 40, I
think, on mine. And that might be the
default. And so, if you want more, you
do more. Um, so there's that. The basic
settings work pretty good.
>> It looks like the bases.
>> It might be 10, but
>> 10.
>> Yeah. I mean, like, I don't really have
a number. The main thing is like, okay,
I want to see the most recent swing that
I'm looking to see fail. Like I don't
really, you know, like looking at a
15inute chart, like I don't really need
a C even though this big one here still
like technically is not filled yet.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I'm not really looking to use that
anymore. Like I'm really looking to just
use this one.
>> It's another one of those things that's
just it's too far back.
>> Yeah. And like it's going to eventually
fill that, but like you know the main
spike reversal move has happened from
that one.
>> Yeah. um
>> for the time frame that you're looking
to trade on, it's not very relevant
anymore.
>> No, like if you were Yeah. like looking
and you were down here and you're
looking to trade over multiple days,
like then that's something that's
something else. But that's not what I'm
doing.
>> Yeah. Okay, cool. I got it installed.
>> Okay. So, [snorts]
>> episode three.
>> Yeah.
[laughter]
>> Um I mean, I guess first thing is like
this week we want to try and get you
ready for trading. Yeah. So, I guess we
want to try and get you set up with like
the indicators I use or just the quality
of life things for Ninja Trade that I
use and then um we can talk more about
like actually entering in trades and how
to execute that stuff. And we can go
over the strategy a little bit. Like I
have this PDF that I made that I can
send to you that kind of just has like a
nice like quick overview of each of the
like five steps.
uh six steps I guess if you count trade
management
>> and so I can send that to you and anyone
else that wants that I can put that in
the description below of the video. From
what I understand like you have a rough
idea of the strategy and I think talking
about like we can talk about some
examples like today and yesterday had
great examples and some um trades I took
last week and kind of talk about those
and we'll probably really hash out.
Yeah, I'm definitely getting I'm getting
more to the point where like I can I can
figure out where kind of the the first
two things are happening if it seems to
be getting into a zone of something
seems like it could happen here, but
then I'm not quite sure what I'm looking
for to tell me what's going to happen or
what I should be specifically looking
for.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I guess we
could just talk about um I'm just
thinking like maybe it makes more sense
to do like give you the indicators and
that kind of setup later and we can talk
about kind of the trade setup that
happened this morning and some just some
chart examples. You were watching the
market this morning. What did you, you
know, kind of we had this spot on where
the market opened up here, you know, at
9:30
>> and then we came down to this 15-minute
timing. Um, and kind of the levels I was
looking at into today was just kind of
this range we had.
>> Yeah, those those are the same two that
I identified and was looking at. And
then I had some other larger Oh gosh,
wrong button.
>> Some like zoomed out ones. Yeah, zoomed
out of like generally the market's been
going up and having upward pressure, but
obviously for the last what is it day or
so it's been in that little channel.
>> This is just overnight market closed. I
mean this is the overnight close line
right here.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> But this is definitely like a common
thing where a lot of times like the
market will have some spike up and then
like it'll be in this channel.
>> I saw it kind of going along this
channel and so I was thinking it's
probably going to do something where
it's just keep bouncing in between the
two.
>> Mhm. Um, and so then we got into that
spot that you were looking at and I
think I was looking at it more on um, NQ
because it was just down closer to the
resistance or the
>> support. Yeah. So I was looking at it
there and so [clears throat] here I saw
I was like, okay, it's done one little
bounce and then the next but the next
bounce is lower rather than higher.
>> Yeah. Um, so I didn't quite see
something super nice to like get in on.
Um, and you're obviously looking for it
to break that trend. And so then it like
kind of broke it and just went straight
up and I was maybe hoping that it would
do a little like head and shoulders
pattern but instead just ripped up.
>> Yeah. Like kind of pull back here.
>> Yeah. And then I saw you posted
something about what it was looking like
on the ES and I was like that's much
more clear of a like comes down and then
goes up.
>> Yeah. Like the ES had much more of Yeah.
like a head and shoulders where it had a
spike here and then it made a new low.
>> Yeah.
>> And then instead of I would I think this
where NASDAQ made a new low like you're
saying.
>> Yeah.
>> The ES just made a new high.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so like I I wasn't trading this
morning really. But yeah, getting in
above kind of above here would have been
where I would have got in cuz it's you
would have been getting on that.
>> Yeah. because you're looking at to break
that long candle or wick, right?
>> Yeah. The high of this candle. Like the
problem is like it's not a it's not a
it's a little more congested of a
bottom. Like it's not like a nice clean
where it's like okay you see it pull
back here and then you're like okay well
when it breaks this I'm going to get hot
get in.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's still doing that here the
price but it's definitely very
>> condensed. It's almost like it did it
all in that. It's more like it's doing
like this and then you're like, "Okay,
well that's I'll get in when it breaks
that essentially because it still kind
of does a little bit of a pullback." And
I think this the idea is like it's still
showing you that the downtrend is
slowing down and it's like losing
momentum, you know, because it's we had
big spike here, a big spike lower here
that made a new low and then it's just
kind of instead of you you'd think there
would be follow through with this
bearish candle right here because it,
you know, it's just a big bearish
candlestick. So you'd assume, okay, the
next two candles would go down, but
instead like it does another choppy
candle and then it makes a new low by
like one tick. And so then it's like,
okay, well, if it reverses all the way
up here, that's going to be pretty
strong,
>> but it's probably going to keep going.
[clears throat]
>> It doesn't like get as far down as the
NASDAQ did. Like the NASDAQ did
>> went all the way down to the resistance
floor.
>> Yeah. Where is it? Yeah. like it came
down and like tested it much better and
like here it actually broke it on the
five minute so it did a minor breakout
but like you know if you think about it
big picture it's like okay it's still
coming down to this low area.
>> Yeah.
>> Like really like having
>> if you drag it low a little bit bigger.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Like that's totally fine. And so
it's like it didn't really like miss
that you know and even if you just think
about okay well it came down to where
this originally bounced.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it kind of exploded. I've had a
couple of the spots where it kind of
gets down and does that little
consolidation [clears throat] thing. I
don't have a good indication or gut read
on whether that's just a consolidation
and then it keeps going lower or whether
it's a consolidation and keeps going
higher. Like I've got it down that
that's like a decision point for going
one way or the other. But
>> yeah, I think for me here, so like the
biggest thing with this common pattern
where the market, you know, is in like
an uptrend and then it does this
overnight range that you're going into
in the market. I often like think, okay,
unlikely that the market stays in this
during the day because it's such a small
range. It's just overnight, you know,
it's these are these are definitely
minor levels. They're not big like you
know levels off of a 15inut chart but I
still think they're important because
they can just because trade on a one
minute chart and if the swings are big
enough they can still produce a good
trade. Um the main thing is I generally
think of okay well I just want to see
how it reacts to these zones. Um like if
it comes down here is it going to bounce
and I can get a swing or is it going to
come down here bounce and then break and
the move for the day is going to go
lower you know.
>> Yeah. Um, yeah. And I think a big thing
is like, okay, the big uptrend, we're in
an uptrend right now. And so for me,
that puts my bias more of, you know,
even if the read or or I'm a little less
confident in reading into the
candlesticks here of having a clear
signal. I'm going to say, well, I think
my bias is more to the upside because
it's likely we do a fake lower and then,
you know, break to the highs and
potentially trend the rest of the day
versus Okay.
>> If it came up here betting that it's
going to go short, I think that's a
weaker of a play because again, you
know, the big picture is the market's
bullish. Yeah. Like in the big picture,
this is kind of like a consolidation and
then you keep going up.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's been going up.
>> Yeah. So even though you know on a one
minute you're taking a reversal trade
right here, you're really big picture,
you know, you're just buying a pullback
that you're expecting to continue
higher.
>> Yeah. Because overall you're think about
the big trend.
>> Yeah. And you know Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
Maybe something that would be helpful
[clears throat] and that I had a
question on from last week was could you
kind of talk through about market
activity over the day of like because it
always seems like it starts off really
energetic and then kind of slowly slows
down over the rest of the day and is
that a fair assessment or
>> Yeah, I mean I think that's why I only
stick to the it really like the first 30
to an hour minutes to an hour just
because uh pretty much when the market
opens there's almost always volatility
or that's on average that's the highest
amount of volatility in the day.
>> Yeah.
>> Um or or volume which would create
volatility and then as the day goes on
it just it's way less likely to
>> things just happen slower.
>> Yeah. Things either happen slower
because the volume volume has gone down.
And like today was a great example like
we had great swings in the morning and
even here there was like funky swings
but as time goes on a lot of the time is
it just starts to dwindle and like this
volatility gets reduced and reduced and
reduced and even like here you know like
it it made a swing like all the way to
the downside. It's like trading in this
is like really almost impossible I find
>> or it's just not as consistent. Yeah, I
just find it not as consist consistent.
And then also for me, just the trading,
you know, you can come in capture or be
available and ready to take a trade
during the times when there's really
high volatility on average because
again, like you have to think about,
okay, can I do this every single day,
you know? Um, yeah. And I find it way
easier to focus on this beginning part
of the day that often has volatility and
then just leave and not even think about
trying to wait for this cuz a lot of
times it's like I just get so bored even
sitting and watching this for an hour or
like two hours, you know? It's like some
days you'll have crazy movement the
whole day, but it's so rare that on
average it's just you're just going to
get so bored and drained and and you're
just going to burn yourself. Yeah.
you're just going to burn yourself out
and just and when you're burned out and
like you're not focused in trading,
you're just going to make mistakes.
>> Yeah. No, something I definitely like
about your strategy is that you can kind
of sit down and do it for like an hour,
hour and a half in the morning
essentially before anything else happens
because at least on the West Coast, it's
opens at 6:30 in the morning.
>> Yeah, it's an early morning, but it's
>> nothing else is happening at 6:30 in the
morning. So after it went through this
whole upwards then I was watching it
through here and to me it was like okay
it's made kind of I guess the way I've
been thinking about this is I've been
looking for like head and shoulders and
so I'm like okay there's shoulder one
now or like bounce one now I'm looking
for a second bounce and it kind of does
that and then it just pukes lower.
>> Yeah.
>> And then like immediately comes back up.
Um, and it's like, okay, it's I I think
ultimately it kind of forms like a
something that looks a little bit like a
head and shoulders. Um, but it's also
just like over such a long period of
time.
>> Um, and maybe that's like an acceptable
period of time and I just don't know
what I'm looking for, which is
completely accurate.
>> Yeah. So, there's a couple things here.
one for me when like one swing happens
like this I find it rare that another
swing happens
>> happens back
>> um it can and so like I was definitely
paying attention to this too cuz I I
still thought there was potential you
know I thought there was potential for
the market to you know if it comes down
to here and it breaks lower you know
it's like that's a big trade.
>> Yeah. Um, and so being open-minded to
that and so and it was a this was a
super fast move up and I would say
unhealthy move that had reason to give
up. And like you're saying like I
wouldn't want to short here or even like
um
>> you know sometimes I'll just look for a
high and then a lower high and then go
lower and I won't even it won't set up
really a full head and shoulders.
>> Yeah. But like this is something that
I've realized you don't want to get in
on. Like you don't want to just put an
order down here, you know, expecting it
to break this chop range and then, you
know, get in if it does because often
this can like, you know, it can break
lower and push higher. Um, especially on
a day like today when the bias, at least
my read was like, okay, major uptrend,
>> upwards bias,
>> like I think we could just be, it's more
likely that this just continues to trend
higher. Um, but you know when it had
this big crazy candlestick that then
failed back in and I think broke this
little minor support here like you know
once you start I think reading into kind
of the candlesticks there and the more
micro patterns I think it's really opens
up the door to take a trade to the low
side.
>> Okay.
>> Um the problem is obviously this
candlestick is huge and I I'm not going
to just put in an order below this level
and get in short there. Um, again like I
I still same philosophy of like I want
to see that head and shoulders, that
lower high happen because in these
instances like you can have these big
candlesticks that just all of a sudden
rip lower and then like reverse.
>> Yeah. Cuz in of itself is a pretty
unhealthy move.
>> Yeah. I guess one of the things I've
been semi struggling with is letting the
market tell me what's happening versus
trying to predict what's going to
happen. And so essentially like how many
candlesticks do I need to let it and
maybe it's some of just where I am right
now. just like I need like letting
several candlesticks form for me to be
like, "Okay, well now it's it's
reversing, it's going down or it's
ripping up versus like trying to predict
that and be
>> um Yeah, I I think some of that just
comes with time cuz it's and sometimes,
you know, you just have a bias and
you're wrong. Like it's okay."
>> Yeah. a or it's like it's just the
market like in this today it's like the
market did do this crazy move and then
punch back up and then punch back down
and when it starts to so for me for this
trade I actually I would have liked a
short if it cuz I think this big
candlestick here could be like the the
start of a huge sell-off like it is
crazy momentum and with the volatility
the market's had recently too but the
thing is it's like I do want to see kind
of what I don't want to just get in
short right below the candlestick
because that's
>> often these candlesticks can just whip
you out kind of like it actually did.
I'd want to see essentially what I was
looking for was again like looking at
more the structure and where reasonable
market trends and stuff would happen.
Like here is like kind of this previous
support. And so I'm thinking, okay, it
broke that. I want to see it come up
here, test it, and fail. Cuz to me,
that's like showing you kind of that
stairstep pattern down.
>> Yeah.
>> And it breaking, you know, a structural
logical thing you can read and see. Um,
and so if it did that, I would have got
in short below this.
>> Yeah. So you're essentially you're
looking for it to rebreak that downwards
momentum essentially confirming it.
>> Yes.
>> Cuz right now it said, "All right, we
weren't sure about going up. We puked
lower." And then you want to see it come
up and be like test [clears throat] that
level, not go through it, essentially
confirm that it doesn't have upward
pressure and then actually break through
that low and then you would get in.
>> Yeah. I mean, even here when it made So,
it's like, you know, here it broke up,
but even here when it made this, like I
was interested in getting in short here
after this push down, but again, like I
needed it to come up here, like do like
a little 50% pullback of this big
candlestick and then break the low.
>> I guess I'm thinking of like right-hand
shoulder. You're looking for it to come
up, show that it wants to go down, kind
of pull back a little bit to confirm,
and then actually push down through.
Okay. Um, I mean I think not always, but
like in this case because this is
already after it's like, okay, here's a
big candlestick that failed. You know,
it's it's starting to kind of act weird
and kind of like you're saying like um
once it starts to do this over too long
like I think you know the good entry
would have been here after this big push
lower but because that didn't work out
it's like okay now it's starting to
>> this is almost like 30 minute time
frame.
>> Yeah. like since it's been it's starting
to chop basically for like 30 minutes.
And so it's like it just gets to a point
where it's like and it's past, you know,
the the kind of 10:00 reversal time. Um
and it's already done like one swing in
the day. It just starts to get to, you
know, I just get that the idea where I'm
like, uh I'm not really interested. One
thing too, I didn't really notice this.
I don't really notice this very often,
but it was exactly at 7,000. And so
that's kind of a big psychological level
that a lot of times can cause a little
chop or or resistance or support
depending on um where things are at.
>> Interesting. How often are you then
paying attention or thinking about the
like 11 a.m. potential point?
>> I pretty much never do it.
>> Okay.
>> Just cuz like I you know again that that
requires me to stay another hour versus
just focusing on okay what's my read in
the first 30 minutes trading based on
that.
>> Does something seem like it's setting
up? Yeah. Yeah. And then, you know, I
feel like it opens the door up for well,
you know, you're trading longer, so
you're more tired, so you're going to
make a worse decision. And then also
like, oh, if you missed a good trade in
the morning, you might try and force
something.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, which I've sent you like, oh, I've
been I've been putting a bunch of work
in. I should be able to get a trade or
like I need to make a trade to make this
time that I've just put in pay off
versus just seeing if something's
happening. If it's not, move on. If it
is, perfect. Yeah, that's why I I feel
bad about it sometimes getting off that
fast, especially if it's like I'm in my
chat room or whatever, but it's like
that's what I'm doing. Like I'm this is
my strategy. I'm sticking to it. Like
that's where I find the best trades for
me and what works for me. And so it's
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's I mean this is kind of
tangent from what we're talking about
but just like in the chat room seems
like there's a bunch of people who trade
similar stuff but slightly different
things or at least put more trades in
and have some like additional little I
don't know if they're indicators or what
but other things of bits of information
they're paying attention to.
>> Yeah. I mean, you know, everyone just
kind of makes it their own, adds their
own variation. Like someone was talking
about the other day of like, oh, well,
what about um,
>> you know, if you see this happen and you
look, you think that it's not going to
go down, what about taking this as a
buying opportunity to go higher, you
know, like instead of if the reversal,
you know, with idea of, oh, if the
reversal is going to fail, like why not
take take the continuation trade
because, you know, most likely you're at
this inflection point where it's going
to choose a direction.
>> Yeah. And if it didn't go down, why not
choose up?
>> Yeah. And I think it can work, but you
know, you can also have days like this
where it's you just get chopped out
either direction. And I think it opens
the door for you're adding on a second
decision of in even though it seems like
it should be simple in theory, and
practice, it's I feel like instead of,
you know, for me, it's okay, it's coming
up to here. It's showing signs that I
don't want to short, so I'm just going
to be done. Versus, okay, it's showing
signs that it don't doesn't want to
short. Now I have to think about all the
signs to go long. Um and again like it
can I think it can just complicate
things and and sometimes you can think
oh well I'm seeing signs to go long so
I'm not going to take the short and then
you actually miss the short. Um, and
you're like, I'm an idiot. You know, I
should have just sat. You know, again,
it's
>> it's trying to just simplify things to
like almost a dumbest amount of level of
strategy. So then you can't mess it up
as much with your mind being stupid and
you trying to just complicate things.
>> You can't over complicate it.
>> Yeah. Cuz that's
>> which seems like it'd be so easy to do.
>> That's really like what messes people up
as trading is they just overthink things
when it's like the hardest part is just
keeping it as simple as possible. Yeah,
it's been it's been tempting to try and
like figure out some of the acronyms and
other things that people are using to
trade in the chat room and I'm just
like, nope, I will skip that. I have
other things I'm trying to learn and do.
So, I will stick to stick to Riley's
message.
>> Yeah, because it's just the thought of
like, oh, well, logically, if I learn
something else, shouldn't that make me
better or make my win rate better? And
it's like it just it just doesn't
necessarily. It's the same thing with
like, oh well, trying to add on taking
continuation trades. It's like, oh,
well, shouldn't that make me more money
because now I'm taking twice the amount
of trades potentially? And it's like,
no, not necessarily.
>> It was really interesting in my like um
one of my my classes, the professor was
like an old like professional trader.
Um, but he was he was going through he's
like, "Yeah, there's all these variables
you can bring in to help track different
components and everything like that to
try and get a better guess." But like
ultimately it came down to like three
variables that had the highest
likelihood of like I like momentum was
one of them. I was like, "Yeah, most of
the time momentum wins." Like you can
include everything else, but most of the
time it's going to be momentum.
>> This was like the market was kind of
here. I think it opened it actually
opened up here, but pretty much
off.
>> Yeah,
>> but the idea was it had a huge rip the
day before. Um, just because the market
was volatile, you know, my thought was
like, okay, well, we might just rip this
back lower and give this move back up go
that this is on a 15-inute chart and
then going into a smaller chart. Um,
you know, kind of it opened up here and
kind of just sell off. Um, and so there
wasn't really there wasn't a spot to get
in short, which I would say was the
better read or or better, I guess,
higher chance of a move just with like,
you know, thinking about giving back,
>> grabbing it on the way down. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, and so, you know, it kind of
just kept selling off, sold past off
past the 10:00 reversal time, and then
kind of just started to sit here for a
while.
>> Yeah. Went into a little like sideways
channel almost. Uh a and so my thought
process on this was well we did have a
big sell-off. We could give this move
back up that it's had. Um
and so I was I think one mistake I did
was I was trading way longer than I
should have. Like once it kind of went
into this chop I think it's more likely
that you know usually these unhealthy
trends like we the trade we were talking
about this morning is like they snap
back quickly, right? And so I mean
almost exactly like this morning on the
flip side is it just started to kind of
doing a volatile back and forth. Um but
like you know potential reversal spots I
was looking at was my thinking was okay
well my my target for the way down would
be this like it essentially giving back
these this spike up it had. And so I
would think that okay when it hits this
it might reverse um or like here's some
kind of gap that it filled. Um there's
like this little gap here between when
the market closed one day and opens.
Sometimes those can be zones as well.
>> Yeah, I think that was over the weekend.
>> Yeah, I think you're right. Um and so,
you know, that's kind of what I was
looking for. And then also, like you
kind of mentioned earlier, the 11:00
reversal timing of thinking, okay, well,
maybe this will reverse at kind of 11:00
and we'll start to get some movement up,
especially since it's kind of has shown
a slow in momentum here. And so I
actually jumped in on a long right here
because the whole time I was kind of
watching this. I was thinking, okay, I
want to see it make a higher high. Like
it made a higher low here, but I didn't
get long because I wanted to see it
making, you know, cuz in a spot like
this, I'd want more confirmation because
it's more likely it just keeps going
down. You know, every time it makes a
new high, it's lower and lower. And so I
think confirmation of it changing that
is when it kind of breaks this. And so
like it broke this, pulled back and then
actually it kind of held this which I
thought was a good sign. Kind of what we
were talking about earlier of like
coming back to the previous swing and
now
>> test to see if it wants to go low.
>> Yeah. Now realizing okay that's support.
So I actually bought in at the high this
candlestick. Um and then it you know
barely made a new high and then kind of
reverse lower from there. Um, and I I
think like this is a good read for like
the trend potentially shifting, but big
picture like kind of in hindsight a
little bit for me was my mistakes were
staying too long. And then also I do
have a pretty common rule that I follow
is uh if it's trended down like that
long and that bit like this is a huge
sell-off actually from here to here even
though you know fits on my screen like
this is pretty much 50 points um which
in the ES is like a huge move and so you
know and like going off up here right
like this is a huge move really fast.
>> Yeah. um that has a lot of momentum and
and there is the idea of like oh it is
unhealthy but the same idea with this
move up being unhealthy the day before
like I I didn't even think about trying
to bet this to the short side with the
idea that okay well more likely these
kind of moves
>> it's just trucking up. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's well it's got so much
momentum and it almost needs overnight
to
work off and then it'll flip. Um I think
literally our last session we were
talking about this.
>> Yeah, we were.
>> And I was like, "Oh, it probably is
gonna either reverse tomorrow or, you
know, maybe midday or the next day." Um
which is kind of funny now looking at in
hindsight how it just ripped the next
day. So it's like usually it takes
something like that and even here it's
like okay, it sold off the whole day. It
had a little bit of a bounce into the
end of the day just because it got so
overextended, but you know, then it it
the major trend kind of came into play
and and it did like kind of come back
50% of this move.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is like a healthy pullback in the
trend before it continues lower. Big
picture.
>> Yeah. No, I think I think cuz at that
same spot that you got in, I was looking
and just had some notes to that were
like, "Oh, this looks like a good spot."
Like it's broken that little channel, so
it's changing trends. And especially
when like I think my chart was probably
zoomed in even a little bit more to
cover essentially I don't know call like
530. So what is that 8:30 onwards and so
in this it doesn't look like too crazy
of a down or anything like that. It
looks much more plausible that like oh
yeah can looks like a great spot for a
reversal.
>> Yeah. I mean, it could it could have
totally done. Like, you know, it's like
it totally could have, but I feel like
in my it's like that's where it's the
good lesson of um getting too sucked
into the smaller time frame and reading
to the one minute chart.
>> Yeah.
>> When if you just glance at the bigger
picture, you know, uh uh I mean, I think
it was pretty much if I try and make
sure I get the the pricing right on
this, it was pretty much here. And it's
like that is, you know, for me like
that's in the middle of the main range,
like there's no like even though it's
giving this move back up as a good
target, that's a target for a trade
you're in. I don't use that as
necessarily a level. Um,
>> and so like to me there's just no reason
to bet long there um in hindsight and
and really reading what the market's
telling you, you know, and so it's hard
sometimes to, you know, you make
mistakes though and that's part of
trading like you just you get sucked in
or or you stay too long. That's why, you
know, that's why I don't like to stay
long is because I like a long period of
time trading because it's like it gives
makes me way more likely to just get
sucked in and FOMO into something or
just make a bad decision like that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Something I think I wrote
down either that day or the next was
like don't think in terms of I want it
to blank. Think in terms of let's see if
it does blank. So rather mean like okay
I want it to give me another little
bounce or another top. I want it to do
this. just be like, "Let's see if this
happens." Because I think if the like I
want it to, I'm I feel like I'm more
likely trying to read it or make it
happen. Yeah. Being like, "Oh, that
looks like maybe that's my bounce or
maybe that's this rather than just did
it actually do that." You're just adding
bias onto what's happening.
>> Another thing I think too is like trying
to think of like for this example of
like, okay, as it's coming down to this
area, you know, it's like, okay, it's
still clearly in a move down. is still
making lower lows and lower highs, but
we're near a zone, you know, like we're
near
>> Yeah.
>> in the sense of like I know there's
potential coming soon like you're
saying. And so instead of like, oh, I
want it to do this. Another thing I
think about is like to get in a trade,
what would I want to see? You know, it's
like it's not like I want it to do this
or I need it to do this. It's more of
like I'm only going to get in if it does
blank kind of thing versus um yeah, I
mean trying to essentially the main idea
is trying to have it pre-planned out of
what you want to see to execute your
plan and so you're waiting for the
market to come to your already figured
out idea versus oh I'm just kind of
sitting here watching it all of a sudden
and then oh shoot it it you know it did
this big candlestick here I better just
jump in long and you you know, bet that
it's going to go higher.
>> Hope. Yeah.
>> Cuz that just, you know, you don't want
to be reactionary to the market, right?
>> No. What do you How do you trade around
when it seems like the market obviously
it's not hitting new lows, but when it's
hitting like lows that it hasn't been at
for a while?
>> I think we kind of talked about this
last time, at least with highs.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. like here in this downtrend like
we broke this big level and so it's like
okay well there's I don't really have a
you know even I scroll back on a daily
chart or something like there's no
support
>> there's nothing for a long time. Yeah
>> it's kind of just like yeah you just got
to wait and I mean if it once it puts
this in like even here I'll say okay
I'll draw a level here and see when it
comes down here I'll look for it to
react on this cuz it's like okay well
maybe it double bottoms and I can get
like a little trade right here. Um, but
then otherwise, yeah, it's just kind of
waiting cuz it it doesn't happen very
often, at least in the market conditions
we're right now. But when it does, like
it, you know, it just even with this,
like if this was an uptrend into new
all-time highs, and you would, you know,
you would just be saying, okay, well,
there's, you know, this high that it's
pulled back from, I'm going to see how
it reacted there, and then it does this,
right? If the market opened up here, and
then it moves along and you say, okay,
well, there's a new high put in. I'm
going to little double top. I'm going to
put it in a level there. And then as
time goes on, you know, I'd only draw
this about after this kind of stuff
here.
>> Yeah.
>> And then same thing of like, okay, well,
it's got this, you know, like this
morning, right? Had this like little
bracket. And so you go into the day with
that now. But that's just how you, you
know, over time would update your levels
and then, you know, delete them or you
can even say, well, this even matched
with that high.
>> Looking back on, I mean, yeah, we
essentially talked about it on the high
side, you know. So, it's very back back
to the what we were just talking about
of the like I want it to I want to trade
in this rather than just let's let's
wait for everything to happen and unfold
in front of us.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> I guess there's this trade from last
week too that I entered that we could
briefly talk about.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> So, this is when the market was pretty
much right here. I think it opened up
like this. And so, like we were still
kind of in a downtrend. And so the
thought was like once it kind of got up
to here, I think this is kind of where
the the short was there. It did kind of
break this, but my thought was like,
okay, well, we've kind of come up to
here. And maybe this is, you know, me
not sometimes being a little aggressive
about the levels I draw. Um, but
thinking, okay, well, had this move
down.
>> What do you What do you mean by that?
>> Um, I think maybe looking for levels in
spots where
>> Okay. it's not as clean, you know, like
like quick examples here for this one.
It's like, okay, we had this sell-off
here and we've given up that move kind
of exactly like that that last loss I
did was like, okay, well, here's a
target for this move, but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a good spot to
short.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, you know, like like I was talking
about over here as it came down here and
like using this as a target, it's not
necessarily a good shot. Like it's
basically in the middle of this range.
>> Yeah.
>> Betting this. It's kind of same thing
here of like well it's given this move
back up but big picture it's kind of
like there's just some gerble garble
here or whatever like there's not clean
swings versus like you know today this
morning right like there's this is very
clear this is very clear like even
though it's a small range like the
levels
>> this has been the most clear that I've
seen
>> yeah like these were clean um and so
that's where it's like again the you
know I can always work on being more
patient too but if you can just be more
patient and be like, "Oh, this is a
spot, but I'm just not going to, you
know, it's just not a good level. I'm
just going to wait." Um, you're you're
probably going to be more profitable.
But again, it's it can be hard because
like here it's like there's so much
movement and you're not taking trades
and it sometimes it gets the better of
you, right? Um
>> Yeah.
>> But so that's where this zone was, I
think, or I was like looking at this low
here thinking like, okay, well, it had
this kind of bounce range. Um, and so
that's kind of what this level was here.
And so the market broke out of that and
came lower. And we're actually at a good
timing. Like, you know, 9:30 market
opens, it kind of just shot up, which
was a nice spike. And then it just went
into this kind of trend. Um, and what
made me like this was it had kind of a
spike up here and such a big pullback.
>> Yeah.
>> Of good momentum and kind of breaking
below this kind of chop it had. And so
my thinking is, you know, it's it's kind
of making that head and shoulders right
here. Um or makes a new low, pulls back.
I kind of see how the market reacts to
this pullback. Um and then I think this
if it goes down, you know, it opens the
door to this.
>> Yeah, you're waiting for that
candlestick to close below the green one
and then you would get in.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think
>> the basic idea. Yeah, I think I was just
watching it, but like the idea was,
yeah, I put in a stop order here. Um,
and then was going to see how because
it's like, okay, I think this is a good
enough attempt, especially this
candlestick right here. Like, as it's
forming, I'm thinking, well, if it's
going to make a double bottom here, this
is probably the candle because it's
showing some strength right here and
attempts to go higher, that's probably
the candlestick that's going to do it.
But because that over this candlestick
that essentially fails, you know, then
it's like, okay, well, I think if it
breaks this, that's great to the
downside. And you know, there's a little
bit of
>> would real quick, would you not want to
wait for it to finish forming a candle
that is like at the end of this
candlestick, get in with a buy below it?
>> You can. I think sometimes without
having like a real good rule for each,
sometimes I'll wait and sometimes I
won't. I think often generally it's I'll
wait if it does like a big spike and I
want to see how it the market reacts to
that or if it's like I'm a little
doubtful. I want to see how and I think
the market's just going to fake lower
and go higher. I'll see how it, you
know, essentially breaks this new low.
If it's just going to break it in
reverse and like you said, I put a stop
or or my entry kind of below this
candlestick here. Um, but like if I if
it already has done like a pullback and
I'm I'm confident and kind of happy with
where things are at, then I'll just kind
of get in at the break of a new low cuz,
you know, for me, like that's making a
new low and that's kind of confirming
that this is a lower high and the head
and shoulders is in play.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I I thought it opened the door
up to down here. Um, I do think that my
one thing was thinking, okay, well,
there is because this, you know, this is
where the unhealthy move is before that.
I think kind of here is a potential
support level. Um, and so,
>> just cuz it started being more calm
there.
>> Yeah, cuz it was like this was a healthy
trend.
>> Yeah.
>> And so my thought is, okay, well, it's
showing reversal signs up here. Maybe
we'll get a healthy trend down. And if
it breaks this, like you can see I drew
that level. If it breaks that, then I
think we'll get the flush lower. Um, so
that's where like a little bit of a risk
in entering this is compared to like if
if the head and shoulders happen right
here and you're able to get in short as
it breaks kind of this, those are the
best trades because there's like there's
just nothing in the way and it will
just, you know, crater super fast. Like
those are when I get trades where it's
like it's over in like five minutes or
something and it's crazy. versus here
it's like you kind of got to let it
develop.
>> And so here it made this little pullback
and I thought, okay, I'll move my stop
down because it essentially made a swing
low. And then here it's like, okay, I'm
watching to see if it does a double
bottom. Um cuz it's
>> in which case you just slam it closed.
>> Yeah. Or move it down more.
>> Um Yeah. And I mean like this looks
super good right here. Like this attempt
to go higher big bearish candlestick and
it's saying no. It's literally like it's
made a new low and it's basically
breaking this support, but it actually
ends up I think pretty much just here
just and so here it's tricky because
like I don't want to close out yet cuz
like it did make a new low and like this
was a nice swing. Sometimes it's like
you just got to let it do its thing.
Like I've already taken some risk off
and I'm happy with this level. Like it
could totally spike here and sell off.
Um,
>> yeah.
>> And so, you know, I made the conscious
decision to be like, okay, I'm happy
with if I lose, you know, 900 bucks, I'm
happy with that. I I think it was okay
moving it my stop from down from there
cuz at this point, if it does such if it
makes a new high, I would just want to
get out like it's probably
>> back up. Yeah.
>> Um, but there's so many times where
like, you know, this if it's going to go
down like this high would hold like even
if it pulls back here and then goes
down. And so that's why, you know, when
it's it's like here and it's starting to
look, you know, I even drew that little
line and it's starting to like make a
spike up like this, I don't close out a
break even just with the idea that, you
know, it's like I think the trade is
still valid and it it could spike up and
go lower. Like you just don't want to
overage work.
>> Yeah. You got to have, you know, it's
like you can't I don't think you can
take the risk off until like it's down
in this area for this particular trade.
But that's, you know, that's like
something that'll just take time to get
better at.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We got to get to entering
trades first.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, that's really interesting, though.
>> Yeah. I mean, I guess we could we could
do entering stuff and get you kind of
like spooled up on that.
>> Let's do some of that. I know I still
need to watch I don't know the second
part of your course that's more aimed
at, I think, entries and some
management.
>> Okay. So I can at least watch some
entries part of it cuz I think you go
over it like quickly in the first part
and then you're like I have more
detailed videos later.
>> Yeah. Let me just send you my
indicators.
>> My courses. All courses. Yeah. I don't
have the indicators unlocked on your
website.
>> Okay. So we we're just going to do the
three main ones. And for these
indicators, um anyone else that wants
them, you can I'll leave a link for them
in the description below. Um, you want
to go to to install them now, you want
to go to just your main control center
near Ninja Trader main control center.
>> Yep.
>> And then go to
tools, import, and then ninjas script
add-on, and then that file you have
that's like a zip file. Um, you're going
to want to find out wherever that is.
Usually, you want to save it somewhere.
Don't save it, uh, for like PCs and
stuff. Don't put it in like your one
drive folder. Um,
just cuz that messes things up. you want
it locally stored on your computer and
then just double click and essentially
open the zip file with the import
option. I gave you kind of like a
special packaged one. So I don't know if
that's going to work or not. If it
doesn't, we can do a different way, but
let me know when it's like says import
successful.
>> Successfully imported.
>> Just right click on the chart and go to
indicators.
>> Yep.
>> And then do you see this at the top?
There's like a little evolved traders
file.
>> I do. Okay. And then you should have the
bar timer in there.
>> Yep.
>> Double click that. That'll add it to the
chart.
>> Just apply.
>> Yeah. Well, no, just just
>> Oh, just Okay, got it.
>> And then double click the click trader
as well. And I think that's kind of the
two you have there. Yeah. And then so
you should have those two. And then just
the default settings is totally fine.
You don't have to do anything with them.
And then you can just click okay. And
you should now have like this box on the
right side and then this little
countdown timer right next to your
candlesticks. Okay, I see the countdown
timer. I don't see the box. We also we
closed out of whatever the thing that
says like buy, sell, everything like
that.
>> Oh, so you just need to go up to here
and turn the chart trader back on.
>> Okay. Yeah, now I see.
>> Okay. How it works basically is if you
hold shift and I'm going to switch to
SIM account so I don't actually enter in
an order. You can click it like pretty
much and then left click on the chart,
it'll put in um an order. And then if
you do control a buy order and then if
you do control it'll do sell um
settings that might mess that up for
you. I don't if you you see primary
order here and secondary order.
>> Yeah,
>> those you want to put as stock market as
your primary order and I like to do MIT
which means market if touched as your
secondary order.
>> So market of touched is if it hits that
it just trades.
>> Yeah. So essentially if you put a a
market if touched buy order below the
price if the market just comes down here
and touches that yeah it'll put in a
market order basically that'll
automatically buy at the best available
price. So essentially the idea with that
is okay well if I'm putting this in and
the market touches here I want to get in
because it's at a price I want. I don't
care if it um slips on me a tiny bit.
And slippage is like if you, you know,
if the market's moving so quickly, it'll
fill you at a price that you didn't
necessarily enter in. Like this is the
price of this order is at 696075
and if it slipped, it would enter in at
something else. Like let's say I'll just
move this for simplicity sake, but it
like slips all the way up here to 6150.
like that would be a a worse entry for a
buy order because you originally you'd
be trying to buy down here but that very
rarely happens generally when the
market's like extremely volatile. Um and
actually if you go to indicators again I
would say you do want to try and um if
you click on the click trader once
you've changed that market if touched
button um also you can actually change
the hotkeys on here. I if you don't want
your sell like the hotkey to trigger a
sell order um you can change it from
control or if you don't want the um buy
order to be shift you can change those
to other items or other hotkeys but for
me shift and control just I find works
and then of course at the bottom like
just click on the template button to
save as your default so it always has
those
>> is it then set up as on bar close.
>> Yeah. So that just allows you to again
like when you know like in these trades
like when I say okay well I want to I
see this candlestick here right and my
signal is that I want to buy above this
candlestick I'll just hold left shift
and put a buy order right there so that
as soon as it if it does and as soon as
it does reverse it'll get in an order
exactly at that point. So I generally
just get in on stop orders.
>> Okay. So shift and just click
>> shift and then left click. Yeah, with
your mouse.
>> It's not doing it.
>> Do you have an Oh, you need to Okay, you
don't have an ATM. This, I'm assuming,
says none.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Sorry. Um, you need to go and I think
your option will either be do this
dropown menu and click custom and it
should bring this up.
>> Okay.
>> Um, so you don't need the order quantity
doesn't you don't have to mess with
that. Change the parameters to ticks and
then your stop loss and profit target. I
just do this to um like if I'm trading
the the ES generally I'll just say okay
I want to my profit target to be let's
say um I'll just put it in oh it doesn't
have points okay um yeah you can do this
like 60 here for a profit target and um
like 30 for a stop loss and then just
click okay actually no you want to save
the template um I'll just save it as
test and you don't really need to change
anything else
>> okay yeah it should work now
>> okay Um, and then you can just click so
if it's here, you can just click buy
market actually to test it. Um, and then
you can see it'll pretty much
automatically put these orders for you.
And that's what the stop loss and profit
is. You're essentially that number we
put in there is saying, okay, this is
going to be 30 ticks away from your
entry. I think the stop was 30 ticks
away and then this is going to be 60
ticks away.
>> Okay. So that's setting your essentially
one to two.
>> Yeah. And then your your risk loss
calculator does all that for you, right?
>> Yeah, we'll get that into that in a
second. Um,
>> yeah.
>> And so, well, so I always try and have
these just far away because the idea is
like, okay, yeah, we'll we'll talk about
this in a second is like I have the the
risk calculator I'll always have drawn
and then I'll just say, okay, it's here.
essentially like especially with these
it's like I want them far away from the
actual price in a safe way cuz then you
know it doesn't take long but you know a
couple seconds to be like okay here's
actually where I want my stop and then
here's actually where I want my target.
>> Oh got it. Okay.
>> Um you know I'll essentially move those.
Yeah. And then so just to kind of close
this out and then yeah the next thing is
the is yeah the riskreward calculator.
Um because this will automatically
update how your order quantity needs to
do based on your target amount. Um, so
first thing is well just to see if it
imported if you go to drawing tools
here, right click and drawing tools. Do
you see it right here at the bottom?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Okay. So that will essentially pull it
up. Um, and I think first thing is
actually if you go back to your control
center. We want to go to tools and
hotkeys just so then you can put I
because I don't think when we originally
set up hotkeys this was available.
>> No. So, if you scroll all the way down
to bottom, um, it should be there now.
>> Perfect.
>> Okay. And then from there, do you have
this drawn up now? Resource rule.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. And then doubleclick on it to
bring up properties. And then a couple
things I believe that the default
doesn't have on it is um you can set
your risk here. So, you know, when
you're starting out demo trading, I
would always try and just do like uh let
me see if I go to um the MEES right now,
which is what you' be trading. Um and
let's say like you try and risk $50 a
trade, like I think that's a great
starting point. So, like $50 a trade
definitely gives you some wiggle room.
trading if you're trading small enough
like if you were only trying to risk $20
a trade sometimes you would be you know
one contract would be too big like here
if if I was going to enter in like this
this morning you know when we were
talking about this like if I was if this
off here and I got in below this like
and you're trying to only risk $20 like
it it would be too much but like with 50
bucks like you're you're much better
there's more flexibility same thing with
like this long down here you know you're
it's going to be sometimes you're it's
going to be harder to get the right
target amount of risk. But that's just
kind of how it goes, especially when
you're kind of just starting out with
sizing and and you don't have the
flexibility of contracts. So, yeah, set
your risk currency to $50 here. Um, and
then I usually have you want strict risk
clicked off and then I usually have
unrestricted risk at like 10 or 15%. Um,
and what that does is it allows your
risk to go over whatever you set. So
like you set at $50 and this is saying
you can go 15% over that. Um, you know,
with $50 it's not that's not crazy
amount. It's literally 650 or whatever
this is allowing you to do. Um, once it
goes over that, it'll say, you know,
zero contracts and then it will be like,
okay, you're over your risk amount. You
could always set that to be a little
more if you're like, "Hey, like I want I
want to get in a trade if it's
especially when you're trading crazy
small risk like this." If you're like,
"Okay, well, I want to take a trade if
it's like I'm fine taking a trade if
it's like 60 or $75 risk," then you can
up this. But like once you get larger
size, I would definitely reduce that
down because you don't need to be going
crazy over your risk amount.
>> This is a dumb question. It doesn't want
to let me move it around very well. When
you click on it, you have to I have to
click on this line to select it. And
then it should have these little
circles.
>> Okay, there we go. That's working
better. Yeah, I see the circles.
>> Yeah, I I you can't really select the
colored lines. You have to click on the
gray line.
>> Okay.
>> Um I don't remember if this is the
default color settings either, but you
change them down here. Okay.
>> What is moving the circles around do?
>> I mean, it basically just remove moves
where the anchor is. like it's just kind
of like it it has kind of like a default
size, but it just helps like visualize
visualize it. Okay.
>> Like where you want and then obviously
like vertically changes um how it works.
The last big thing is um you want this
this auto set quality is always off by
default. You need to click that on and
then that should be the last setting. If
you want to increase how many profit
targets you have, pretty much you just
have to do the same grammar that it has
set up here in this little ratios box,
you can literally just copy paste and
add a four.
>> Okay.
>> Um, and I think if anyone's on the
European or just non-American, it's
slightly different how it's set in
there. Um, but you know, that adds you
another target if you want to see that.
And then of course uh actually in there
there is also um you can change this to
not have essentially price or or a
dollar amount of the risk. You can just
change it to price or or something but
usually riskreward the default setting
works for me. And then that auto set
quantity makes it so this automatically
updates like you were saying. So like if
if I you know one contract it changes
this. So like if you then make it
smaller this automatically updates to
three. Right. So you
>> got it. Okay. It's super easy to say,
okay, well, I'm going to put my stop
loss here and my target here, and if I'm
trying to target roughly $50 of risk on
this trade based on that size of a
stoploss, how many contracts do I trade?
Because when the market moves, you know,
and and where that is, like that changes
like here, from here to here is $50. Um,
and you don't want to just be trading
two contracts every time because down
here it actually takes three contracts
to do that same risk, right? So, that's
like the huge thing about it that makes
it so easy to just use this and say,
"Okay, well, my risk is here. You know,
it's $50. I'm going to just put my my
order right here and with my shiftclick
hotkey." And so, it makes entering in
like super fast. Um, so these are like
insanely big quality of life upgrades, I
would say. And then, you know, with the
hotkey and the default, you know, here's
my mine defaulted to my normal size.
Then you switch over to the because
we're on the micro, you know, E right
now, you would switch over to the normal
size
>> be what? 4.5 or something.
>> Yeah, it just it just default to because
you can't trade half a contract. It just
default to four contracts.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, any other entry questions?
That's that should be pretty much the
main setup.
>> I don't think so. I think that's the
that's the nuts and bolts. It seems like
it's just getting better and
understanding exactly what I'm looking
for.
>> Yeah. in terms of reversal patterns cuz
I mean like so far most of what we've
been looking at and what I've been
looking at is the like larger sets of
candlesticks and what they're all saying
together and this is much more what is
this specific candlestick say and how
are these three candlesticks interacting
together.
>> Yeah. And one thing I actually to bring
back up about the drawing tool is
visually what it does very easily to
mess with your mind is you know like
let's say for here right the signal to
jump in on this trade was here and the
stop would be here because that's where
the swing was and so for this trade um
you know I would I would draw my tool
right here because this is you know one
tick below here and then I' I'd enter
here right and so you know it's it's
targeting my risk I I would you know put
my order in here and I'd wait to get in.
>> Okay. So, you're putting it you're
putting it one the bottom is one tick
lower.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Technically, I like to do it
one tick below cuz I like then that's
officially broken that low. Same thing
with this high. It's officially broken
that high when it's one tick above. Um
okay.
>> But so the thing that can mess with your
mind is, you know, it's like, okay,
well, I'm going to get in on a stop
order here. But if I enter in down here,
if I just enter in on a buy order, a
buy, you know, on a pullback, that
allows me to, you know, you would adjust
this down and you can start to say,
well, I would hit 3x right here. I can
get, you know, 10 more contracts, you
know, like just the the ratio, like your
riskreward ratio, you know, from
entering in here, you would be up 2x
when it's at that price versus if you
entered in here, you'd be up 3x. Um, and
so it's very easy to like not get in or
instead of putting in that stop order,
you put in um, you know, a a buy limit
order down here and wait for the market
to come back and fill you if it does.
And, you know, you run the risk of it
not coming back and filling you and just
shooting up. Or I mean if this case it
it broke up and then you'd wait for a
pullback, but sometimes if you just wait
for it to pull back versus not, you
know, you want to get in essentially
when the signal happens, bottom line. Um
I'm sure there's ways to maximize things
in more ways, but like at the end of the
day, it's better just get in with the
signal and you know, your your
maximizing is going to be sizing down
the road. Uh yeah,
>> because like at the end of the day, the
goal is to just capture some of this
move. Um, and even though at your
current size it's like, well, I would
be, you know, up X amount here versus if
I entered it here, I would be up way
less, you know, I'd be up 2x instead of
3x. And it's like, well, you're still up
money and you're getting in. You're, you
know, you're not trying to like I just
had times in the past where I'll try and
play with that. And it just again, it
just it just adds another layer of just
where you make mistakes and mess things
up. And then if you if you miss it and
you don't get in or whatever, like it
just messes with your mind and your
ability to just do clean executions.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> I think that's all I have on entries
unless you have any other questions. I
don't think so, especially not for nuts
and bolts. I mean, the main thing is
just trying to figure out exactly what
I'm looking for in terms of patterns or
trying to understand the couple
candlesticks that go together. And some
of that might be,
>> but I think that a lot of that really
comes up when it's like you start
actually trading and it's like, you
know, it's like you actually have to
make that decision of like, oh, I'm
going to enter in here. And even, you
know, even when it's like demo trading,
it's like you're still taking that
making that decision versus just kind of
watching the candlesticks print.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I guess last week was pretty
exciting with having that big trade go
on and you kind of practicing with
>> Yeah. my first fake real trade.
>> Yeah.
>> Real fake trade.
>> Getting used to like what that might
look like and actually pulling the
trigger on some of that stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I feel like I wasn't great
about going and doing my homework from
last week. Um, I did spend some time
flipping through um some of your like
videos in the course which I felt were
honestly like is super helpful to go
back and revisit those videos cuz the
first time I watched them through it was
very much a like just trying to get an
understanding of the strategy and a
little bit of what's happening so that
when I start looking at the charts I
have some idea of what I'm doing. But
re-watching them was super useful cuz
it's like, "Okay, now I have more
understanding of what I'm doing and more
understanding now of what Riley's saying
in his videos and coursework."
>> That makes sense. Like you can connect
the dots a little bit better.
>> Yeah. So, if anybody is also going
through this, highly recommend
re-watching some videos.
>> Helps a lot. Okay. Um, yeah. Yeah. So, I
mean, I guess we can if you want to walk
we can walk through that kind of trade
and then like you can kind of see what
you were thinking when you saw it and
kind of talk about stuff like that and
I'm sure there's some other questions
and spots we can talk about.
>> Yeah. 212 I had a question of like was
there an entry that day? Was there a
spot where you could trade? Okay. So
from my perspective, I guess starting
out more big picture, um
the market had kind of come up and
gotten itself into this little channel
that we're seeing there.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it just kind of been dinking back
and forth in the channel.
>> And so I think we start off the day
>> starts the day off at the high of the
channel. Yeah, it starts off the day at
the high and like in pre-m morning
trading it had done that giant like
candle and push up um which looks very
unhealthy. So it kind of comes up
touches it initially.
>> Yeah, right at the open.
>> Yeah, right at the open. Um and looking
at looking at it so this was I guess
kind of one of the first most of the
time when I've been looking at it I've
just started with like okay properly
start looking at what's happening once
the the market opens. Um, and this was
one of the first days where I properly
kind of looked at, okay, it's already
made some moves or made part of the like
come up, test the level, sell off a
little bit, retest. Yeah. Um, and then
give that back up. And so it did some of
that before market open.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and so I had a little bit of a trend
line drawn from, I don't know, the 845
mark through Yeah. through there. And so
when it came down, broke that. I was
like, "Okay, step one, be at a
resistance zone. Step two, break the
trend line and break it in a manner
that's meaningful." And then watched it
for a little bit and it just kind of
kept going down and was this
consolidation did that kind of spike up
and immediately rejection.
>> Mhm.
>> Um, which I thought was pretty strong
for not wanting to continue higher. I
also think the way I had my support zone
drawn was slightly higher and so the tip
of that candle really touched the bottom
of my support level
>> like this your resistance level.
>> Yeah. I'm sorry. Resistance level. Yeah.
Um and so it kind of to me touched it
again was like nope not feeling that
continues lower for a little bit. Has
that bar has a couple more and then I
had um it's kind of forms a little bit
of a trend line there with one or two
more. H maybe I drew that afterwards.
Um, but I just had a note in there just
being like needs to see how it reacts to
a low here and then obviously decides to
keep pushing. Um, and so my thought was,
okay, here it is. It's formed its like
it had its first shoulder at 9:00 a.m.
before open. At 9:30, it's had its head
and then it set a new a lower low and a
lower high as well. And so it's really
formed that nice like head and
shoulders. Um, and so then when it then
has a little bit of a nicer candlestick,
actually, it's not even that nice of a
candlestick, but push down below that
low of
>> yeah,
>> of the shoulder, um, it seemed like it
was going to start going, especially as,
okay, it's been healthy moving up. It's
kind of touched the support zone. It's
done its whole nice head and shoulders
thing. And then I essentially decided to
enter somewhere around there with my
riskreward. I probably didn't I don't
think I necessarily put my um exit zone
in the right spot, but yeah, I I got in
there and then just watched it kind of
go down and I I just had a note of like
it seems kind of sloppy how it's all set
up. Um but all the basic principles are
there. What we talked about the day
before was there and then I kind of just
sat in it and watched it go down for
>> Yeah. And just kind of lower. Nice. I
mean it's you know it's still whole like
main principles basically spotting the
top. Yeah.
>> And waiting for those confirmations and
then you know like actually entering in
trades and stuff like you'll get more
practice with that actually cuz like you
didn't actually enter in an order,
right?
>> No, no, I just Yeah.
>> kind of like went like mine's being a
little funky with that. Yeah. So I just
did my riskreward and then just left it
there and didn't touch it.
>> And I slowly I slowly wrote in notes of
like okay moved my stop brick to here
and then moved it here and then had it
theoretically get stopped off at
>> Yeah. I wouldn't like slow down.
>> Nice. So, yeah. And I guess the next
thing would be like are you would you be
able to enter in orders this next coming
week cuz that'll definitely be helpful
to start doing that too.
>> Yeah, I think I should be able to.
>> I guess the interesting thing about this
setup that was a little different was
like it wasn't, you know, the market
opens and then did a big selloff and
then you look for like, you know, 30
minutes after and for it to reverse.
>> Yeah. versus like it kind of did that
like you were saying before the market
and then it just kind of opened and it
was like so there wasn't really that
timing of like oh looking for a reversal
at like 15 minutes or 30 minutes after
the open. It was more of just like this
the unhealthy moves already happened and
I'm just watching the structure
breakdown and you know it looks like
that's going to cause the market to move
this direction this this morning.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um and then I think yeah the
other the other tricky thing about this
trade was this like chop like getting in
on that was um abnormal [snorts]
or funky you know but again it was like
yeah
>> just looking at the the main picture and
you know just being like oh I think that
big picture is going to play out
essentially.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I was definitely like it
seems sloppy and weird and not
necessarily super clean, but it's like
still sticking to as you were saying the
big principles of like all right, it's
done your it's at your your ceiling or
resistance zone. It's broken a trend.
It's done its like head and shoulders
thing.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it's gone through and broken
the low of your head and shoulders.
>> Yeah. And then that was a nice signal to
get in. I also think when I was looking
at this because that gave me a little
doubt with this trade of like oh it is
kind of acting a little choppy but when
I was looking at a five minute like this
is pretty much I think where it was when
I got in and on a fivem minute like this
looks amazing to me. Um
>> and just to try and articulate why it
looks amazing is because there's you
know this this I would say is the big
unhealthy move right here this
candlestick. And so I when I see it is
like okay once it breaks like this is
kind of a minor support and once it
breaks this I think it's going to move
down really quickly to at least to here
and then you know maybe it slowly moves
down to the rest of the way or it or it
just shoots down as well cuz the
momentum is just crazy. That like gap
there I think is like what's really
strong for these trades is when there is
no you know there's no candlesticks like
that could support it. Like here it's
like there's here there's back and forth
in these candlesticks and that's why it
was kind of slow to get going when it
went moved down and it's like it these
like swings are really clear to see on a
fivem minute as well and so that that
gave me a ton of confidence and like the
just the the structure of it looks so
good.
>> Yeah, that's something I didn't do was
flip over to look at the five minute
chart that I think would have been
really useful just for having a beat
like that. All right, it drowns out a
lot of the noise.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And lets it appear much more obvious.
>> Yeah, cuz Yeah, I think it's super
obvious here. But then, yeah, if you
look at this, you're like, "Oh, well,
what about like these 20 candles here
who are just super choppy versus being
like, oh, that's just that's nothing
right here. That's just a little move
and it's clearly going to get going
lower."
>> One of my questions, I think, from that
day was any reason why not to enter? So
obviously most of the time when you you
see one of these and you take it on
either the ES or NQ, why not enter on
both just because it's essentially
doubling down or just gives you more to
manage and think about.
>> You're just doubling down I would say
like you know they're so correlated like
if we pull up both of these like
>> they look basically the same and so it's
like yeah you're just doubling down like
it's either going to work out or it's
not. So, it's like why not just double
down on one and I you know it's like and
some of them do move better like if you
like really look at okay the NASDAQ I
think let's see if I try and look at the
exact candle stick I entered in on I
think I entered in pretty much here on
this candlestick at 54 and so you know I
put my entry there and my stop there and
if we go to 54 that's this candlestick
and I would have put my stop up here you
know we look at this and trying to then
I just pull the chart to see where it
actually went like this got down to I
pretty much got out here at 3x and then
same thing if we look at it here it
would have been actually pretty much the
same thing 3x so it's like now there's a
little contract issue like NASDAQ is
actually larger of an asset so to try
and get you know my target is $1,500 of
risk and so one contract was $1,200 so I
couldn't trade two cuz I would have been
$2,400 00 versus the ES I I did three
contracts at 1650 risk which I'm fine
you know I'm fine doing that a little
extra risk to get a little more closer
to that 1500 and so on the ES actually I
would have made more money and so that's
something I've actually realized why I
like to trade ES over the NASDAQ is
because generally you can trade more
contracts which for the size depending
on what size you're at um generally it's
a little more flexible um for either
either.
>> Could you could you just do the micros
instead?
>> Yeah, I could. Um, but the problem is
then I would be trading on the NASDAQ
what it probably be like 15 micros. It's
like that the fees when it comes to
trading that it starts to get a lot like
I was trading like 15 micros for a while
because of that adjustment, but once you
kind of get into this territory like you
don't want to be trading 20 or 30 like
it's just it's not worth it.
>> Yeah. Starts racking up fees.
>> Yeah. and you want to I mean they're not
crazy big and especially if you're like
not trading often and like your accuracy
is good but you know it adds up.
>> What's the I could probably Google this
as well but what's the difference in
value of ticks between the ES and
NASDAQ?
>> The NASDAQ is $5 a tick and the ES is
$1250. Okay.
>> So that's why it's like there's that
discrepancy.
>> Yeah, there's a discrepancy in number of
>> Yeah. Well, because you know like the
NASDAQ is moving 100 actually this this
move was like 300 points versus the ES
was let's see 80
70 for so but like at the end of the day
the correlation like just trade one I
the NASDAQ people would say is more
volatile but from my experience whenever
they're moving the same which is when I
want to trade like I like them to be
moving the same if they're if they're
not sticking together which is I think
one of the days actually we'll talk
about um when they're you know diverging
and different like they're just not
worth trading. Um so even though people
say the NASDAQ is more volatile for this
strategy I find it to be the difference
doesn't make it any any difference.
>> Yeah. And I guess another question I had
was a little bit of like do you ever
find there's much of a lag between them?
I mean even if it's just like a couple
candles in their movements. So if like
the if the ES is leading the trend and
then the NQ is following, is there
anything you can take advantage of in
that of essentially like okay well I can
further guess that it's going to go down
here or is that kind of just like I
guess in some ways you're just trying to
>> um fancy and optimize.
>> Yeah. like yeah that's what I sometimes
I think yeah you could almost just not
look at the NASDAQ um or just don't I I
mean I like to look at them in the sense
of like I want them to be trending the
same way you know again that I want that
alignment but in terms of yeah like
you're trying to see like oh if one's
leading you know like easy example that
I've tried to do is like oh well if the
ES is acting more bearish like
technically this made a new low when you
know the NASDAQ at this point hadn't,
you know, it was actually it made it
didn't make a new low yet. It was just
actually more in this choppy range. And
so, in that sense, the thought is like,
oh, well, I should get in on the the ES
here because it's acting more bearish,
so it's more likely to sell off more.
Uh, or vice versa. You know, if the
NASDAQ's acting stronger and I want to
get in a long, I should get in a long on
the NASDAQ. I would say I have never
found that to work out well. Um, same
thing with like trying to be like, "Oh,
well, the ES made a new low, but the
NASDAQ hadn't, but I like the NASDAQ, so
I should use that as a signal to confer
my short on the NASDAQ." I don't think
that's the case. The what I will do
sometimes though is if I like a trade on
like let's say I like a short on the ES
here, but the NASDAQ is just still
trending higher. often in that sense I
will say well I want to wait for the
NASDAQ to start showing that it's making
a trend down as well in the sense of you
want them to be both aligned like you
want them to be both putting a short
signal out to bet lower um cuz otherwise
what can happen in cases is um the
NASDAQ could be super strong and just
drag the ES up like even if the ES is
down here and you think it's going to go
lower it could just get slowly dragged
up and the NASDAQ is just like rocketing
throughout the day just because, you
know, for some reason tech is doing
really well that day. You know, tech is
huge amount in the S&P 500 and so it's
just going to drag the market up and so
that's about the only amount that I use
is just I want them to both be
correlated. Okay. Um, don't Yeah, I've
tried to like I've tried to do that and
it just I I think it just over
complicates thing and just sometimes
it'll work and then other times, you
know, it's like you'll you'll get in
short on one thinking that it's more
bearish one and then it won't go down
very far and you know the one you were
going to get in on just like puked and
you're like, well, I could have been up
way more money if I just followed my
like read on the right market. Yeah,
seems like something to file away into
the potential factor that you could add
in that really is too complicated and
has a minor effect.
>> Yeah, I just think
>> or it's just going to have like
confirmation bias associated with it.
>> Yeah. It's just again I think it's just
one of those things that's tricking
yourself and to thinking you can figure
the market out.
>> Yeah. Rather than just sticking to the
like big principles and things that
matter more.
>> Yeah. Um I I guess a thing too to think
about that this trade was so a little
bit that I don't do all the time um is
to kind of walk through this recording
of the entry is usually like I would
jump in when it makes this big
candlestick and makes a new low here.
Like a lot of times a lot of the trades
I'll have this stop a stop order to get
in just sitting there and then when this
candle broke that I be in the trade. And
the reason why I did that on this one
was because it was so choppy, you know,
because I I didn't want to get like you
want to get in on momentum, but in the
market where it's like it's there's so
little momentum, it makes it more likely
that it does this the next candlestick,
you know, that this is just a a
unhealthy move over one candlestick and
so it's going to pull back and so
there's no point in, you know, baited
into the market.
>> Yeah. And then this is also a good spot
to where if the market was going to fake
lower and actually go higher, I think it
would have done it after that candle and
fake lower because it's barely making a
new low and then it would have been
like, okay, we baited people short and
now the market's going to go up. But if
that continues lower and keeps going
lower, then I think it's like, okay,
well, it's just it's just a slow bleed
of the big picture working out and it's
just this chop has to figure itself out.
And so then I put my stop below this low
that it made. Yeah, I think my my entry
was a tick or two lower is where I put
it.
>> Yeah, that was basically the reason why
I did that versus I think some other
trades it's um Yeah. Was there any other
questions about this trade like the
management or I mean even like where my
stop was like my stop was a lot of times
I say put your stop up here above the
high versus here. I wasn't really
thinking about my stop, but yeah. How
would how do you where are you trying to
place your stops?
>> Generally, I like to do it above the
swing, you know, with idea like, okay,
we're just making lower lows. It could
come up here and make another lower low.
And so, the trade's only invalid when it
breaks this right here. In this case,
I'm skirting the rules a little bit by
putting it here. But my thinking was,
you know, I think this is going to get
going and it's made this kind of move
here that is almost like a a little
minor lower high from this. And so just
my my reading on the market was that,
you know, I think if it's if it's going
to get going here, it's going to get
going. And also in the, you know, I
guess we talked about this a little last
week of trying not to do this too much,
but you know, if I put my stop all the
way up here, I'm going to have to take
two contracts and it's just going to
make my riskreward crappier.
>> Yeah, you're giving yourself lots of
room to play. But yeah, it's so high.
>> Yeah. And and my kind of thought was
like, okay, well, you know, we might
even be in in this kind of downtrend
right here. So, but you know, it it did
definitely room up for it could have
come up here, knocked me out, and then
gone lower. So
>> you know in the probability sense that's
a risk that I added on. Um but you know
my kind of read was that it was kind of
going to start working out
>> that yeah then can you talk about where
you how are you managing how you moved
your
>> the initial target you know is going to
be this right this news open cuz it's
like okay that's where the easy money is
that's the like that's the where this
unhealthy trend started. If the trend's
going to just like recover and become
healthy again that's initial target. So
that's what you know kind of this
support zone right here is. So that's
kind of like I'm thinking okay well at
least I want to see how it reacts to
that. Now one thing I did move my stop
down here once it made this big spike
lower and I saw it kind of like it
spiked lower here and pulled back really
fast. And so my thinking was, okay,
well, I can at least probably move my
stop down to here where this kind of
move started. Because if it comes down
here all the way and shoots all the way
back up here, I think it's so unlikely
that it then just reverses again. Like
at at that point, it's probably filled
this kind of gap that we're looking to
fill. Like it's gone most of that. And
so the risk is okay, the market comes
down here and just like, you know,
starts trending upwards, right? And it's
it's had its pullback that it needed.
And I'm, you know, I'm looking for a
deeper pullback and something that's
more than just a pullback.
>> But I didn't want to go to break even
yet because I think it totally could
have come up here, essentially retested
this support zone.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it could have come up somewhere
here, you know, even broken a little
higher and then gone lower. And so
that's why I didn't want to move to
break even yet cuz that that my stop
would have been too close to that zone.
Um, and it would have like retested the
bottoms of these candlesticks, you could
say, too. So, like that's why I didn't
do that yet. But when it essentially
made a double bottom here and retested
this low, then I moved it because it's
like, okay, if it comes down here, does
a double bottom and comes up, just get
me out. You know, there's no point in
risking any money on a trade at that
point. And it's it's still plenty of a
pull back to give it for if it's if it's
going to have some kind of pullback and
then continue the lower. So, you're
viewing that as a double bottom even
though it's all of two candles or like
or like or the candle is still forming.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. I'm just I'm not
necessarily viewing as though well the
thought is like if it does bottom here
and you know it bought like this
candlestick goes green and this
candlestick starts pushing up. It it's
getting into like the the smaller
picture as of for managing it. like as
I'm managing I'm looking more at that
stuff and and it's tricky cuz it's like
you don't want to overmanage it but it
was the why I did that was because we
had such a big move down here and so
like you can see that double bottom like
kind of starting and it almost gives
this back up and really like there could
have been a a world where it did come up
here and then kept going lower just to
retest this. So, like in hindsight,
maybe I moved my stop lower a little too
early. But my thought is because it
double bottomed here, that felt a little
spookier versus this initial candlestick
here had a pullback already to make it
more of a healthy move. But then it, you
know, then it it broke lower. And so
when it makes a new low like this and
breaks this low here, that's would be
that's my signal to move my stop down
below this low cuz it's essentially
confirming this swing here as a lower
high. when it breaks this low right
here.
>> Okay.
>> And so that's that's how I when it gets
to it, how I like to stair step pattern,
you know, my stops down if it's doing
that. And so as soon as it makes like a
new low right here, I'll move my stop
down. Makes a new low here, I'll move my
stop down to here.
>> Okay?
>> And so that's how I try and methodically
do it is like even though right here
it's at that minor support, right? It's
looking at a 5m minute. It's, you know,
it's or this is a 1 minute, but it's got
down to this spot right where I think
the trade could reverse. And so I'm not
moving my stop down yet cuz like, you
know, at this point I'm only up 1x and I
think there's a lot of more room to go
if it keeps going. And also there's kind
of this downtrend in play. It's more of
like a mental trailing stop of like,
okay, I'm gonna see how it reacts to
here and then maybe I'll move my stop
down a little bit to like just get out
and get some money. But like it's just,
you know, I'm just going to leave it
because it's, you know, I just want to
see how it develops. I'm expecting some
kind of pullback. And even here, you can
say, well, it's made this low, makes a
new low, it essentially comes up here,
tests that low, and then starts making a
new low as well. So, like, you know,
that's how it's [clears throat] like you
want to just have these areas in mind
and that's why it's like they're they're
micro areas where I'm not going to take
a trade off of, but like as I'm managing
it, I'm watching how the market's
reacting to them.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you can see I moved my stop
down here again below this little micro
swing we had as we kind of got going
again. And so, you know, then it's then
it kind of started to I think not yet
like at this point I'm still just like,
okay, I'm just using this trend line.
But then when it I think prints this
next candlestick, um I essentially
switch. Yeah, I switched to like, okay,
I got to be more aggressive. Like this
is starting to go unhealthy in the
downside direction. And so there's this
big bearish candlestick here. And so I
put my stop above there cuz like a lot
of times these big candlesticks, the
market won't break the high of them
unless it's going to reverse. Like even
this one right here, like this is a a
big bare candlestick where a big move
happened. And so you can put your stop
above this and you know it's like there
was a swing right here, but like this is
a great candle as an example. And then
this is a good candle as an example. And
then here it does the same thing of
another big candlestick. And so as it
closes, I actually moved it a little bit
before. Um, and the reason why I did
that is because it it broke the previous
candle's low and it was I mean it was a
big candlestick right here already. So,
like my thought is like, okay, if it if
it ends up like coming back in the
candle, I'll just get out cuz we're
getting down to the major support zone.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, if I just pull it up from where that
is, that's like Oh, no. One minute
still. That's these I'll just do a five
minute way simpler. Like here, it's
basically these two major swings from
the overnight, right? And so as we kind
of come down to there, I'm going to
think, okay, we're we could totally
reverse, right? Same thing like treating
this as a spot where I'm not going to
take a trade and bet long after this,
but like I'm going to assume that this
momentum that it's going in is going to
dry up because it's so fast. And then
it's it's kind of just like repeating
that of like, okay, it just and even
this candlestick, I moved it down to the
high, but because it was such a big
candlestick and it's kind of just down
here still that I'm okay moving it down
to the high of that. um if that makes
sense. And then cuz like the candlestick
starts to just kind of get kind of huge.
Same thing with this one is it just kind
of broke a new low and it kind of got
going. So I moved the stop down again
and then eventually it just kind of you
know one of the candles prints green and
especially at this point is that's why
it's like I switch from doing this using
the trend line because if I have to wait
for it to come all the way up to the
trend line that's a lot of space. Yeah.
>> You're giving this whole move back up.
Yeah. And it's like I would I would lose
like $3,000 I think. Like at the most I
was up over like 6K on this trade. And
definitely if I just reverse like to
move all the way back up to here if
that's where I was waiting for. It's
like I would have been up I would have
only gained like 3K.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's why you got to like cut to
like a trailing stop. And it's like you
leave you do leave money potentially on
the table. Um, you know, I think if we
if we look at this in hindsight of what
it ended up doing is like it it had that
one candlestick and then it kept going
for a little while eventually to bottom,
but like you know that would have that
there's definitely money left on the
table, but you know, if you think about
it big picture, right, the strategy is
you're not trying to capture the exact
high to the exact low. Like that's just
impossible, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> For this trade, it's like, okay, I did I
I didn't capture I got out here. I
didn't capture this part of the move and
I got in what? Right here. So, I'm
literally capturing like onethird of the
move. Like that's pretty much all I
caught like from entry to exit.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's like that's the easy money.
Like it's way easier to wait for this
confirmation than trying to aggressively
get in up here because so often you'll
be wrong versus just waiting for this
really super clear confirmation and then
getting out when it shows any token of
resistance because a lot of time this
could easily turn into where the thing
just rips up, you know?
>> Yeah. And a lot of the times, honestly,
a lot of the times looking back at my
trades, this will be the bottom right
here, and there won't be this extra. And
so, it'll look a lot better to where
it's like, oh, instead of, you know,
capturing a third like this, it's like
the the trades more like this, and you
know, I'm capturing from here to here.
And so, it's like I'm capturing 50% of
the moon. You know, it's like it's
always going to be slightly different,
but it's like you don't need to don't be
focused on trying to capture everything
because it's going to make it to where
you have to be too loose or too
aggressive in certain spots where it's
just not going to work out.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think in some ways I got
for how cuz I ended up getting out
essentially
right after it forms that first big
white one going up. That's what knocked
me out.
>> This one or this one?
>> No, no. All the way down. Oh,
>> okay.
>> That
>> like this one. Um, two two or three to
the left. Yeah, that first one. That
one. Yeah.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And I think some of it was just like I
obviously don't know what constitutes
necessarily a big move. And like I guess
a lot of what we've been watching or
I've been watching is where it's super
seems like it's doing really big moves
and very volatile. And so I was like,
"Okay, it's it's done its first little
those first two spots where it kind of
like stair steps up and then keeps going
and stair steps up and keeps going
around 10:00 a.m." And so then when it
did that next one at 10:15, I was like,
"Okay, stair steps up and then keeps
going a little bit." And then I moved my
stop down, I think, just above there. So
it was way less active management.
>> Mhm.
>> And then I think when I got towards the
bottom, I was like, "Okay, it's getting
close to really big resistance level and
it's losing a lot of momentum. I'll put
a stop down there."
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean that makes sense.
>> I think part of that's just like in some
ways got lucky and was way less actively
managing it. [laughter]
>> So,
>> well, I mean like when you don't
actually have a trade on it, it's a lot.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Way easier to just kind of
sit and let a watch
>> sit and let it do its thing rather than
>> it'll be fine versus versus seeing that
one candlestick pullback be a $1,000.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
>> but it was also interesting. I guess one
of the things I thinking about that
candlestick as well is like it doesn't
seem
>> this way.
>> Yeah. It doesn't seem especially out of
the ordinary when you're looking at the
size of the other candles. And so I
guess in part of my thought was like and
obviously I wasn't I wasn't really
looking at dollars and saying, "Oh, this
is a $1,000 move or whatever, but it was
just like, okay, it's roughly the size
of some of the other candles that the
market's been moving. So it doesn't seem
like relatively too high or relatively
too big of a signal.
>> Yeah. I don't think it was necessarily
it's like oh this is a big signal. Um I
think it's just more of the way I'm
doing it is I'm just saying hey it's
just printed so many bearish
candlesticks in a row.
>> Yeah.
>> If we're getting a spot where it could
bottom and just print all those candles.
Yeah. I mean, like even just thinking
about what Friday, you know, that we
haven't talked about yet, but that day
where it's super choppy, like here, just
so many bearish candlesticks and
obviously it's not trending, but like
out out of nowhere it just kind of did
that and then all of a sudden the next
candlesticks are boom, it's just the
other way.
>> Yeah.
>> And so you just risk you're just risking
and and like you could have a rule and
I've done this before. I don't think um
it kind of depends for me where it is in
the cycle, but it's you can be having um
you know, you could just have a mental
stop of like, hey, like I'm going to see
how this candlestick develops and then
see what the next candlestick does. You
know, like in the sense of like, okay,
it prints a big bullish candlestick, but
is that it? You know, is it just going
to do this and fall over? Right? The
problem is again you risk though that
okay this candlestick finishes forming
you put your stop above it and
technically I think if you put your stop
above the high of this candlestick it
would have got knocked out. So like
>> you're doing it one tick.
>> Yeah. And you're and you're just leaving
again a lot of risk versus like it could
just do this and then like we we just
looked at it could just print another
huge bullish candlestick and then you're
like oh [__] there goes my trade.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is obviously content
I haven't watched or gotten into on your
course, but how when you're managing it
down like you're talking about there,
how much wiggle room are you giving it
off of an individual candle? Is it just
like one tick and you're done? Or is it
like, okay, three ticks or two ticks?
>> It's just I just do Yeah. one tick off
the high. I mean, like it it's
especially in this size of a market,
it's not going to make a difference most
likely.
>> Yeah. Like
>> it's just making it's just moving.
>> Yeah. Like you could have it you could
have it here like you could have it like
oh at the open of this candlestick but
it's just like if it gets up here it's
probably going to you know just blip you
out. I I just do one tick above the high
cuz it's just like okay that's just like
a a break of the candlestick and it's
just like a logical spot. But I think
you know three ticks are like oh you
know at the high of the candlestick like
it's I don't think it's a little bit of
personal preference.
>> Yeah. But again like I don't think it's
going to make a big difference. Like if
it's going to break it it's going to
break it. And like, you know, you could
get lucky once in a blue moon where, you
know, oh, like here, if I had mine one
tick above the candlestick, it would
have got knocked out. But if you had
yours three ticks, you would have been
fine, you know, like
>> Yeah,
>> that's good.
>> Yeah. Which is I mean, which is roughly
what happened there.
>> Yeah. And you know, it's like, okay,
well, that plays out once in a blue
moon, but then like the other 80 times
where you're you just take more of a
loss, you know, on the three extra ticks
or two extra ticks.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. Um, do you want
to talk about Friday, this just choppy
day real quick? Cuz it was kind of
crazy. Um,
>> I do. Give me a couple minutes though.
Yeah, I'll be back in like 3 or 4
minutes.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Yeah. One of the things I had down
on my notes for this day at the
beginning of the day and you're starting
to trade. How do you think about the
overnight highs and the lows? Cuz I've
seen you reference them a couple of time
in in your like morning
>> Yeah.
>> summary and levels setting. um or are
they are they just kind of like a point
of interest? Is there kind of like a
common behavior for the market around
them?
>> Looking at a 15-minute chart of this day
is when the market opens up like here
kind of in the middle, you know, it's
the the major lows down here, the next
major resistance here, and the highs are
all the way up here. Um,
I like to look at them as like here's
like I mean this day is just kind of
shitty like there's there's no we're
just kind of in this I think what I was
looking at in this day was like okay
we've have you know there's maybe a down
I'm trying to look at like okay maybe
there's a downwards support zone here
like the market's clearly trending in
some funky and so I think when the
market kind of I think it let's see 9:30
right here like it basically opens up
here I'm thinking well okay well there's
also like kind kind of two swings right
here. Maybe I can draw a resistance
level here off of these highs, but like
they're just minor. And then here, you
can definitely start to make like a kind
of a support zone.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I I think of them as like they're not
a major zone because, you know, it's
it's from just literally overnight
action. It's not like the market's been
bouncing along it for multiple days
like, you know, we had up here, right?
>> Yeah. So yeah, it's like it's the first
point of defense like so those are you
know these are those zones and then
looking at a one minute chart okay the
market opens here I'm thinking okay well
if the market's opening here and this is
kind of an interesting high especially
extreme you know you will t have times
where it's like it'll even if it's a
small zone and like the market's going
to move a lot throughout the day it's
it's a spot where the market could come
up here and break this and then trend
down for the rest of the today. So, it's
almost like they're good entry spots for
potential reversals to where, you know,
the market just tests it and is like,
"Nope, we're bearish today or nope,
we're bullish today and we're going to
push up higher." And you can, you know,
get in the lows and capture the move of
the day versus, you know, otherwise
there's just there's just nothing to
look at. You know, it's kind of hard
when it's like, "Oh, well, what about
this level right here or this level?"
And, you know, this
>> I mean, this zone kind of lines up with
that. And you can also even say like
well this high actually if you draw it
lines up with the close of yesterday you
know our white line here. Um so it's
like again it's like try not to read
into like oh how many of these do I
take? But like but also seeing okay well
this is a potential spot for that. With
that in mind you need everything else to
line up to take a trade too. like I need
it to just flush down into here, you
know, do a double bottom or some kind of
like retest or attempt to break lower
that fails versus it bottoming here and
then me just being like, "Okay, well,
here we're at the support. I'm just
going to buy in blindly and capture like
a Vbottom, which is um, you know, kind
of what it ended up doing, right?" Cuz
it breaks here, but then immediately
just like, "Okay, I can't do anything
with that. That's not tradable."
>> Yeah.
>> Like if you get in here, like the move's
already basically halfway done. like
your riskreward is horrible. Um, you
know, you get down here, it's like
you're just that's just a a gamble.
>> You have no idea. Yeah.
>> Um, so it's like like I would have taken
a long here if it did like a second
bottom and then made it better. But
>> yeah, kind of reinforced the signal that
that was that that level was had some
additional strength to it.
>> Yeah. Versus Yeah. I mean like this
candlestick was also like 20 points
which is big. And then and then it comes
up here and it's like okay well what
about if it decides to do that on the
flip side like it could because this was
a crazy move. I could see this move
getting reversed even though it's like
well it gave this move back up. This was
so crazy like it totally could but then
it kind of it just it just did the same
thing like it just went down in two
massive bars and then here it basically
started bouncing off the middle of the
range. um which to me is like a big chop
signal or or or a thought is it's a
basically a 50% pullback of this move.
If I draw this as just a Fibonacci tool
and take the low and take this high,
halfway between them is here.
>> And so it's bouncing off 50% basically a
50% pullback of this move up. It pulls
back 50%. That's as as well as another
thing that's like a very good indicator
of a potential healthy pullback spot.
And so that was just another spot like
you know you can just do that in your
head you know it be like oh well this is
kind of you know halfway between these
two it's somewhere there.
>> Um and so especially with just how it
was like so funky like that. Um in my
mind I've seen this so many times I just
immediately went to especially with how
the overnight action was. It was choppy
and then the pre-market action where it
started moving a little bit more it was
choppy. This is just larger chop. And so
my thought was like, okay, it's probably
just gonna go into chop. And I actually
I think I think here or like I don't
know after maybe after this candlestick,
I don't remember. I called it pretty
quick.
>> Yeah, you called it.
>> This isn't going
>> like I'm done. We get by.
>> Yeah. Everyone just stayed around for a
little bit longer. But you can see it
pretty much just did that.
>> I think somewhere in here I was drawing
kind of a Yeah. This type of thing.
>> Yeah. Wedge.
>> And I was like, "Oh, that's cool. I
haven't seen something like that
before." And then of course you have the
the thought of like well it seems like
it's moving in on like it can't decide
which direction wants to go. Is it going
to hit that and then shoot out in one
direction like
>> yeah like do a big breakout and just
like okay now it's going to keep going.
That's a big thing that I don't use. I
just I usually just am like oh it's in a
wedge that means it's choppy. because so
often that yeah you think oh it's going
to break this imaginary line I'm making
in my head and then it's going to just
explode out of nowhere and it sounds
ridiculous when you say it but like
that's how a lot of people trade and
well I mean that's how I trade too in a
lot of ways but like to me it's like
it's it's it's choppy here and so why
would it change?
>> You use real imaginary lines Riley.
Yeah, mine mine or mine are the correct
one.
>> But yeah, then I think I I think I saw
it do that and it comes back and kind of
crosses at the tip of the wedge. I was
like, "All right,
>> okay. Stopping and it's like it does
eventually go somewhere, but like you
know
>> it slowly trends up, but yeah."
>> Yeah. Like often I'll just be like,
"Okay, it's just going to if it does
break this, it might just slowly chug
away, right?" But like again, like
sticking to our strategy, yeah, like it
slowly trends throughout the day and
like if you did buy here and somehow
held like you would have got a big move.
It would have taken you hours, which
would have been excruciating if you held
through all these volatile pullbacks,
which probably not. It's Yeah, it's like
it's, you know, we're sticking to this
first 30 minutes, and if it doesn't do
what we want, you just move on. Like
that's that's at the end of the day,
right? Like that's for me like why I
left so early here because in my
experience when it starts doing this and
I'm seeing that it's choppy for me to
like even consider a trade it would
somehow have to do a huge move in one
direction and then hit a level and make
a clean double bottom but like at that
point it would be too late in the day
like the timing and and just for my like
morning quick reversal move it's like
it's just not going to happen. And so I
just as soon as I can tell that that's
the case, I'm just going to move on.
Like there's no point in, you know, oh,
being like, well, I'm gonna wait till,
you know, 10 o'clock or 10:05, you know,
because that's when I'm going to stop
and when, you know, I can take trades at
that time if it sets up. But like you
can tell right here that that's not
going to happen today. And so it's like
why waste time watching, you know, paint
dry, you I also think it's really easy
to like looking at this and then seeing
it kind of shoot out the one side or
then trend upwards to be like, "Oh, hey,
it did that one thing last time." So,
next time I see something like that,
I'll try and take a trade off of that
thing that I saw one time. Like, it
feels really really easy to put in
trades that work and make make decisions
for like, oh, hey, last time I saw it do
this, it did that. and just try and do
that off of something like this even
though it has like no statistical
relevance or like
>> Yeah.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I mean, I think that's just at the
end of the day, the constant fight you
you have to do, especially when you
start out of your brain just wanting to
over complicate and add more things.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, that's so confirmation
bias of like, oh, well, I saw it.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, like especially here, it's
like, oh, well, the the the market did a
crazy bottom here. If I bought at this
low, you know, I would have made 4x in 3
minutes, you know, like what a rush
would that be. Like that would have been
crazy. I would never I've never had a
trade like that. And it's like, you
know, you go and do it and the market
just, you know, instead it just like
pops up here and then lower. Like
>> it's always one of those things of like
it's always going to do the if you're
trying to trade like that, it's always
going to do the opposite. And that's I
think how you get those times where
people are like, "Oh, my lot my win rate
is like if I just reverse the the my
trades and trade the opposite of what I
think, I would actually make money." And
it's like that's cuz you're trading like
that.
>> Yeah. You're flipping coins.
>> Yeah. and doing it in like a weird
emotional way that somehow has a very
good way of consistently losing.
>> Sticking to the very defined time limit
or the limited time limit of like, okay,
you're trading for an hour and a half or
whatever all said and done of sticking
to that or being like, oh, it's doesn't
look like it's setting up. Okay, I'll
call it. But having such a defined time
limit helps so much to like stay focused
and be able to stick to trying to do one
pattern and looking for one set of
things to stick like to set up. Cuz I
think if I was trying to do this for way
longer in the day like 3 hours or 6
hours or whatever, I would just start to
invent things for me to look for or to
see just cuz you're doing it for so much
longer.
>> Yeah. I think that something that comes
into my mind when you say that is you're
instead of approaching it like you're
trying to make money. You're approaching
it like you're trying to execute a
specific strategy. And so you're not
even like focused on the money in the
sense is your whole focus of trading,
which is how it should be. Like your
whole focus of trading should be how I
can be process focused and execute my
specific strategy and not about the
money. Like it's not about oh if I you
know because otherwise if you focus on
the money it's so easy to be like oh
well I would have made money today if I
bought here or did this or did that and
you know the next day that doesn't work
versus you know like this it's like I am
focusing on executing a specific
strategy I don't know when it's going to
show up but when it does I consistently
make money.
>> It's like a bonus thing. It's like
instead of being like okay I'm have to
make money off of this. I am looking for
this and trying to make money every day
off of this. It is a like, all right,
I'm just waking up an hour and a half
earlier than I would have normally waken
up, and I'll see if this thing shows up,
and if it shows up, I get a nice bonus
and some extra money, but if it doesn't,
like, oh well, I just move on with my
day like I normally would.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and thinking of it as like, oh, it's
a nice thing that appeared versus like
I'm grinding to try and get this to
work.
>> Yeah. Cuz that like just puts, you know,
again, puts pressure on you to find
trades and trying to force trades
doesn't work. Yeah. I mean I would say
like thinking about this last week like
this is you know pretty I would say
pretty typical of of trying to just
zooming this on a five minute to like
make it easier to scroll through but
like you know Friday it was just choppy
there's nothing the next day Thursday
it's like the market opened up here and
just went lower a tiny bit chopped and
then just puked and so no trade that day
either. Yeah, I saw that and I was
wondering if um there was some Oh, I
guess Wait, wait, wait. On that chart,
it looked really good on the five minute
>> on the five minute. I wouldn't say there
was a way to get in on this.
>> Yeah, I in some ways I was looking at it
and I was thinking about the setup from
the day before.
>> Yeah, I I can see that it kind of
opened, sold off a little bit, and then
made some kind of like high higher lower
high here and then just puked.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, in a way that's very similar to
the day before. Yeah. Um,
>> and I think maybe it was in my mind cuz
the day before we'd seen something like
that where it kind of like it almost
looks like it has a like I don't know
what is that 8:30 or so comes and forms
a little Yeah. forms that little top and
then kind of retests it and then
>> starts dropping off and then has that
shoulder there.
>> I would say the biggest thing of why I
didn't even think about that here is
just scrolling out. It's in the middle
of the range. Like if you just drag
these across it's just in the center of
the range. Why would it not just
continue doing this? You know,
>> one of my questions was like, was there
something there or was there a way to
get into this cuz it has like part of
the setups, but also Yeah. like it
wasn't really at an actual zone.
>> Yeah. And that's why it's like, you
know, that's definitely a dangerous part
of trading of like hindsight. It's like
you start to think, oh, how could I have
caught that? You know, but that would
then put you at the risk of like, okay,
well, I'm going to take trades in the
middle of the range away from, you know,
the number one step in our strategy is
you're skipping step one, which is like
the most important step, and then that
would just open, if you skip that step,
opens the door for so many like bad
spots and you know, the once in a blue
moon where you get this crazy move out
of nowhere. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So yeah, no trade that day and
then the day before was like a good
trade and then the day before that it
was a chopfest as well, which I would
say is a pretty standard week of like
having one or two trades at the most
just because of you know you there's so
many other options for the market to do
and a lot of the times it likes to chop.
>> Yeah. There's a lot of behaviors and
it's got to cycle through them like
>> Yeah. And then it has to, you know, even
if it does something that like a good
move, it has to line up with our other
things. And you know, that's just that's
kind of just how the strategy works. And
um you know, you're not going to make
money every day, but the idea is over
time you're going to make money even if
it's like, okay, you don't take a trade
for a week.
>> The key thing always seems like it's not
about taking more trades. It's just
about making sure the ones you're taking
are correct and then you can scale up
those trades.
>> Yeah. Yeah, because it's like, oh, if
you take one trade a month, but you make
$10,000 on the one trade, like that's
pretty good.
>> Who gives a [__]
>> Yeah. Well, who cares how many Like, it
might be hard to sit there that long,
but like at the end of the day, you're
here to make money, and if you make the
money, who cares how you do it?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's such an important thing.
It's Yeah. that like mindset of it's as
long as the one thing happens and you
can capitalize on that one thing, you
don't need to be functioning on like oh
I need to make x number of trades an
hour.
>> Yeah.
>> There's no like there's no there's no
like hourly rate.
>> No. And and I mean like sure maybe you
could make that like you could calculate
that for fun eventually, but like at the
end of the day it's like and that's the
hardest part about I think when you
start out is if you wait a whole week to
take one trade and you make a $100 on
that trade, you know, you're starting to
think, oh well, I just spent all that
time and I made a hundred bucks, you
know, like especially if you traded like
five hours a day or something or you
watched for five hours a day. It's like,
well, that's one reason why I like to do
it short and sweet cuz, you know, it's
like quite often if it's like if it's
choppy the first 30 minutes, it's going
to be crappy the rest of the day.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, like, you know, it saves you
that heartache, too. But, you know, just
trying not to think about it as the
money initially and just focusing on the
process. And again, like in your mind,
just think about, well, if I made a $100
doing this, just adding two zeros is
just a matter of time.
>> Yeah. And obviously like that'll take a
while because scaling up slowly to get
there takes a while. But like you know
it just takes time to get there. And you
know the strategy at bottom line is like
if you can make $100 trading a strategy
consistently, you can make $10,000
trading a strategy consistently.